Mh.
so da bin ich ich habe noch gearbeitet bis 1530 und habe jetzt noch eine runde sport gemacht
massive schwitzt champ aber ich muss mein mikro runter stellen teams hat wieder dran
rum gewurstet ich sehe es schon teams keck weight aller richtiger keck weight
ich bewege mich sport genug kannst du schon über das spiel reden ja und nein also die
nda ist um 17 uhr 10 vorbei vorher darf ich nichts konkretes sagen squash squash habe ich schon eine
ganze weile nicht mehr gespielt da war ich auch nie sonderlich gut aber da ist man echt übelst
ins schwitzen gekommen ich habe mich nicht in der zeitzone vertan ich habe extra nachgeguckt
am besten du sagst einfach nix ich darf nix sagen zum gelben
soll man kurz musik ein bisschen leiser machen
also den offiziellen livestream der ist halt nicht sonderlich spannend aktuell
der offizielle livestream deswegen schwitzen wir vorher noch ein bisschen wir können den ja
wir können den ja irgendwie hier so ich kann ihn ja so ein planten das probieren wir das probieren
mal aus ich probiere ich blende das ich blende das ist einfach mal hier oben ein capture gucken
ob das überhaupt funktioniert ich glaube das geht nämlich ich glaube man kann capture capture
window bf ich glaube man kann das gar nicht capturen ach doch anik chromium kann ich
capturen chrome nicht so rum war es genau weil chrome hardware beschleunigt ist und da geht
das nicht so jetzt mal schnippeln kurz wie ging das jetzt noch mal sack ich kann mir die die also
genau die shortcuts nicht merken für oben ist eigentlich können wir das noch ein bisschen
kleiner machen einfach so machen wir die urzeit hier oben hin und gut ist oder reicht doch ich
wusste das gerade meiner forscher angucken ist glaube ich durchaus in ordnung leute danke für
die ganzen subs ich habe übrigens wer es noch nicht mitbekriegt hat ich habe den copyright
strike bekommen für meinen apple stream letztens weil apple wohl der einzige laden ist in 2021
interessiert ob public events gestreamt werden was ziemlich sagt kannst du schon sagen ob es
skill-based matchmaking geben wird nein kann ich nicht sagen das liegt daran ich weiß es
schlicht und ergreifend nicht ich habe es versucht rauszubekommen aber man weiß es nicht nein ich
weiß es nicht was muss ich chrome im focus behalten keck-keck-wait
geht das jetzt wieder muss ich das echt im focus behalten ist das jetzt euer ernst
oh meine güte ist das schlecht keck-keck-weh alter ist das schlecht ist das schlecht ernsthaft
ne jetzt geht's aber den darf ich nicht raubt moment wartet mal wartet mal wartet mal sack
darf ich das im anderen chrome aufmachen ist das dann ok das liegt bestimmt an den tabs
das liegt das liegt an den tabs wow wow wow ii weit sieben geh weg ah moment moment dunkel
ah jetzt hoi hoi hoi war klaus klaus kahl alter man ist es schlecht warum
warum darf ich das in vordergrund machen und das geht aber in chrome fenster darf ich nicht
was ist das denn siehst du wir kämpfen wir kämpfen erst mal die erste zeit mit ubs easy
kein problem mal gucken vielleicht geht es mit firefox ich mache es jetzt mal in firefox
warum ist es immer so keck-wait gemacht alles
huge keck-wait gebel field chrome firefox so geht das jetzt wenn ich zu mache das scheint
zu funktionieren wenn ich zumachen na das geht ok nice um nicht zu sagen excellent
firefox geht big brain tactics hier heute nicht gesponsert von hetzner die lasse ich
heute raus so wunderbar dann kann ich ja eigentlich auch den anderen kram wieder
im chrome aufmachen oder besser besser so ist perfekt ja leute auf geht's ich habe
keine ahnung warum das rumspat mit dem overlay aber soll mir recht sein probier doch sonst
firefox pipp was ist denn firefox ach picture in picture das so moderne features kann ich
nicht verwenden da bin ich zu alt für sowas sowas kommt mir nicht in die tüte picture
in picture also das gab es noch nicht zu meiner geburt das geht jetzt auch nicht du hörst
dich heute so anders an ich mich heute anders an eigentlich sollte ich mich heute wieder
ok ich habe grad sport gemacht direkt davor ich bin jetzt ich bin jetzt wach was ich
sonst nicht bin aber ansonsten sollte sich eigentlich alles gleich anhören oder ich
auch in meiner forschung höre ich mich relativ ähnlich an ich glaube normalerweise rede
ich halt eher so in der richtung bin ich ein bisschen entspannter und schreien ich so
rum ist aber höre ich mich großartig anders an das teste ich jetzt mal seck seck das
muss ich mir jetzt mal anhören ich mich großartig anders anhören machst du dann squat stream
ich weiß nicht ob wir squat stream wir labern aber dann zusammen erst mal erst mal werbung
angucken erst mal eigene werbung angucken exzellent dankeschön immer w player genau
danke für die ganzen subs leute der baumi ist auch am start barni ist da 905 der martin
22 monate hypersubs subscription dankeschön der mark ist auch am start defs el gero an
hier war schon vorgestern aber danke für die subs leute so höre ich mich anders an
ich höre mich ich höre mich an wie immer es usual höre ich mich an nur noch 21 minuten
bis zur enttäuschung leute eine sache kann ich sagen ohne scheiß ohne spaß jetzt ohne
spaß ich glaube ihr werdet begeistert sein also für ich kann sagen jeder also ihr kennt
mich ich habe im vorfeld auch gesagt die müssen mich erst mal überzeugen und ich habe immer
noch keine ahnung wie sie spielt ich habe das game noch nicht gespielt oder sowas in
der richtung aber ich habe schon ich habe halt schon ein bisschen mehr gesehen also im
prinzip das was ihr jetzt seht das kenne ich schon und ich kann kann euch ehrlich sagen
ich habe am anfang bin ich da so mit gemischten gefühlen reingegangen weil ich mir gedacht
habe ob das was wird aber nachdem ich den trailer eine ganze scheiß gesehen habe leute
ich habe echt gesagt ich habe ich habe echt war richtig hab ich habe halb ich will ich
will nicht übertreiben ich habe nicht geheult oder so ja ich hatte aber ein wenig und das
sagen wir ich habe mit dem lost ja auch schon video aufgenommen das kommt dann 17.10 oder
so auf youtube on also wir haben wir haben gesagt also wir haben nicht geheult aber wir hatten
doch schon leicht feuchte augen als wir manche szenen im trailer gesehen haben ja dazu wie
das spiel heißen wird kann ich nichts zu sagen richtig lost ja so ich muss jetzt noch mal
schnell in meine mails gucken nicht dass da noch irgendwelche auf sachen auf den letzten
drücker gekommen ist der battlefield 1 trailer war auch mega geil nein ich fand den battlefield
1 trailer nicht gut ich war damals live vor ort in berlin und hab mir gedacht ea ist ja
auch geil the fuck ea schickt mir jetzt irgendwelche battlefield bildchen die ich für mein video
gebraucht hätte vor vier tagen also es ist bisschen bisschen spät vielleicht jetzt
genau das gleiche null aber ich habe die ja glücklicherweise schon alle also leute ich
versuche mal kurz die questions soweit zu banten wie ich hinkomme wann kommt der trailer
ach so moment den trailer kann ich ja auch schon aufmachen weil aus irgendwelchen gründen
will uns battlefield jebaiden jebaiden wollen die uns nämlich die haben nämlich zwei verschiedene
streams die haben die wollen den jebaid song singen die haben ich muss aufhören dass ich
kein kein inhalte aus der mail mit kopiere warte mal wo ist denn jetzt wo wo hat der
kelter jetzt das geschickt coverage ach hier da ist er countdown to reveal trailer den
habe ich auch und der reveal trailer der wird dann hier sein ok ich habe ich habe ich habe
reveal trailer stream link schon mal geliegt hier 35 minuten leute in 35 minuten gehts
los das ist witzig die haben den countdown die haben den countdown und und den eigenen
reveal trailer stream ich weiß nicht warum ich hoffe dass sie hier den trailer zeigen
ehrlich gesagt weil ansonsten muss ich dann hier umschalten oder so also ich versuche
noch mal ein paar sachen zu beantworten jetzt halt nicht zu dem game nicht direkt zumindest
so man wird zum anderen wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich alles klar das ist gut zu wissen na dann was
ist das für einen subsound ganz neuer ich habe den standard subsound den standard subsound
aber das was ihr hört im hintergrund ist bad company 2 game also fand ich durchaus auch
ok das weiß ich nicht
das ist ich weiß es nicht es ist auf jeden fall mindestens der trailer der heute kommt
mindestens der trailer vielleicht machen die auch noch irgendwie eine show drum herum ich
habe keine ahnung also was ihr geplant hat weiß ich nicht außer dass ich den kram schon
mal vorher gesehen habe loot boxen so man man weiß es nicht also besser gesagt ich darf
das das darf ich um 17 uhr 10 beantworten ja bei strike weil battlefield halb stells
angesagt ist ja die frage die kam warum ich das schon sehen durfte ist ganz einfach zu
beantworten battlefield also ei oder da ist oder wer auch immer da wie genau umfangen
die haben ein paar leute vor einer weile schon eingeladen vor einer woche ungefähr und man
durfte sich das angucken ich muss immer überlegen was ich sagen darf und was nicht also ich
kenne den reveal trailer schon und ich kenne sogar noch mehr ich kenne sogar noch gameplay
trailer und da gab es noch eine q&a session wo man sachen fragen kann aber da kann ich
nichts zu sagen erst ab 17 uhr 10 hoffentlich geht der trailer mal zwei minuten oder länger
ja wie gesagt ich glaube zwar nicht dass ich gestrikt werde wenn ich die trailerlänge
aber ich glaube es war ein bisschen länger immerhin aus dem discord das bullshit bingo
aktualisiert ich glaube das brauchen wir nicht ich vermute das wird keine große show
geben wie zu das ist top top bullshit bingo alter so muss das sein ich glaube das werden
wir nicht brauchen ich denke mal nicht dass es so lang ist genau pinsel zweimal wenn
du was verraten darfst der dark reader verkackt echt moment ich mache den dark reader aus
achtung achte jetzt noch mal mit dark reader kann man solche dinge überschätzt hab kostenlos
hausen ja du kannst github github pages sides wie heißt in der kram ich dachte da kommt
jetzt eine emote oder sowas als gif das kann sein dass ich kurz bevor es losgeht noch mal
ganz schnell jutsch jutsch kackers machen muss weil immer wenn ich sport gemacht habe
muss danach aufs klo ich war jetzt nicht auf dem klo bin direkt an rechner gestellt direkt
hierhin gesprintet was hast du denn zu befürchten wenn du es ausplauderst von von strikes bis
zu post vom anwalt keine ahnung ich will es auch nicht ausprobieren was hast du gemacht
ich hab mich bewegt monka es mit headset ja wenn ich aufs klo gehe dann habe ich ja immer
den chat auf damit ihr immer top aktuell informiert was so abgeht ich bäde dann immer
ein bisschen im chat vom klo aus weil es mir da eh langweilig ist leute wir können ja
mal eine sache machen ich darf zwar noch ich darf zwar noch nicht sagen aber was mich
jetzt mal interessieren würde was erwartet ihr wenn ihr also was habt ihr für erwartung
an das game beziehungsweise was würdet ihr euch wünschen kann einfach mal irgendwie
es kann ja mal jeder so das erste was ihm in kopf kommt zu battlefield 6 schreiben ich
kann euch auch noch mal sagen was ich dachte bevor ich es gesehen habe ich dachte ganz
ehrlich ich lasse mich nicht hypen ich lasse es komplett auf mich zukommen und ich war
nicht sonderlich überzeugt nach battlefield eins und battlefield fünf und ich dachte
mir die müssen mich jetzt erstmal wieder überzeugen und das müssen sie immer noch
also ich werde auch nach wie vor nicht preordern oder sowas die müssen die müssen mich jetzt
nach zwei verkackten games überzeugen das sehe ich im prinzip immer noch so aber nachdem
ich den reveal trailer gesehen habe würde ich sagen der erste schritt ist gemacht aber
ich sehe selbst dann 17 uhr i get fucked over i get fucked up in the ass over hier genau
das muss unbedingt wieder rein linux support das wirds nicht geben also ich weiß es nicht
aber es wird mich äußerst wundern wenn es linux support gibt wer weiß wer weiß autolock
und bullshit solides map design das wird sich glaube ich erst bei einer beta oder so zeigen
battlefield red strains ich muss euch ehrlich sagen dass also so geil ihr wisst dass ich
es geil finde mit battlefield 3 und und riesen wiederbelebungs kram und sowas aber ich muss
sagen ich glaube man muss nicht unbedingt den battlefield 3 reds revive defi kram machen
ich glaube es reicht zu einem zwischending man muss es auch nicht so lahm machen wie
nachher aber es wäre zum beispiel eine gute kombination dass jeder wiederbeleben kann
das finde ich prinzipiel ganz gut in den neuen battlefields aber dass der medic halt machen
könnte das fände ich nice wobei es dann halt wieder noch mehr revive spam ist mal gucken
mal gucken mal gucken da weiß ich tatsächlich schon so ein bisschen was aber da kann ich
nachher was zu sagen merkt euch das mal was ihr wissen wollt das könnt ihr mich danach
17 oder 10 fragen wenn wir den trailer gesehen haben wie wohl und dankeschön für den zap
ich könnte mir mal ein paar fragen für später aufschreiben leute das machen wir jetzt
das waren wir jetzt ich schreibe mir mal ein paar fragen von euch auf die kann ich danach
haben im lost beantworten also die erste frage war wir machen wir machen das jetzt mal machen
hier coach also also dass das mal jetzt ist eine gute idee bf 6 questions und ein habe
ich geleakt oder auch nicht man weiß nicht also gibt's medic train wie in bf 3 das ist
eine gute frage was haben wir noch für fragen ich habe performance habe ich gelesen ok weiß
ich ob ich da viel zu sagen hat ja was war mit maps wird's rush geben war eine frage
ok gibt's auto lock on war auch noch eine frage ok gibt's gibt's sb mm gibt's loot box also
ich kann zu den meisten sachen die ihr da fragt was sagen aber natürlich nicht zu allen
eigenen server fragezeichen br zum start ja haut immer revolution oder so ne map zerstörung
fragezeichen fragen für ab 17 uhr 10 10 wird's cross play geben ja gute frage
weiter effekte wird's welche geben gute frage ja customserver habe ich schon aufgeschrieben
map design müssen wir ein bisschen spezifischer fragen das akenas das ist eine äußerst gute
frage fahrzeug spawn oder direkt rein spawnen fahrzeug einsteigen oder direkt rein spawn
fragezeichen ja gute frage schiffe panzer flugzeuge was gibt's alles gute frage ex ex
quesit 5 hat 6 6 hat mega hat frage mega hat bräuchten wir haben 5 hat wir haben 6
hat mega hat wird's 120 player geben also helis ja helis hier was haben wir noch hi fat
menschen genau sehr spezifisch aber vielleicht habe ich ja noch was davon gehört
waffenarten ok gibt es teammates born protection also leute ihr könnt natürlich so spezifische
sachen stellen aber ihr müsst wissen das war jetzt auch kein kein fünftage event dass
ich jetzt irgendwie bei dice den source code gelesen habe oder so ne also ich weiß da mittlerweile
schon ein bisschen was drüber bei das game aber jetzt ihr könnt mich jetzt nicht fragen
benutzt die studio oder oder was anderes spielmodi könnte man fragen ja
ja
Ich gucke gleich weiter okay habe nämlich ein textdokument wo ich mir die sachen aufgeschrieben
habe suppression kampagne fragezeichen suppression fragezeichen ok a sniper limit sehr gute
frage ja könnte man könnte man gucken ja c4 auf der auf der drohne so was da kann werde ich
werde ich nichts zu sagen können wird premium geben pass fragezeichen ok gute frage ja ping
system was ist ein ping system achso wo man sachen markieren kann aha ja gute frage
a spotten ja spotten auch gute frage wie gesagt ich werde nicht alles beantworten können commander
spotten eventuell sogar 3d spotten der stream kann ins archiv ich habe das ok von von ea
dass ich dass ich stream darf auch auch hier zeigen und so das ok performance habe ich doch
schon aufgeschrieben map remakes lehnen die fragen sind ein bisschen zu spezifisch wie gesagt
ich habe nicht den source code gelesen bei denen oder so das ist eine gute frage alte
console versus neue wie modifizierbar werden waffen ok ich genau ich habe das git repo
geschädt bekommen auf auf github habe ich habe jetzt battlefield source code das wäre
noch mal was dann werde ich krasse battlefield influencer wenn die mich einfach zu ihre github
orga einladen versuchen die wieder was in competitive ich könnte mir eigentlich eure
namen mit dabei kopieren dann könnte man vorlesen wer was gefragt hat aber gut das
ist jetzt zu spät das ist zu spät single player hammer 3 behemoth fahrzeuge ja könnte
man fragen jetzt pick up waffen geben cosplay ist doch ein muss das habe ich im vorfeld
auch gedacht ja ich also ich weiß es nicht aber ich würde mal ganz ehrlich also unabhängig
davon ob ich der schon infos habe oder nicht meine persönliche meinung dazu ist es ich
war mir von anfang an sicher dass es cosplay geben wird weil das machen mittlerweile andere
games vor und ich glaube nicht dass die sich das nehmen lassen wollen genauso wenig wie
ich glaube dass die sich den battle royale nehmen lassen wollen und sowas nehmen lassen
werden die sehen wie viel kohle activation macht mit modern warfare beziehungsweise war
zone das lassen die sich nicht angehen habe ich auch schon vorher in einem video gesagt
bettler wie to play das med min ist das auch eine gute frage warum warum warum nummer
riecht es eigentlich durch komplett useless ja die haben jetzt den call of duty typ mit
am start richtig ich bin mir nicht sicher ob die einen ob die eine kleine veranstaltung
machen oder nur den trailer zeigen sollte die nicht sollten die eine kleine veranstaltung
machen das ist eine gute frage achtet mal drauf wie wikinger mäßig die leute bei
dais aussehen mittlerweile also ich finde so so zwei drei leute von da ist zumindest
die die ich da im stream gesehen haben die könnten direkt aus vikings kommen eins zu
eins die sehen wirklich so richtig richtig nordmann mäßig aus game as a service fragezeichen
sind ja auch schweden jaja rückkehr zum bettel nett zu bettel lock bettel lock wollte
gerade sagen bettel netz in die hier koop missions so ein paar pang buster ne anti cheat anti
cheat hatten wir schon hier irgendwo drinne pang buster lul weh wir machten bitte pang
buster in 2021 die lehrzeichen das mache ich immer so besser lesbar wird es eine open beta
geben exzellente frage mindestens anforderungen das das das können wir bei performance was
zu sagen es gibt es spmm habe ich schon direkt hier oben drin stehen switch die frage erinnert
mich ein bisschen daran wo ich bei einer microsoft konferenz mal gefragt habe wann sie endlich
emojis im source code supporten und sie die frage tatsächlich dran genommen haben und
am ende hat sich noch einer gemeldet bei mir von microsoft und hat gesagt ich habe
dann microsoft einkaufgutschein gewonnen weil ich eine frage gestellt habe die im stream
drangekommen ist dabei war das einfach purer troll exzellent exzellent exzellent sniper
one hits das ist alles schon ein bisschen so spezifisch wie gesagt denkt er ich habe
den source code nicht gelesen und das spieler nicht gespielt also ich sowas kann ich nichts
sagen nachher
klassisches klassen ok klassen system das ist tatsächlich eine gute frage da gibt es
einiges zu zu erzählen später
feldraum fragezeichen war warum ich wie viele maps ogres gute frage map größe fragezeichen
lootboxen und so habe ich schon aufgeschrieben
huge singing skills ich war jetzt fischkei medic oder sturmsoldat zu klassen haben wir
schon genug jetpacks das schreiben wir mal hier dabei
customserver habe ich schon drin stehen rush habe ich auch schon die frage nach rush habe
ich auch schon drin stehen
1710 muss ich den titel vom stream ändern da kann ich nämlich den namen vom game reinschreiben
und dann muss ich auch das video freischalten
der reveal der geht los da gibt es auch guck mal da guck mal oben rechts guck mal oben
rechts da steht 18 minuten
gab es schon eine frage zur freie schaltung von waffen und levelsystem wir haben viel wir
haben auch waffen und sowas drin wenn wir was wissen werden wir auch was zu sagen
ok waffenskins kann ich mal wieder aufnehmen
was passiert wenn im trailer die mca musik drinne ist dann verklage ich ia
das ist das ist tatsächlich eine gute frage
ich muss discord auf dem zweiten bildschirm ausmachen das nachher mit loss schreiben kann
wenn es losgeht oder emir je nachdem wer vorher fertig ist
dogtech system melee animation sehr gut da sieht man wer battlefield gespielt hat die
letzten
also wer die früheren teile die mittleren teile sozusagen gespielt hat
15 minuten pause champ pausierungs champ
und dankeschön übrigens für den sub huge hyper subscription hier
field upgrades
melee animation counter knife ja könnte man vielleicht noch fragen performance hardware
specs haben wir schon
warum chromium die frage ist warum nicht
wie pot knife
kannst du jemand zum release befragen nee aber ich habe schon ein paar sachen gesehen
im vorfeld die wahrscheinlich über das hinausgehen was man im reveal trailer sieht und ich das
wegen auch ein bisschen was erzählen kann
ein aussteigesystem haben wir ja ja das haben wir schon mit animationen
das haben wir hier schon haben wir schon drin stehen
wer neu amd technologien supporten na das muss man glaub wie gesagt so ganz so ultra
krass im detail kann ich auch nichts zu sagen
farbfilter das hat wird tatsächlich ganz interessant ich frage
ok kill streaks ja stimmt könnte ja auch sein man weiß ja nicht
server haben wir schon ziemlich alles drin stehen haben fahrzeuge und endlich munition
wir werden uns dann zu fahrzeugen auslassen gibt es gibt es kampfhunde ok
da läuft eine ansage beim countdown
die ist bestimmt langweilig
ah who cares die sollen mal da die sollen den countdown machen und wir gucken uns das
dann an
wenn es aber nicht leute erinnert mich dran erinnert mich mal alle dran kurz bevor es
los gehts bemt den chat an mit voll dass ich chat aus dass ich chat heide countdown heide
und alles wegmach
die commander krieger wauzis ohr cringe
ohr cringe alter pains champ
wisst ihr was noch pains champiger ist die predator schnuppelmaschine
massive pains champ
so komm zwei fragen noch 50 fragen machen wir voll
nachtsicht und nachtmaps gute frage ja
machen wir lhw hier dazu
dlss wie gesagt so richtig spezielle sachen kann ich nicht kann ich eh nicht beantworten
competitive mods ok ja
ob das habe ich schon irgendwo drinne stehen
jetzt noobtube geben ganz ehrlich unabhängig davon ob ich das schon gesehen hätte oder
nicht würde ich meine würde ich raten ja weil es noobtubes in jedem game gibt in jedem
military setting game gibt es noobtubes
deswegen gehe ich davon aus dass es in battlefiend 6 auch noobtubes geben wird
wir hatten hier eine frage zu wettereffekte
da schreibe ich mir noch mal hin vielleicht möchte einer vielleicht können wir was zu
sagen
das wirst du wahrscheinlich im trailer dann schon wobei bin mir gar nicht so sicher
zum release dazu kann ich nur sagen
ich weiß es nicht also ich weiß es nicht aber es wird mich sehr wundern
ok ich sehe also jetzt die fragen die jetzt kommen sind sind viel zu spezifisch die kann
ich alle nicht beantworten nachher
aber wir gucken uns dann übrigens hier gleich noch mal hier pass mal auf hier
wo habe ich spelt viel 6 bf 6 assets leute ja da darf ich jetzt aber noch nicht reingucken
können wir uns nachher noch ein paar screenshots angucken wenn der trailer raus ist was so
Sachen die so nicht im nicht im weiß ich ob die nicht im trailer drin sind aber ich
glaube es sind Sachen auf jeden fall drin die man im standbild besser sehen kann
quicktime player ja kommt man kommt man nicht kommt man manchmal leider nicht drum herum
der desktop der desktop ist poggers ich weiß gar nicht warum es die leute immer so sehr
an meinem desktop stören
was habt ihr gegen meinen desktop desktop ist ordentlich ja finde ich auch
wie war das das genie überblickt das chaos
ich benutze meinen desktop ja auch nicht als desktop ich benutze mein desktop als ganz
normaler ordner ist der los da ich schon da ist er da ist er der machts gleich wie ich
gammel vor sich hin und wat bis endlich losgeht soll heute zehn minuten zehn minuten war das
nicht die oder war das fünf minuten was war die war diese legendäre münchner bahnhof
rede war das zehn minuten oder fünf minuten ich das schon zu lang her zehn minuten in
zehn minuten was gar nicht was der typ jetzt macht ich glaube den stolber haben sie in
die eu geschickt zum zum bürokratie abbauen oder sowas habe ich habe danach nie wieder
was von dem gehört seitdem er aus bayern weg ist gibt es bei youtube nicht auch einen
countdown ja der countdown oben rechts ist aus der youtube premiere und hier gucken wir
nachher in acht minuten in sieben minuten leute in sieben minuten ist soweit wird es
wieder cringe pr werbung geben das weiß ich nicht habe keine ahnung was die vor haben
so leute es wird jetzt folgendermaßen laufen das kann ich jetzt das kann ich jetzt mal
dazu sagen 17 uhr gibt's den trailer der läuft dann ein bisschen und ab 17 uhr 10 fällt
die nda und ich darf was zu sagen das heißt wir gucken uns den trailer an und mir nachdem
wie lange das läuft und danach kann ich vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz noch mal eine eindrücke
sagen und ein bisschen was was jetzt so was mir so einfällt und dann irgendwann keine
ahnung so 17 30 oder 45 oder je nachdem wann immer rufe ich an den lost an wir labern ein
bisschen drüber ich habe noch nichts gespielt nein gespielt gespielt ich habe ja darauf
gehofft dass ich spielen darf aber ich darf es durfte es leider noch nicht spielen es
wäre geil wenn ich hätte spielen dürfen aber ich durfte es noch nicht spielen also
das einzige was wir also ich kann sie ich kann es ja noch mal sagen also was wir was
wir erfahren haben ist ich habe den reveal trailer schon gesehen von einer von ein paar
tagen ich habe einen extra gameplay trailer gesehen vor ein paar tagen und ich habe eine
fhq session mit paar daisleuten habe ich zugeguckt das heißt ich weiß ein bisschen mehr über
das game aber es ist jetzt nicht so dass wenn ihr euch den trailer anguckt also dass ich
jetzt so krass ultra viel mehr ahnung hätte ja also wenn ihr euch den trailer sorgfältig
anguckt dann wisst ihr auch 50 prozent von dem übrigens ich weiß bis heute nicht warum
die mich eingeladen haben ich habe die letzten battlefield games nur noch geflammt oder
denkt sich da ist oder max der flämt uns immer so schön den laden wir jetzt ein keine ahnung
warum haben uns andere schon gespielt ich gehe von aus ich weiß es nicht aber ich gehe
von aus ich gehe von aus ist der reveal trailer sehr cinematic also wenn du die alten battlefield
trailer kennst dann weißt du wie die trailer aussehen
größte aktive battlefield 3 streamer auf twitch ok das mag sein aber das ist keine
großes keine große errungenschaft battlefield 3 spielt ihr auch mit keiner mehr geschweige
den stream auf twitch so fünf minuten leute in fünf minuten ist es soweit ich bin so gespannt
was ihr euch sagt ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen also wir waren als als los so nicht wir haben
ja schon video aufgenommen wir waren so gehyped und wir durften jetzt eine woche nichts sagen
mir ist es noch nie so schwer gefallen ohne scheiß ich habe schon ein paar unterschrieben
aber keine 100 aber schon ein paar nds in meinem leben unterschrieben und mir ist es
bisher noch nie so schwer gefallen was dazu zu sagen dazu nichts nichts dazu zu sagen
ja ich glaube versionen kündigen sie an bin ich mir aber nicht sicher da gibt es ja alles
so leute hier gleich ist soweit und ihr müsst mir unbedingt also wenn der trailer durch
ist also der loss und ich wir hatten beide bei einer szene im trailer das kann ich spoilern
bei einer szene im trailer hatten wir leicht tränen in den augen mich würde mal interessieren
wie es euch geht nachdem wir den trailer gesehen habt nur so leicht ja lost hat er schon gesagt
er ist der mann der auch gefühle zeigen kann so leicht so leicht ja aber aber nicht aber
nicht setzge nicht setzge sondern richtig ja habe ich da eigentlich ein passendes emote
dafür so happy so so happy happy glatke daily youtube content ne aber ich lade ein video
ab 17 uhr 10 hoch also ich habe das video schon hoch geladen ich schalte das dann 17
uhr 10 frei natürlich schön mit streamverlinkung dass alle leute wieder herkommen also ich
habe das video titel wird sein battlefield name einsetzen reveal warum wir mega gehyped
sind mit features lost aiming oder mit lost so ist das video titel aber ihr werdet wahrscheinlich
auch alles was wir in dem video sagen zusätzlich ausführlicher noch mal hier wobei alles weiß
ich nicht aber das meiste hier von uns danach im stream auch noch mal erfahren fast liegt
ja kannst du das neue ich weiß nicht was das ist das mache ich jetzt auch nicht hier im
stream auf ich habe keine ahnung was das ist das ist eine neue emote seite noch mehr obstlauf
ich weiß es nicht ich weiß es nicht nachdem die nda aber 17 uhr 10 vorbei ist vermute
ich mal es kommt der trailer und dann es kommt ein bisschen was davor und dann kommt der trailer
oder es kommt der trailer und es kommt nichts mehr ich weiß ich habe keine ahnung ich kann
noch nicht mal jetzt nda preaching oder so ich weiß es schlicht ergreif nicht was die
heute abend zeigen oder was die jetzt in zwei minuten zeigen ok leute wir machen schon mal
die musik aus jetzt wird es jetzt hier jetzt jetzt gehts los wir machen die musik aus ich
mache schon mal den chat aus drei minuten und die musik lasse ich an chat aus moment
chat aus katze katze aus oh ich habe display capture ausgemacht kek wait battlefield und
chico aus musst du nicht auf die toilette jetzt gehe ich nicht pinkeln jetzt nicht
moment moment moment moment warum stehen jetzt was ist hier los wie laut premiere begins
shortly leute ich habe schon f5 ich f5 schon die ganze zeit massive f5 bin ich hier ich
bin der f5 master wir sind einfach schneller leute wir sind wir sind wir sind einfach schneller
ich mache die musik jetzt aus wir sind einfach schneller wir warten einfach bis es hier los
geht und bei premiären kommt immer noch kommt immer noch countdown also also gleich gehts
gleich gehts los ja das ist laber im hintergrund gelaber das ist egal da labert keiner das ist
einfach nur einfach nur schau so stand by gleich gehts los leute gleich gehts los huge
huge jetzt sind nicht so ausflippen mehr so gut den können wir jetzt zumachen jetzt gucken
wir den hier 1 40 leute ich bin massive gehyped also ich weiß schon aber ihr könnt euch nicht
vorstellen wie gespannt ich drauf bin was ihr sagen wird und ihr müsst mir alle danach
sagen einmal im chat wenn ihr wenn ihr es seht und einmal danach ob ihr auch bei dieser
einen szene und wenn ihr sie gesehen habt wisst ihr welche ich meine auch so leicht
tränen in den augen habt ihr wisst es ich kann mir für kein geld der welt kann man
sich meinen hype kaufen ich habe nichts dafür gesehen okay kannst du ein bisschen lauter
machen ich weiß noch nicht wie laut sein wird ich mache jetzt einfach mal bärm das
bläst uns gleich das ohrwerk ich sags euch kann sein dass ich ein bisschen runter regeln
muss
wir sind live dabei fast auf hier 20 post jam geht los jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt massive
poggels
Das ist das, was manche Leaks schon gesehen haben.
Es ist Mord an.
Bam.
Wartet's ab, gleich kommt's.
Poggers, Alter.
Poggers.
Nosher Cannons.
Dogtags.
Das kennt man aus den Leaks.
War das so geil gemacht.
Das hat geleckt.
Shut up and take my money, genau.
Poggers.
Passt auf, Leute, jetzt kommt's.
Passt auf.
Und...
Bam.
Das ist so geil gemacht, Alter.
Das kennt man aus den Leaks.
Und Name?
Jetzt wissen wir's, 2042.
Big Brain Name.
War das nicht geil, Leute?
Also, war ganz ehrlich.
Ich war am Anfang echt skeptisch.
Ich war mega skeptisch.
Aber nachdem ich den Trailer gesehen hab, hab ich gedacht, das ist geil.
Es ist ein bisschen Zukunft.
Aber ich find, das ist durchaus im Rahmen.
Das ist 20 Jahre.
Man darf sich nicht vergessen, 2042 sind 20 Jahre.
Das ist jetzt nicht so viel.
Das heißt, vieles.
Und ich darf es noch nicht sagen, aber ich sag gleich was zur Story und so.
Und man sieht halt einfach, dass die...
Ich hab vergessen, was ich gesagt hab.
Keg-Wade, Alter.
Das ging mir schon, als ich das erste Mal gesehen hab.
Was wollte ich denn sagen?
Das passt.
Guck mal, das sind noch 20 Jahre.
Das sind 20 Jahre.
Und da kann man viel mitmachen.
Weil vieles an Technologie, was heute so prototypmäßig ist, gibt's dann halt zumindest...
Da kann man sich das ansehen.
Dass die Soldaten 2042 mit Wing-Suits in einem Tornado rumfliegen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das 2042 auch so sein wird.
Aber zumindest die Hunde und das ganze Zeug, was man gesehen hat, ist halt richtig nice.
Das hieß es ja jetzt schon.
Gibt's diese Boston-Dynamic-Videos und alles Mögliche.
Da geht's auf jeden Fall hin.
Aber ohne Scheiß, das Beste war in dem ganzen Video.
Wie sie spielt, sei mal außen vor, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Das kann am Endeffekt sich immer noch mega beschissen spielen.
Man weiß es nicht.
Aber die Szene mit dem Jet und dem RPG, die fand ich einfach richtig geil.
Allerdings, und ihr wisst ja, ich muss dann immer gleich die Sache stellen.
Ich hatte eine Woche Zeit, mir über den Trailer Gedanken zu machen.
Ich war am Anfang, die ersten zwei, drei Tage, mega hyped.
Weil ich gesagt hab, geil, RPG und Jet und sonst was.
Und dann hab ich mir gedacht, wenn die so was explizit in den Trailer packen,
dann ist das vielleicht gar nicht so im Game, weil es rein Cinematic ist.
Oder es ist so im Game inszeniert, dass es eben nicht so dynamisch entsteht
wie in den alten Battlefields, sondern quasi, dass es dann so ein Quicktime-Event gibt.
Jetzt Button für RPG aus dem Cockpit oder so.
Man weiß es nicht.
Aber ich geh mal davon aus, sie werden hoffentlich die Kurve kriegen, was das angeht.
So.
Also ich warte jetzt noch bis 17.10.
Leute, vielleicht in 10 Sekunden darf ich was über das Game sagen.
Poggers, Alter.
So, das ist 17.10.
Okay, Leute, ich darf was über das Game sagen.
Nice.
Also, wir schauen uns jetzt mal was zusammen an.
Wer bin ich?
Entpack mal die Bilder.
Ich kann euch das jetzt nämlich zeigen.
Jetzt ist okay.
Jetzt ist NDA.
NDA ist vorbei seit 13 Sekunden.
Titel anpassen, ja.
Battlefield 2042 Reveal.
Also, ich zeige euch mal was.
Also, ich habe ein paar Bildchen von denen gekriegt.
Das erste, was es gibt, das sind Sachen aus dem Trailer.
Die kennt ihr wahrscheinlich.
Jetzt habt ihr ja auch schon alle gesehen, das sind Sachen aus dem Trailer.
Da sieht man auch mal die ganze Panzergeschichte.
Dann hast du hier nochmal die Wingsuit-Geschichte, Tornado-Geschichte.
Wann kommt Lost?
Ich bin hier im Discord-Off.
Ich weiß nicht.
Äh.
Ähm.
Ich sage mir, es soll Scheiß sagen, wenn er ready ist.
Also.
Der macht was mit Video.
Ja, das kann sein.
Der will sein.
Oh, ich muss mal ein Video freischalten auf YouTube.
Hätte ich jetzt fast vergessen.
Öffentlich.
Fertig.
Speichern.
Jetzt gibt es noch ein Video auf YouTube.
Zack.
Sehr schön.
Auch raus.
So, also jetzt können wir uns auch was zusammen angucken.
Wo fangen wir am besten an?
Also wir gucken jetzt einfach nochmal die Bildchen über an.
Und mit Lost rede ich dann gleich darüber, was wir noch alles erfahren haben.
Übrigens, Leute, ich bin immer noch der Meinung, nicht vorbestellen sehe ich immer noch genauso.
Also so gehypt ich drauf bin.
Ich werde euch jetzt mal noch ein paar Sachen zeigen.
Ich werde euch die, wir gucken uns jetzt ein paar Sachen vom Spiel an.
Und dann noch, was es für, wann es Beta und sowas gibt.
Kann ich euch auch schon zeigen.
Also.
Folgendes.
Wir gucken jetzt mal hier schon noch die Bilder an.
Wingsuits, Tornados.
Also es gibt dynamische Wettereffekte.
Wie das genau sich auf dem Map verhalten wird, war noch nicht klar.
Sie haben nur gesagt, man kann das quasi auch zu seinem Vorteil nutzen.
Aber ich meine, ist ja irgendwie logisch.
Das übrigens am Anfang, was aussah wie Demervent Peak, ist nicht Demervent Peak.
Sieht aber verdammt ähnlich nach Demervent Peak aus.
Gut.
Haley Stelz, gibt es jetzt nichts, gibt es jetzt nichts besonderes zu sagen.
Außer, dass sie erzählt haben, dass diese ganzen Kran-Dinger hier und sich dynamisch
bewegen und so.
Mal gucken.
Hovercraft-Gedöns gibt es jetzt genau.
Es gibt diese komischen Hunde, Stelz-Dinger, Haley.
Also sie haben ganz viel Wert darauf gelegt, dass das alles All-Out-Warfare ist.
Das ist so das neueste Buzzword anscheinend.
Also Leute, denkt an mich.
Ich predikte das jetzt schon.
All-Out-Warfare wird das Ding, was die uns bis zum Schluss, das werden sie uns rein
hämmern bis zum Release.
All-Out-Warfare haben sie uns zumindest auch von.
Ach ja und Sandbox.
Sandbox und All-Out-Warfare.
Das haben sie uns zumindest vor einer Woche in dieser internen Vorstellung haben sie uns
gefühlt drei Stunden All-Out-Warfare erzählt und Sandbox.
So.
Jet.
Die Jet-Geschichte natürlich.
Wetter, dynamische Wetter.
Blitz.
Blitz-Stelz-Geschichten.
Das haben wir ja schon gesehen.
Das unspektakuläre Panzerstelz.
So, aber was euch jetzt wahrscheinlich viel mehr interessiert ist, bevor wir uns das Klassen-System
angucken.
Falls einer beim Lost reinguckt, kann er mir sagen, wenn er fertig ist.
Wir können uns die.
Genau.
So.
Das Ganze gibt es natürlich weiterhin auf Origin und EA Play.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, wenn es das über Steam gibt mit EA Play, dann wird das wahrscheinlich
über Steam gelauncht werden.
So.
Es gibt Early Access, Open Beta, wie immer, wenn man hier wahrscheinlich muss dann vorbestellen
oder was auch immer.
Da gibt es eine 10 Stunden Trial.
Ich weiß nicht, ehrlich gesagt, ob das nur EA Play ist.
Ach, gibt es das jetzt schon auf Steam?
Witzig.
Ja gut, aber wenn es das auf Steam gibt, das wird 100 pro Origin lauschen, Leute.
Alle Battlefield-Teile, die zurzeit auf Steam sind, lauschen Origin.
Also, man muss sich da keine Hoffnung machen, dass man über Steam Playlist Leute einladen
kann.
Das glaube ich nicht.
So, dann gibt es, ich mache mal kurz wieder Musik an.
So, dann gibt es Blah, Member Rewards, was auch immer.
Jetzt 10% auf Pre-Order und sonst was.
Und eine Sache, die ich jetzt aber schon sagen kann, weil das viele von euch auch gefragt
haben, es gibt keine, ich meine, nagelt mich nicht drauf fest, ich kann nichts dafür,
wenn sie mir das sagen, aber es am Ende nicht machen.
Es gibt keine Lootboxen.
Es gibt einen Season Pass.
Es gibt mehrere Season Passes.
Also im Prinzip das Modern Warfare System.
Kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten?
Ich finde es okay.
So, dann haben wir das.
Key Art, das ist das Box Art, das haben wir jetzt ja schon gesehen.
Übrigens, witzigerweise, ich muss so lachen Leute, ich muss so lachen auf Reddit.
Ich habe mich so weggekackt auf Reddit.
Mega weggekackt auf Reddit, nämlich die Leute haben dieses Box Art gepostet auf Reddit und
haben gesagt, guckt mal hier, Leak, was meint ihr, meint ihr, ob das echt ist?
Und dann die Leute auf Reddit, nein, nein, das sieht doch jeder, jeder sieht, dass das
nicht echt ist.
Guckt mal diese Farbgebung an, die passt ja überhaupt nicht zusammen.
Das muss Fake sein, das kann nicht echt sein.
Lolli, glaubt doch nicht ernsthaft, dass DICE sowas released, null, das ist Fake.
Und ich gucke mir diese, ich gucke mir diese ganzen Sachen auf Reddit an und denke mir
halt einfach nur, ihr habt alle keinen Plan.
So, wie gesagt, das ist das Box Art in Hoch und Left.
Dann haben wir noch das Logo, gut, das ist jetzt Logo für euch, das ist ziemlich wurscht,
das brauche ich für Thumbnails später.
Map Screenshots.
Na gut, die haben wir gerade schon gesehen.
Es gibt zum Release, muss ich mal nachgucken, das beantworte ich gleich im Lost, wie viele
Maps und so es gibt.
Lass mal zu den Fragen übergehen, das machen wir, wenn der Lost da ist.
Dann machen wir erst mal eine Videozeuge fertig machen.
Also es gibt glaube ich zum Start, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, 6 oder 7 oder, ich muss
mal nachgucken, ich habe es mir mal aufgeschrieben.
Und was ich lustig finde, das hier, war der allererste Leak, könnt ihr euch noch dran
erinnern, der allererste Leak mit der Rakete, wo die Leute auch gesagt haben, nee, nee,
das wäre aus Just Cause und sowas, da habe ich mich auch übrigens weggepisst, glaubt
man doch nicht ernsthaft.
Aber da sieht man aber wieder, wie absolut Low IQ Reddit ist, ja, du kannst Reddit nichts
glauben.
So, und jetzt kommen wir mal zu einer Sache, die euch wahrscheinlich brennend interessiert,
wie das mit den, ach nee, gucken wir uns mal an, was es für Editions gibt, wahrscheinlich
auch recht interessant für Standard Edition, Gold Edition, Ultimate Edition.
Ja, okay, wer es braucht, meinetwegen.
Also es gibt, ich bekomme in der Standard Edition wirklich das Base Game, das ist aber
zu gütig von euch, das ist zu gütig von euch, ey, dass ich das Base Game bekomme.
Das Teppichmesser gibt es wieder, ja.
Early Axis, bla, ihr müsst also vorbestellen und bzw. den Kamiu Ultimate, Cross Gen Bundle,
ach so, das darf ich jetzt auch schon sagen, genau, es kommt auf der alten Konsolengeneration
raus und auf der neuen Konsolengeneration, aber der Unterschied zwischen alter und neuer
Konsolengeneration ist, die alte Konsolengeneration ist beschnitten, was Map Größe und Spielerzahl
angeht.
128 Spieler auf den neuen Konsolen und auf dem PC, auf den alten Konsolen nur 64 Spieler
und kleinere Maps.
Sie haben natürlich Wert darauf gelegt, dass sie immer gesagt haben, so nach dem Motto,
die Battlefield Experience ist überall die gleiche, aber ganz im Ernst, ich glaube, das
ist ein Spiel, das spielt man echt am besten auf PC oder auf den neuen Konsolen.
So, dann gibt es Midnight Bundle, juckt mich nicht, ich kaufe mir wahrscheinlich Standard
Edition und den Rest dazu oder eine Gold Edition Ultimate kaufe ich mir bestimmt nicht.
So, Early Axis, Game Lounge, Cross Gen Bundle, das Cross Gen Bundle ist wahrscheinlich, dass
man von alten Generationen auf seine neue, seinen Account dann quasi beides parallel
spielen kann oder so, was auch immer.
Battle Pass gibt es jetzt dabei.
A Cross Play, da bin ich mir ehrlich gesagt nicht sicher.
Ich weiß, dass es viele interessiert mit Cross Play.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob die was dazu gesagt haben.
Da müsste ich den Lost mal fragen, ob der da was von mitgekriegt hat.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass es Cross Play geben wird.
Ich bin mir aber nicht mehr sicher, ob sie was dazu gesagt haben.
Ich habe mir jede Menge aufgeschrieben, das können wir dann gleich besprechen.
So, was haben wir dann sonst noch?
Genau, Pre-Order Awards.
Leute, ich weiß, ich bin auch mega gehypt, aber ich werde auch nicht pre-ordern.
Die haben den ersten Schritt gemacht, mich als alter Battlefield-Fan und wo sie mich ein
bisschen verloren haben, jetzt mit 1 und 5 wieder neu zu hypen, aber ich pre-ordere nicht.
Und ich meine, es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass es...
Gut, ich meine, das einzige, wo es sich lohnt, ist eventuell für Open Beta.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich würde nicht pre-ordern.
Ich muss mal kurz bei mir auf YouTube rein gucken, was da so geht.
Auf YouTube sehen die Leute schon wieder sich überhalten ums Battle Royale.
Soll ich euch was zu Battle Royale sagen in Battlefield?
Also, folgendermaßen, zu Battle Royale kann ich nur sagen, dass DICE uns nichts gesagt hat.
Die haben aber sich so krass drumherum gedrückt, dass ich persönlich immer noch davon ausgehe,
dass es einen Battle Royale geben wird und dass es free sein wird.
Die haben sich so krass um diese Frage gedrückt, sie haben explizit gesagt, die Spielmodi,
wenn Battlefield released wird, es ist kein Battle Royale.
Und sie haben aber immer noch so einen Spielmodus extra offen gelassen in jedem ihrer Bildchen.
Und ich bin mir eigentlich sicher, da kommt ein Battle Royale und der wird free to play sein.
Es könnte auch sein, dass es kein Battle Royale im klassischen Sinn wird,
sondern ein Battlefieldigeres Battle Royale.
Das wird es geben, free to play-Teil wird es geben.
Ich bin mir da zu 99,9% sicher.
Ich bin so sicher wie die Uptime von Azure.
Also, ja, wird es geben.
So, ansonsten gibt es nichts mehr zu zeigen.
Das haben wir uns schon angeguckt hier, Battle Pass wunderbar.
Ich finde übrigens auch das Design wieder ganz cool,
dass sie das von Battlefield 3 und 4 so ein bisschen beibehalten haben.
Diesmal ist es ein bisschen mehr türkis, ist euch, glaube ich, auch schon aufgefallen.
Battlefield 3 war quasi so grau-blau, Battlefield 4 war eher neutral
und das ist jetzt eher so türkis.
Ganz, ganz nice gemacht.
So, und jetzt kommen wir mal zu einem Punkt, was euch alle interessiert.
Wie wird das mit den Klassen sein?
Macht der Lost Ready?
Weil da macht Gameplay keinen Sinn.
Da gehe ich auf alle Maps ein.
Das ist eine Übersicht, das ist ganz cool.
Ja, ich warte mal ab, ich warte mal ab.
Also, genau, was ich euch jetzt zeigen kann, ist folgendes.
Wie wird das mit den Klassen sein? Folgendermaßen.
Kann ich jetzt ja mal kurz zeigen.
Also, es wird keine Klassen mehr geben im klassischen Sinne wie in Battlefield bisher.
Also, es war ja die ganze Zeit so, es gibt Engineer, Medic, also Sturmsalat auf Deutsch,
Medic, Engineer, Support und Recon.
Es wird keine klassischen Klassen für jedermann geben.
Deswegen wartet es ab, wartet es ab, wartet es ab.
Jetzt gibt es Specialists, die in einer der klassischen Kategorien sind.
Also, es wird folgendermaßen sein.
Es gibt nach wie vor die Kategorien, Medic, Sturmsalat, Engineer, Recon oder Support.
Und in diesen Kategorien gibt es verschiedene Operator bzw. Specialists.
Ich habe die ganze Zeit immer Operator gesagt, aber da hat DICE noch mal darauf hingewiesen,
der Kram heißt Specialist.
Und ich muss euch sagen, ich finde die Idee gar nicht schlecht,
weil da kommt noch ein paar Sachen dabei.
Was ich aber auch sagen muss, das erste, was mir durch den Kopf geschossen ist,
als ich das gesehen habe vor einer Woche.
DICE hat sich alles abgeguckt, was Spiele erfolgreich gemacht haben die letzten Jahre über.
Also sprich, die haben sich relativ stark von, zumindest sah das ein bisschen so aus,
inspirieren lassen von Warzone, sie haben sich inspirieren lassen von Rainbow Six,
sie haben sich ein bisschen inspirieren lassen von CS und also vieles,
was die letzten Jahre über erfolgreich war, bisschen Fortnite, alles dabei
und haben daraus Battlefield gemacht.
Die hauptsächliche Inspiration ist aber eindeutig Rainbow Six und Warzone, finde ich.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns mal ein paar Specialists an.
Ich werde es gleich im Los zusammen noch alles möglichst detailliert erzählen.
Genau. Also, es gibt jetzt hier nur vier Specialists, hast du schon Gameplay gesehen?
Ja, aber da darf ich im Detail noch nicht allzu viel dazu erzählen.
Ich darf fast alles erzählen, aber noch nicht 100%ig alles.
Also, es gibt Specialists und hier haben sie vier Specialists reingepackt,
die quasi, ich weiß nicht, wie viele, ich weiß nicht, wie viele,
ich weiß nicht, wie viele, ich weiß nicht, wie viele,
es gibt Specialists und hier haben sie vier Specialists reingepackt,
die quasi den klassischen Classes aus Battlefield entsprechen.
Das hier ist ein Recon Specialist, das hier ist, ich glaube, der Medic Specialist,
ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so sicher.
Das ist auf jeden Fall der Engineer Specialist und das ist der Support Specialist.
Ja, glaube, glaube, so war es, steht leider nichts dabei.
Zumindest, sie werden es folgendermaßen machen, ich glaube, das hier ist der Medic.
Ich glaube, das ist der, guck mal, die hat doch hier, seht ihr das?
Die hat doch auch hier Medic, Medic drauf.
Sexismus, der Medic ist eine Frau, Anzeige ist raus, Alter.
War das der Trailer, den ihr bekommen habt?
Jaja, das ist der Trailer, den ich vor einer Woche gesehen habe.
Ja, ist genau exakt der gleiche Trailer.
Rule 34 ist raus, ja, das ist immer raus.
Zumindest, was es da wirklich cool ist, was es da wirklich Nicest dazu zu sagen gibt.
Ich will es jetzt nicht allem so sehr vorgreifen,
weil ich muss ja mit dem Lost nachher noch was zu erzählen haben.
Ich schreibe dem Lost einfach mal im Chat.
Twitch Lost.
Ich sage dem einfach Lost.
Twitch Lost, ich sage dem einfach.
Also, falls jemand beim Lost im Chat ist, ihr könnt ihm sagen,
er soll einfach Bescheid sagen, wenn er ready ist.
Ich wäre so weit.
So, also, was man zu diesen Specialists noch sagen kann, ist Folgendes.
Es wird zwar kein klassisches Classes mehr geben wie in den alten Battlefields,
aber es gibt Specialists in den unterschiedlichen Kategorien.
Das bedeutet, das bedeutet, weil eine der Frage im Vorfeld war,
ob es wieder Battlefield 3 Wiederbelebungstrain gibt.
Teilweise, weil, also es wird nicht nur ein Specialist geben pro Klasse.
Ist ja logisch, wer ja ein bisschen bescheuert,
wenn man nur ein Specialist pro Klasse macht.
Es ist zum Beispiel so, dass dieser Specialist hier einen Kit bekommt.
Ich weiß nicht, sieht man den Defi? Ist das hier der Defi?
Zumindest die bekommt einen Gadget, die 100% wiederbeleben kann,
wenn ich die richtig verstanden habe, was da ist.
Also sprich, es gibt mehrere Medic Specialists
und unter anderem ein Feature von manchen Medic Specialists ist,
dass sie einen Defi haben, der 100% wiederbeleben kann.
Sind die Specialist auf bestimmte Waffen beschränkt? Nein.
Specialists können, also du kannst keine Waffen,
es gibt keine Locked Waffen mehr.
Du kannst als Medic, oder du kannst als Sniper,
so wie ich es verstanden habe, Assault Rifles nehmen
und du kannst als Support auch oder du kannst als Medic
Submachine Guns nehmen oder so was.
Also es ist nicht mehr gelockt, da sieht man auch,
jeder Sniper hat eine Assault Rifle am Start
oder ein DMR oder so was in der Richtung.
Auf jeden Fall nice.
Und das wird es nicht mehr geben.
Wie mich das Träger hat mit dem schnellen Schein?
Ja, da kann ich auch nichts machen.
Genau, es gibt keine normalen Klassen, korrekt.
So, und es ist so, dass die, dass du, wenn du den Specialist
auswählst, jeder Specialist hat quasi eine Sache,
die ihn ausmacht.
In dem Fall, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie diese Dudes,
Casper heißt er, Casper steht imwegs der Name dabei,
excellent. Also, die haben keine Perk, in dem Sinn,
die haben ihr Primary Gadget.
Jeder Specialist hat einen Primary Gadget.
In dem Fall, der hat eine Drohne.
Die hat, wer ist es denn?
Maria hat 100% Defi.
Der hat als Primary Gadget so einen komischen Turret.
Und der hat als Primary Gadget, glaube ich,
so eine Art Grappling Hook.
Alles andere kannst du auswählen, wie du willst.
Also, das heißt, die Specialist sind jetzt nicht so krass
wie die Operators aus Rainbow Six.
In Rainbow Six sind ja die Operators ziemlich,
ziemlich unterschiedlich.
Es ist im Prinzip ein klassischer Recon mit einer
Primary Perk.
Und das ist ein klassischer Medic mit einer
Spezialfähigkeit Primary Perk.
Du kannst ansonsten, wie viele Specialists es gibt,
es gibt zum Start, glaube ich, 10 Stück.
Es gibt, glaube ich, 10 Stück zum Start.
Und, ja.
Sie werden das erweitern.
Also, ich gehe davon aus, dass sie das so machen werden.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass sie das so machen werden,
wie in Warzone, dass die Pro Season Pass neue
Specialists bringen.
So, was macht der Lost?
Mal schauen.
Der Lost am Start.
Oh, erst mal ein bisschen Werbung.
Excellent.
Ja, ansonsten, es gibt noch jede Menge Sachen zu sagen,
aber das wollte ich mal für den Talk gleich aufheben.
Waffenaufsätze.
Ja, Waffenaufsätze.
Exzellente Frage.
Also, mit Waffenaufsätzen sieht es folgendermaßen aus.
Also, wie viel es geben wird, weiß ich nicht.
Aber, und jetzt haltet euch fest.
Jetzt haltet euch fest.
Eine Sache kann ich jetzt schon raushauen,
bevor wir mit unserem Talk anfangen.
Eine Sache kann ich euch schon mal verraten.
Waffenaufsätze wird es möglich sein,
während der Runde zu wechseln.
So ein bisschen wie in Crisis.
Also, du kannst dich ranzliden.
Zum Beispiel, du spielst hier Medic mit Pistol
oder du spielst hier Recon.
Und bist am Start mit Red Dot.
Und dann slidest du in die Deckung,
gehst in deinen Waffenkonfigurator
und machst dir einen Vergrößerungscope drauf.
Nein, nein, im Game, während du spielst,
kannst du das machen.
Nicht, während du tot bist.
Es wird nicht alles customizable sein.
Die Waffe kannst du nicht wechseln.
Ich glaube, du kannst Gadgets und Waffen
und Granaten und sowas nicht wechseln,
während du noch lebst.
Was du machen kannst, ist, du kannst das Scope tauschen.
Da gibt es dann auch, glaube ich, eine Animation
oder sowas für.
Also, du kannst das Scope tauschen.
Also, sprich, wenn der Dude hier mit Red Dot unterwegs ist
und er ist ein Recon,
dann kann er seine Drohne irgendwo hinschicken.
Und die Drohne fliegt dann weiter
und man macht LLV auf der Map.
Er geht in die Deckung und tauscht das Scope aus
zu einem Sniperscope und kämpft sich den Ass ab.
Das würde funktionieren.
The Lost is Ready.
Ich ruf ihn an, können wir anfangen.
Okay, ich muss Discord anmachen.
Nicht, dass ich im falschen Channel bin, Leute.
Nicht so nice, nicht so nice.
Nicht, dass ich in meinem Rule34-Channel bin oder so.
Ah, nee, passt.
Okay, ich starte mal den Anruf.
Mal, ob das funktioniert.
Es sollte bimmeln.
Wenn das funktioniert.
Es ist... ah, okay.
Oder auch nicht.
Am Lost gerade ein Upload im Eimer.
Er wird dann schon reinjoinen, wenn es soweit ist.
Erst mal Pogu hinten dran, weil geht.
Ich glaube, da kann er einfach reinjoinen.
Jo, wie sehen die Specialist Customizations aus?
Da sagen wir gleich was zu.
Ich muss gerade mal auf YouTube gucken,
ob mein Video jetzt freigeschaltet ist und alles.
Wie sieht das Spotting-System aus?
Also, ich habe zwar einen Gameplay-Trailer gesehen,
aber im Detail darf ich es noch nicht so sehr sagen.
Es wird wahrscheinlich so sein, dass du weiterhin spotten kannst,
wie gehabt, mit einem LLV, dass du quasi einen LLV hast,
der ein bisschen Radar wie in Warzone macht
und es dir dann auch die Leute markiert.
Wie das mit 3D-Spotting ist und Q drücken, weiß ich nicht.
Komm, ich gucke mal, ob die Leute auf YouTube auch gehypt sind.
Auf Battlefield 4 basiert OMG. Nein, ist es nicht.
Es ist, by the way, auch nicht Demavent Peak.
Ach ja, übrigens eine Kampagne wird es nicht geben.
So viel kann ich jetzt schon mal sagen.
Kampagne, Kampagne wird es nicht geben.
Keine Kampagne.
Ich mache gerade noch mal auf, wo man sieht,
was es an Editions und so gibt.
Weißt du schon was zu den Grafikanforderungen?
Die haben sich da recht bedeckt gehalten, was das angeht.
Aber nachdem das so, naja, ganz schwierig ist,
Grafikkarten zu bekommen, kann ich mir vorstellen,
das läuft auch noch mit einem halbwegs guten, aktuellen PC,
der nicht super high end ist.
Skill-based Matchmaking.
Okay, zu Skill-based Matchmaking kann ich jetzt was sagen.
Das ist eine Frage, die hat mich persönlich auch extrem gewurmt im Vorfeld.
Ich habe ja sogar ein eigenes Video zugemacht
zu Skill-based Matchmaking, also folgendermaßen.
Ich glaube, es wird so laufen mit Skill-based Matchmaking.
Ich habe gefragt, also wir hatten eine FAQ-Session mit DICE.
Ich habe gefragt, Leute, wie sieht es aus, Skill-based Matchmaking.
Ich habe das mehrfach gefragt.
Und ich bin mir sicher, die haben es gesehen.
Aber die haben das richtig krass ignoriert.
Die haben kein Wort gesagt zu Skill-based Matchmaking.
M320 drin wahrscheinlich.
Die haben kein Wort zu Skill-based Matchmaking gesagt.
Die haben komplett das ganze Thema Skill-based Matchmaking umschifft.
Aber ich vermute mal, dass es folgendermaßen läuft.
Wie gesagt, keine Ahnung, ob das wirklich so wird.
Kann ich euch nicht sagen, ich weiß es nicht.
Ich vermute mal, ich vermute mal Folgendes mit Skill-based Matchmaking.
Ich gehe auch mal davon aus, dass es einen ganz normalen Serverbrowser geben wird.
Also ich denke mal, das normale Game,
also wenn man sowas wie Conquest spielt und sowas,
das wird kein Skill-based Matchmaking im klassischen Sinne haben.
Es könnte sein, wenn man über das Quick-Match geht,
dass versucht wird, die Teams zu balancen.
Aber, aber es wird so eine Art, vermute ich mal,
so eine Art Ranking-Modus geben.
Da haben sie auch ein bisschen was zu geteased.
Ich bin mir allerdings nicht sicher, ob das ein Ranking-Modus ist.
Und da gibt es dann natürlich Skill-based Matchmaking.
Ja, logisch, weil Ranking ist Skill-based Matchmaking.
Ist Skill-based Matchmaking, auch wenn Leute mit höherer Kd eine größere Hitbox haben?
Nein, sowas nicht.
Werden private Server möglich sein?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Also zum Selbsthausten garantiert nicht.
Wie viele Quadratkilometer hat eine Map?
Schwer zu sagen.
Es gab Einblendungen von um die sechs Quadratkilometer,
aber man hat keine Ahnung, auf was sich das bezieht,
auf den Areal oder auf die ganze Map.
Keine Ahnung.
Kann man während dem Wingsuit ballern?
Ich glaube nicht.
Irgendwelche Metro-News?
Ja, wir können uns gleich nochmal die Map...
Ich kann euch gleich nochmal vorlesen, wenn der Lost am Start ist,
wie das mit den Maps aussieht.
Ich habe mir hier alles aufgeschrieben, wie viele Maps es gibt
und welche unterschiedlichen Maps und sowas in der Richtung.
Und dann gehen wir auch eure Fragen durch.
Eine Frage, die mich auch extrem im Vorfeld gequält...
Gequält hat, es gibt es Rush oder nicht.
Es gibt auf jeden Fall Conquest und es gibt auf jeden Fall ein,
ich habe vergessen, wie der heißt,
so eine Rush-ähnliche Sektor-Eroberungsgeschichte.
Also es sind keine M-Coms, die man planten muss.
Aber die Leute haben gefragt, wird Rush zurückkehren?
Und die haben sich sehr darum gedrückt, was zu sagen.
Breakthrough, genau.
Die haben sich sehr davor gedrückt, was zu sagen.
Also es könnte sein...
Ich weiß es nicht, ob es Rush gibt.
Das ist auch was, was ich mich schon die ganze Zeit frage.
Und ich hoffe ja, ich hoffe, dass es ein ganz klassisches Rush geben wird.
Und wie gesagt, das mit dem Medic Train habe ich ja schon beantwortet.
Medic Train wird es in der Art und Weise global für alle nicht mehr geben.
Aber es gibt Specialists, die einen Defi haben für instant 100%.
Ob der einen Cooldown hat oder sowas, weiß ich nicht.
Aber es gibt Perks für 100% Revive.
Also das ist eine Primary Perk von einem Specialist.
Das heißt, die kann man auch nicht ändern.
Das heißt, immer wenn man diesen Specialist spielt, hat man 100% Leben Revive.
Ist jeder Spieler automatisch einer der verfügbaren Specialists?
Ja, da sind keine Helden wie in Battlefront, so wie ich das verstanden habe.
Wird es einen In-Game-Store geben? Nein, wird es nicht geben.
Zumindest keinen In-Game-Store, wo du dir Waffen oder irgendwie Sachen kaufen kannst.
Es wird einen Battle Pass geben.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen? Genau.
Du musst einen der Specialists picken, damit du die jeweilige Klassenkategorie spielen kannst.
Also es ist kein Helden-System wie in Battlefront.
Auf der Webseite gibt es mehr, da gucken wir uns das doch mal an.
Schauen wir mal.
Wie ist denn die offizielle Webseite überhaupt?
Wie ist denn die offizielle Webseite davon?
Kegweight, Alter.
Guck mal, der Chat ist wieder schneller.
Der Chat kennt sich aus.
Also, zeig mal her.
Ich sag doch, All-Out-Warfare.
Das haben die gefühlt.
Jedes zweite Wort war All-Out-Warfare und Sandbox von den Leuten von DICE.
Sind es Helden wie in Apex?
Ein bisschen Helden wie in Apex, ja, aber nicht so sehr spezialisiert.
Du hast eine Primary Perk pro Held oder pro Specialist, die unique für diesen Specialist ist.
Also zum Beispiel hier.
Er hat eine Drohne, die hat sonst keiner.
Sie hat einen 100% Defi, den hat sonst keiner.
Er hat einen Turm, den hat sonst keiner.
Und er hat einen Crapling Hook, den hat sonst auch keiner.
Hast du schon Gameplay gesehen?
Ja, aber da darf ich nicht so viel im Detail was zu erzählen.
Noch nicht.
Ich glaub erst in drei Tagen oder so.
Das ist gelockt bei den Specialists.
Den Rest kannst du frei spielen.
Also es ist so ein Zwischending zwischen einem Apex oder Overwatch Held
oder einem Rainbow Six Operator und einer klassischen Battlefield Klasse.
Was findest du von den Specialists?
Das ist so halbe halbe.
Das finde ich aber auch ganz gut.
Weil es ist ja auch, und es wird natürlich auch Skins und sowas geben.
Weil sonst, das wäre ja schon ein bisschen lächerlich.
Wenn, ich würde sagen, seht die Specialists weniger als Overwatch Helden
und weniger als Apex Rainbow Six Helden, sondern seht die mehr als Subklassen.
Seht die Specialists eher als Subklassen von Medic, als Subklassen von Engineer.
Weil es ist nicht so wie ein Held in Overwatch, der komplett unique ist.
Du hast ein Primary Gadget, in dem Fall hier die Drohne,
und den Rest kannst du customisieren, wie du willst.
Es ist ein bisschen wie die Black Ops Specialists.
Ja, in die Richtung.
Zeig mal, wo steht hier was zu Specialists?
Genau, also das hier sind die Spielmodi.
Das hier ist Conquest und Breakthrough.
Ich hoffe mal, dass da noch Rush dabei kommt.
Conquest ist ganz klassisch, wie man das kennt in Battlefield.
Und Breakthrough ist Sektor, Sektor einnehmen.
Es gibt im Battle Pass neue Specialists.
Hazard Zone, es ist kein Battle Royale.
Kein Battle Royale, das haben die 85 Millionen mal gesagt.
Hazard Zone, auch wenn es Zone hat, ist kein Battle Royale.
Ich glaube, Hazard Zone wird der Versuch,
ein Competitive Modus zu machen in Battlefield.
Ist meine Vermutung.
Ich vermute, dass Hazard Zone ein Versuch wird,
einen Squad-based Competitive Modus zu etablieren.
Da weiß ich aber noch nicht so viel dazu.
Ich denke es aber mal, weil die öfters was von Squad-based erzählen.
Doch, ich bin mir nahezu sicher, dass sie einen Battle Royale machen.
Ich weiß nichts dazu, aber es würde mich äußerst wundern,
wenn die das nicht machen.
Dann gibt es neuen Spielmodus, den die überall eingeplendet haben.
Wenn man sie dazu gefragt hat, wird das ein Battle Royale sein,
haben sie immer gesagt, no comment, no comment.
Das wird von DICE LA entwickelt.
Und soll quasi was sein für Langzeit-Battlefield-Dinger.
Entweder ist das da, Battle Royale, oder Battle Royale kommt free to play nächstes Jahr.
Ich persönlich tippe drauf, Battle Royale kommt free to play nächstes Jahr.
Ach, hier gibt es was für Story, das ist tatsächlich ganz interessant.
Battlefield FAQ, wo gibt es hier was zu den Specialists?
Wo steht denn hier was zu Specialists? Hier ist Specialists.
Ach guck mal, was? Maria Fleck? Ah nee, Falk.
Ich habe ja Fleck, Alter.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns das mal ein bisschen im Detail an.
Gucken wir uns erstmal den Medic an, weil das wahrscheinlich da drauf ist,
wo ich schon so ein bisschen drauf schiele, das zu spielen.
Also genau, es gibt, genau, sie hat den 100% Defi.
Sie hat den 100% Defi.
Und an wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich auch Range Healing oder sowas.
Oder, oder Midi-Pack, das wird so eine Art Midi-Pack sein oder sowas in der Richtung.
Aber soweit ich weiß, also wie die das gesagt haben, ist es, dass nur das hier gelockt ist.
Das müssen wir mal sehen, wie es dann wirklich so ist.
Rau als Medic, Freierich ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Warum nicht? Ist mir vollkommen, vollkommen egal. Lost ist jetzt, ready?
Ah nice, ok, dann rufe ich an. Perfekt.
Sprachanruf.
Hallo, hallo?
Hörst du mich? Nice, ja, funktioniert.
Alter, ich bin komplett, ist ein kompletter Clusterfuck bei mir.
Was ist los, was ist los?
Das mit dem Trailer-Ersetzungsrat einwandfrei funktioniert, aber ich versuche das gerade hochzuladen.
Erst ging es, dann war aber die Leitung, weil ich eine andere Leitung nehmen wollte, damit es halt auch safe bleibt.
Die hat dann zu wenig Upload gehabt.
Dann habe ich abgebrochen, musste den PC neu starten, weil OBS mich nicht mehr den Stream anschmeißen lassen wollte.
Ach du Scheiße.
Wo du jetzt dein Kabel gewechselt hast, da musste ich das umstellen.
Jetzt wollte ich den, jetzt wollte ich es hochladen.
Auf einmal fängt an, der Stream zu laggen, was vorher nicht der Fall war, wo es vorher nicht den Upload tangiert hat.
Und jetzt will ich versuchen, auf dem zweiten PC mit der anderen Leitung das rüberzuziehen.
Jetzt ist mein USB so überlastet, dass ich da kein Ding einstellen kann.
Ach du Scheiße, Alter.
Das kotzt mich gerade, ich bin gerade komplett...
Du bist lost sozusagen.
Ich bin komplett lost gerade, no joke.
Komplett lost.
Das ist Mist.
Tut das Upload wenigstens prinzipiell jetzt, oder hast du noch gar nichts?
Ja, Stream und so läuft.
Ich bin auf jeden Fall da, ich versuche das nebenher zu finden irgendwie.
Also wir können auch eine Viertelstunde warten noch, ne?
Also du musst jetzt ja nicht...
Alles gut.
Stopp.
Ja, also Leute, wie ist die Lautstärke so?
Bin ich okay beim Lost und ist der Lost okay bei mir?
Lautstärktechnisch?
Ich glaube bei mir, red nochmal kurz.
Blablabla.
Hallo Jungs und Mädels, hier ist der Max.
Oh krass, jetzt bist du ein bisschen laut gewesen, aber das kann ich...
Ich glaube ich habe auch zu sehr geschrien.
Das kann ich runter.
Ich glaube ich muss dich einen Ticken lauter machen, ne?
Ich kann mich auch ein bisschen lauter machen.
Passt, passt, perfekt, jetzt sind wir gleich laut, alles gut.
Nice.
Alles klar, wunderbar.
Ich habe im Vorfeld mal ein paar Fragen eingesammelt von den Leuten.
Die haben uns zig Dinge gefragt, wo wir wahrscheinlich überhaupt nichts dazu sagen können.
Aber wir können es ja mal probieren.
Ja.
Auf jeden Fall.
Ich habe auch gesagt, die Leute können gerne Fragen stellen.
Das kann natürlich sein, also ich würde sagen, wenn du zu Beginn zumindest die Rolle der Fragen übernimmst, wäre ich dir dankbar.
Dann kann ich mich ein bisschen weiter konzentrieren.
Passt noch, passt noch.
Ich mache noch mal schnell den Trailer an.
Ich lad mir den Trailer mal kurz runter und lasse den im Hintergrund laufen, dass ihn ein bisschen was tut.
Ich schalte ihn auch mal kurz rein.
Chatfenster ist nicht so spannend.
Ich muss ihn erstmal runterladen.
Wie?
Ich darf ihn nicht runterladen?
Wait.
Nein.
Hast du den, hast du den?
Du kannst den, die sind gerade auf dem, der ist auf dem Battlefield-Kanal jetzt online auch in 4K.
Ich lasse den einfach aufgründen im YouTube-Video runterlaufen.
Ja, ich bin nicht eingeloggt.
Alltagsfreigabe.
Zu geil.
Jetzt bin ich auch lost.
Jetzt vorbei.
Okay, auch nicht schlecht.
Wir sind top vorbereitet.
Wir sind top.
Ja, es wird immer Zeug in den Weg gelegt hier.
Kann man noch tricksen hier, dass man das abspielen kann?
Ja.
Jawoll, es geht.
Nice.
Kann ich abspielen.
Okay, ich mache den Sound einfach ein bisschen leiser und machen wir das jetzt hier mal.
Ich kopiere mal die Fragen mal rüber.
Also ihr seht Leute, wir haben uns, wobei das stimmt, wir haben uns tatsächlich im Vorfeld
Gedanken gemacht.
So ist das nicht, aber wir haben nicht damit gerechnet, dass das, doch vielleicht nicht
so funktioniert alles.
Ja.
Okay, ich lasse den Trailer laufen und mache ein bisschen Gedudel im Hintergrund an und
dann können wir anfangen.
Okay, perfekt.
Also erste Frage.
Also ich habe im Vorfeld schon mal erzählt, dass wir erstmal Gameplay gesehen haben, dazu
aber nichts sagen dürfen im Detail und dass wir eine FAQ Session hatten mit DICE.
Das heißt, wir wissen schon ein bisschen mehr als das, was man nur im Trailer gesehen
hat.
Aber jetzt so superspezifische Fragen können wir auch nicht beantworten.
Also wir haben weder den Source Code gesehen, noch haben wir das Spiel irgendwie mal gespielt.
Nee, also wir können zu Gameplay technischen auch halt gar nichts sagen, weil wie du sagst,
wir haben ja nicht gezockt.
Gameplay kommt am 13.
Und da kann man dann mit Sicherheit noch ein bisschen mehr zählen.
Aber so was, was Hintergrund angeht und so, da sind wir glaube ich zu dem zumindest, was
jetzt gerade im Trailer halt in dem Review Trailer zu sehen ist, da haben wir noch einige
Informationen.
Ja.
Also erste Frage, die finde ich super, weil ich bin ja auch so, wie sagt man so schön,
Medic Main.
Die erste Frage, die bei mir total oft im Chat gekommen ist, gibt es wieder einen Medic
Train, so einen Reds Train wie in Battlefield 3?
Nun ja, wir wissen es nicht genau.
Wir haben ja kein Gameplay, also wir haben es wieder selbst gespielt, noch haben wir da
irgendwie jetzt so tiefe Einblicke.
Aber was es gibt, es gibt einen Specialist, der 100% wiederbeleben kann.
Ja.
Also das heißt...
Das ist vielleicht auch...
Ja.
Nee, hau rein.
Ich wollte sagen ja, das heißt im Endeffekt, die Chancen bestehen, dass es so einen Medic
Train gibt, wenn alle diesen Specialist nehmen, was wir halt nicht wissen, ob das vielleicht
ein Cooldown hat oder sowas.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ja, das ist ja das Interessante.
Also das habe ich tatsächlich noch gar nicht erwähnt, was gar nicht so unwichtig ist.
Ich habe nämlich witzigerweise im Vorfeld, ich weiß nicht, ob es dir auch so ging, es
kommen ja immer wieder Leute rein, jetzt gerade auch heute, die dann irgendwie Sachen
noch gepostet haben.
Hey, also das soll ja so sein, das soll ja so sein.
Und man nimmt das ja so auf im Chat, aber man kann natürlich oder geht idealerweise
in dem Moment nicht drauf ein, weil es ist ja auch nicht da.
Ja, das Problem hatte ich auch.
Und was ich ganz lustig fand, weil auch auch ganz cool in dem Sinne, weil ich wusste, wie
es wirklich ist und halt im Internet auch gelesen habe, dass das ja irgendwie das Gerüchte
herrsche, dass es ja jetzt irgendwie wie so in Battlefront so einen Helden.
Helden, ja totaler Blödsinn.
Ein Helden, das totaler Blödsinn.
Weil jetzt gibt es halt, also wie du schon gesagt hast, es gibt Klassen, ganz normal
ja Support, da fällt zum Beispiel diese Medic drunter.
Dann Recon mit Sniper mäßig, also so Aufklärung, Assault ist selbst erklärend und Engineer,
so Anti-Ding.
Genau, es gibt die klassischen Battlefield Klassen, nur dass es jetzt halt verschiedene,
dafür übrigens sich Operator sagen, ganz, ganz böse Specialist, dass es verschiedene
Specialist gibt.
Ich glaube der beste Vergleich, jetzt weil es kamen Leute auch gesagt, so ist das wie
Apex und sonst wie.
Ich glaube man muss sich diese, diese Specialist weniger vorstellen als jetzt so ein Held
in Overwatch oder irgendwie was in Rainbow Six, weil in Rainbow Six ist ja so ein Operator
ziemlich unique.
Da hast du ja komplett alles von der Bewaffnung her bis zu den Gadgets her und sonst was.
Man muss dir sich glaube ich eher als Subklasse vorstellen von den klassischen Battlefield
Klassen, weil du kannst bis auf das Primary Gadget, zum Beispiel hat die Medic Frau eben
100% Defi, 100% Defi wiederbeleben, kann man das komplett Customisen wie man will.
Ja, das ist glaube ich mit das, was die Leute, bin ich gespannt wie sie jetzt darauf reagieren,
weil das ist so eine der, ich glaube eine der größten Änderungen.
Das heißt du hast Klassen, die eine gewisse, ja die halt so ein gewisses Spielfeld halt
bedienen, wie eben der Recon, der so mit dieser Aufklärer, aber innerhalb dieser Klassen
hast du eben die Spezialisten, die, wo jeder, also du kannst, du bist nicht mehr abhängig
davon, welche Klasse du spielst, welche Waffe du hast.
Du kannst als Assault Spieler, kannst du eine Sniper Rifle mitnehmen, Waffen, Sidearms,
Granaten und ein Gadget, was du auswählen kannst zusätzlich, das ist komplett unabhängig.
Du kannst mit jedem Specialist jede Waffe nehmen und das einzige auf das du fest gelockt
bist, ist eben dieses Spezial, also auf den Specialist zugeschnittene Gadget.
Primary Gadget, genau.
Primary Gadget, ja.
Und ansonsten bist du komplett frei und kannst tun und lassen, was du willst, was die Customization
und Waffen und so angeht.
Das ist halt ja so Söldner Style, genau.
Und das ist ja im Endeffekt auch so, also die Theme, es gibt ja, das ist ja auch, wurde
jetzt darin nicht bekannt, aber es gibt keinen Singleplayer, also es ist ein reines Multiplayer
Spiel.
Ja, kein Singleplayer.
Aber die Theme ist ja so ein bisschen, dass Russland gegen Amerika wieder antritt und
die Welt im Rahmen dieser Naturkatastrophen ja so zugrunde gegangen ist, viele Länder
halt auch kaputt sind, überschwommen, Krisen, Flüchtlinge wandern aus und diese Flüchtlinge
werden dann zu diesen Notepads, also Non-Patriots, Notepads kurz genannt und die werden von den
großen Amerika und USA rekrutiert und deswegen passt das mit dem Söldner ganz gut rein.
Und deswegen haben wir auch diese, diese Specialists, die halt Charaktere sind, die
haben dann den Namen, die kommen dann aus Deutschland oder aus irgendwoher und haben
halt so ein bisschen so eine Story, aber das ist halt trotzdem ein Multiplayer.
Genau, ich denke, Storytechnisch wird sich das beschränken so auf die Hintergrundsachen,
wie es auch in Rainbow Six oder Warzone ist, die haben einen Namen, die haben vielleicht
eine Mini-Biografie und das wars.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie da so abgehen werden wie in Overwatch, dass die wirklich Lore-Cinematics
machen für die einzelnen Dinger, für die einzelnen Helden und so.
Mal gucken, mal gucken, ich glaube das hängt davon ab, wie sehr das ankommt und wie, wie,
wie sagt man so, wie immer es dann so die Welt ist und wie die Leute darauf abgehen.
Also wenn die Leute das irgendwie haben wollen, werden sie das machen.
Aber ich glaube letztendlich, es gibt einen Battle Pass, wo es dann einfach immer seine
neuen Specialists drinne gibt, die kriegen einen Namen, die kriegen eine Biografie dran
gepappt und dann spielst du halt und bashst die Leute damit.
Fertig aus.
Das großartige Geschichte und tiefgreifende Story würde ich mir von diesem Battlefield
nicht erwarten.
Die haben dann, die haben dann ein bisschen ein Setting drum herum gestrickt, damit sie
eben erklären können, warum spielst du denn in 2042, warum gibt es denn Umweltkatastrophen
und warum gibt es Specialists.
Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, die wussten vorher schon, das wollen sie machen und dann
haben sie sich halt eine Story drum herum überlegt, dass es irgendwie ein sinnvolles
Setting gibt und fertig.
Also tiefgreifende Story dürfen wir nicht erwarten.
Nee, das auf jeden Fall nicht.
Ich bin nur gerade hinter dem PC, du kannst nur kurz weitermachen.
Ich, ich, ich mach weiter, ja.
Was man eben auch im Gameplay gesehen hat, gerade im Trailer, weil ich eben, ach so,
die seht ihr jetzt beim Lost nicht, aber ich habe gerade die Szene gehabt, wo er gemessert
wurde, was ich mega nice finde, wo er beim Messern das Dogtag abgenommen hat.
Das ist so richtig, so richtig wie, wie ich, ich finde es einfach nice, dass sie das eingebaut
haben.
Vor allem der Moment im Trailer, ich weiß, keine, ich habe jetzt deinen Chat nicht offen,
aber ich glaube, da ist es ähnlich, wo der Typ aus dem Jet gesprungen ist und hat den
RPG reingehauen, da waren sie alle, sind komplett eskaliert.
Ja, das ist der Moment, wo die Leute aufspringen, ne?
Ja.
Das ist der Moment, wo die Leute aufspringen.
Ja, haben wir bei uns im Video ja auf YouTube auch gesagt, du hast ja noch gesagt, du bist
der Mann, der Gefühle zeigen kann.
Ich habe auch gesagt, ich habe nicht geheult, ich habe nicht geheult, aber so ein bisschen,
so ein bisschen Tränen in den Augen hatte ich schon.
Ja, es war so die, die, die, das ist so dieses Gefühl, wenn das so reinsteigen in die Nase,
ne, und dann kitzelt die Nase so und es hat so ein bisschen, der Trainingkanal geht dann
auf und dann, dann merkst du so, oh krass, das ist einfach so dieses Gefühl.
Aber das ist auch, auch mit dem, mit dem Messer, also ich würde mal jetzt behaupten, Dogtags
Confirmed.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Einfach mal so ins Blaue rein, auch, also kann ich mir gut vorstellen, weil das ja auch
ein Feature war, was viele Leute auch gefeiert haben.
Ja, auch viele, oh, ich kann mich an die Zeiten erinnern, wo einfach die ganzen Dogtag-Hunter
unterwegs waren und versucht haben, die ganzen YouTuber und so.
Oder Dice, diese Dice-Dogtags.
Ja, genau.
Voll, also das finde ich nice, das ist auch eine coole, ist halt, sind das so, sind das
so die Kleinigkeiten, weißt du, wo die einen oder anderen auch dazu bringen, halt auch langfristig
so, weißt du, gerade in die Langfristigkeit.
Das sind so coole kleine Features, die einfach so die, diesen Fanservice bieten, gerade auch
die Szene, wie du sagst, mit der, mit der, mit der Rakete, nachdem er ausgestiegen ist.
Das zeigt halt so dieses Sandbox-Battlefield und da wollen sie, das Video ja, das haben
wir in dem Video, das ist so witzig, weil es ist ja vieles, was wir in unserem Video
ja schon erzählt haben, halt wirklich wiedergeben wollen, so dieses Back to the Roots, zurück
in die komplette Sandbox und die Leute halt diese ganzen Memes mit C4, Quad und, und von
mir aus, ich weiß nicht, ob das geht, aber wenn man so Sachen sich erinnert, auch in
Battlefield 4, wo die einen Panzer mit C4, also aus dem eigenen Team, hochkatapultiert
haben, um dann in der Luft mit einem Panzer einen Flieger zu zerschießen und so.
Also sie wollen, glaube ich, wieder so ein bisschen in die Richtung gehen und das finde
ich ganz geil.
Ja, ich auch.
Also ich bin, ich, ich, ich, also ich bin da echt richtig gehyped drauf und im Chat kam
gerade die Frage, wir haben ja gesagt, man kann alles customisen, kann dann auch einen
Medic, einen RPG nehmen.
Das wissen wir so genau nicht, aber ich vermute mal nein.
Also das Primary Gadget, das rate ich jetzt einfach mal, es würde aber, denke aber ergibt
Sinn.
Der Medic hat, der Medic Specialist, der hat seinen Primary Gadget, das kannst du nicht
ändern und du hast noch ein zweites Gadget, das ist bei Medic zum Beispiel ein, so eine
Pistole, wo du Leute über Range mitteilen kannst und sowas.
Also ich vermute mal, dass man dann als jeder, als quasi, dass jeder Medic Specialist einen
Primary Medic Gadget hat und sich noch ein zweites, ein zweites Medic Gadget aus, frei
aussuchen kann, aber ich glaube nicht, dass ein Medic einen RPG mitnehmen kann.
Das ist die Frage.
Das wissen wir nicht.
Ob die auswählbaren Gadgets auf den Spezialisten gelockt sind, die halt da noch zusätzlich
auswählbar sind oder ob es einen Overall Global Pool sozusagen gibt.
Das wissen wir jetzt nicht, aber ja gut, das werden wir dann noch erfahren auf jeden
Fall.
Wäre ja auch blöd, wenn wir jetzt schon alles wissen.
Ja, man muss dazu sagen, wir hatten ja halt die Chance, noch ein bisschen diese DICE FAQ
zuzumachen, aber wir haben jetzt so die richtig krassen Details, die die Leute teilweise wissen,
Leute wissen wollen, wie viel Tickrate hat der Server oder so.
Keine Ahnung, wo soll ich das wissen?
Das kann man leider auch.
Skill-based Matchmaking, weil die Frage immer kam, die wurde jetzt nicht beantwortet, die
hattest du glaube ich sogar gestellt, da sind sie jetzt nicht darauf eingegangen damals
bei dem Ding.
Was ich aber beantworten kann, weil es auch grad kam, vielleicht auch nicht uninteressant,
da ist extra der eine noch mal Haupt-Dude reingegrätscht, was alles, was ja irgendwie
Battlefield 2042 angehen soll, ist Dedicated Server.
Ach, ja stimmt, das habe ich gar nicht aufgepasst.
Da habe ich nicht aufgepasst, als ich das gesagt habe.
Du als Server-Master musst das ja nicht.
Was ich halt cool fänden würde, was es aber nie im Leben geben wird, ist, wenn die Server
hätten, wie sie bis zu Battlefield 3 hatten, dass du dir einen Server mieten musstest bei
einem Anbieter, aber dass du noch Custom Plugins reinmachen konntest und sowas.
Das war cool, da konntest du nämlich so Sachen setzen wie Sniper-Limits, aber ich glaube
nicht, dass das gehen wird.
Ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen, der Trend ging halt komplett weg davon, das zu customizable
zu machen, also ich würde mich wundern.
Das wäre cool, weil es gibt nichts beschisseneres als Rush-Runden, wo 50% des Teams hinten sitzt
und einen nice Range-Shot macht.
Ja.
Das stimmt.
Das wissen wir nicht.
Aber ich komme mal ein bisschen zu den Fragen.
Also ich habe 50 Stück hier insgesamt, die meisten davon können wir wahrscheinlich
gar nicht so im Detail beantworten.
Was ich interessant finde, ist, dass mit Matic hatten wir schon zur Performance, können
wir glaube ich gar nicht so viel sagen.
Ich meine, DICE hat uns das gezeigt, bestimmt nicht auf den schlechtesten Rechnern.
Gehe ich mal voraus.
Wir haben da schon was ordentliches hingestellt, um das zu präsentieren.
Also ja, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie gut die Performance ist.
Aber du hast Battlefield 5 doch recht viel gespielt, oder?
Ja, zu Beginn als es rauskam, die letzten Wochen habe ich tatsächlich immer wieder mal gespielt
und ich habe das den Leuten auch gesagt.
Also ich gehe mal davon aus, wenn du Battlefield 5 spielen kannst auf deinem Rechner, dann
wirst du auch Battlefield 20...
Ich denke auch, ja.
...2042 spielen können.
In welchen, also mit wie viel FPS, abhängig davon, welche Settings du hast, ist natürlich
dann wieder die Frage.
Und mit Sicherheit wird aufgrund der Kartengröße und der höheren Spielanzahl und natürlich
auch der nächsten Version, sage ich jetzt mal, von Frostbite, die natürlich sich weiterentwickelt
hat, wird das einen Impact auf die Performance haben, mit Sicherheit.
Aber klar, wenn du jetzt Battlefield 5 mit 30 FPS auf den niedrigsten Einstellungen
bisher gespielt hast, dann wirst du vielleicht in Battlefield nächsten ein bisschen Probleme
haben.
Aber...
Ich denke auch, ich denke auch, dann wirst du wahrscheinlich Pech haben.
Aber mal ganz im Ernst, ich glaube, man muss sich da nicht so viele Gedanken drüber machen.
Die Games hatten bei Release zwar immer busy viele Bugs, so die letzten, wobei das letzte
ging eigentlich, aber performanstechnisch waren zumindest auch schon die letzten zwei
Battlefields zur Release echt in Ordnung.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall.
Ich glaube, da muss man sich keine Gedanken machen.
Was gibt es?
DLSS 2.0?
Keine Ahnung.
Dazu haben sie nichts gesagt.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es so Sachen geben wird.
Gerade was jetzt so neu angesagt ist an Technik, wird sich ja anbieten, das einzubauen.
Gerade wenn sie ein bisschen vielleicht auf eSport und sowas noch machen wollen.
Kommt aber gleich zu, gibt es ja was, was man da vermutet.
Ich gehe aber auch davon aus, dass es drin sein wird.
Also ich meine immer zuletzt B5 gerade mit Sachen wie Raytracing und Co.
Haben die ja gerade auch mit solchen Sachen ja gearbeitet.
Und ich meine, die wollen das krasse Erlebnis haben.
Die wollen ihre Grafik spielen lassen.
Die wollen den Leuten, die ja mittlerweile, gehöre ich jetzt ja auch dazu,
sage ich auf 1440p oder so upgraden.
Und gerade da ist natürlich ist DLSS 2.0 halt ein mega Ding.
Wer auf jeden Fall da ist.
Gehe ich davon aus, dass sie das mit einbauen
oder spätestens irgendwie mit einem Update noch irgendwie implementieren.
Ich denke auch, ich denke auch.
Interessante Frage, gerade noch im Chat.
Was der Tornado hinsichtlich In-Game-Map-Veränderungen für Auswirkungen hat.
Ja, der Tornado.
Also man hat es ja im Trailer kurz gesehen.
Der Tornado hat gewisse Schneisen.
Also der erscheint, was wir gehört haben, nicht immer an der gleichen Stelle.
Und der ist ja auch nicht unbedingt auf jeder Map.
Also es ist jetzt nicht so, glaube ich, dass jede Map ein eigenes Event haben wird.
Aber zum Beispiel Kaleidoscope war das ja, was wir am Schluss gesehen haben.
Da ist scheinbar dieser Tornado und der kann offensichtlich an unterschiedlichen Stellen sich entwickeln.
Also wirklich, man sieht dann auch, wie er sich formt.
Und dann fährt er scheinbar solche Schneisen durch die Map.
Und der kann, wie man gesehen hat, Fahrzeuge aufheben, Infanterie und so auch aufheben.
Offensichtlich, ich weiß nicht, wie es im Tornado aussieht.
Wenn du da vielleicht von einem Teil getroffen wirst, stirbst du.
Aber du bist normalerweise nicht instant tot.
Und was ja ganz cool ist, da haben wir auch eine Story gehört.
Weißt du noch die Story, die uns erzählt wurde in Bezug auf den Tornado?
Wo er erzählt hat, wie er selbst gespielt hat da, ja.
Ich krieg's nicht mal ganz zusammen.
Zumindest geht's wohl in-game dann darum, dass du kannst, wenn du so ein Wingsuit dabei hast,
kannst du zum Beispiel auch in den Tornado springen und dann damit rumfliegen und sowas.
Ob das die Soldaten 2042 machen, bin ich mal gespannt.
Ja, das Coole war, bei der Geschichte eben, dass...
Also mit der neuen Frostbite-Engine haben sie einen neuen Physik-Engine am Start.
Also irgendwie das Team EA Gothenburg hat ewig lang dran gearbeitet.
Die haben irgendwie erzählt, dass sie vor drei Jahren oder noch länger die Idee hatten,
wie wäre es mit so einem Tornado?
Und die haben dann schon die Hände über den Kopf zusammengeschlagen, weil sie gesagt haben,
ja cool, aber wie soll man das machen?
Also sie haben eine komplett neue Physik-Engine in die Frostbite-Engine integriert,
was zum Beispiel den Tornado jetzt zulässt.
Und da haben sie jetzt eine Story erzählt aus einem Playtest,
wo jemand unterwegs war und wurde von einem Sniper beschossen.
Und dann ist halt der Tornado gekommen und der hat irgendwo ein bisschen weiter hinten ein Auto aufgehoben.
Also vom Boden ein Fahrzeug.
Und hat tatsächlich mit dem Fahrzeug, der Sniper, der da einfach lag, den Sniper platt gemacht.
Also das sind halt so diese Physik-Sachen, wo du halt den Tornado wahrscheinlich auch ein Stück weit nutzen kannst,
um dich auf der Welt vielleicht auch, wie du sagst, bewegst du oder dann irgendwie vorzubewegen.
Aber wie gesagt, keine Ahnung, kann auch sein, dass du im Tornado bist und da sind so viele Sachen, dass die dich erschlagen.
Aber es ist schon ziemlich krass.
Also es ist ziemlich krass, auch diese, die nennen jetzt erst Ground Deformation im neuen Battlefield.
Genau, da haben wieder jede Menge neuer super Wörter sich ausgedacht.
Ja, denke ich All-Out-Warfare und Sandbox-Experience, ganz wichtig.
Das kommt ja, das kommt zusammen so ins Gefühl, jedes zweite Wort erzählt.
Ja, das ist ja das. Also da bin ich noch gespannt, wie das aufgeteilt ist,
weil sie haben im Endeffekt das Game in drei Teile aufgeteilt, so wie sie es uns präsentiert haben.
Und bei den alten Battlefield-Teilen würde man jetzt denken, ja, okay, du hast halt Multiplayer, du hast halt Singleplayer und dann irgendwie noch was.
Aber das erste, wie du sagst, das ist All-Out-Warfare und da haben sie uns ja gesagt,
das ist jetzt, was wir jetzt bisher wissen, ist halt Conquest und Durchbruch auf jeden Fall.
Genau, Breakthrough hast du. Also sprich, du hast Conquest, so die klassische Geschichte mit,
wir haben Fahnen und nehmen Sektoren ein oder ein bisschen größere Areale ein.
Die Maps sind größer, da wird es wahrscheinlich auch mehr Punkte geben.
Haben sie ja auch gesagt, dass die eine Hälfte der Maps sich komplett anders spielen wird als die andere Hälfte der Maps
oder jeder Sektor der Maps sich unterschiedlich spielen wird.
Du hast bei der einen Seite Wüste und Panzer-Battles, bei der anderen hast du Innenstadt-Battles.
Dann hast du vielleicht irgendwas, wo es Landefahrzeuge gibt und bei dem anderen hast du, wo Chats am Start sind und sowas.
Also die Maps sollen wohl mehr so Richtung, es ist zwar eine große Map, aber von der Abwechslung her
soll es wohl so sein, dass es eher so drei, vier verschiedene Play-Styles unterstützt.
Also sprich, du kannst als Chat-Pilot abgehen in manchen Maps und du kannst aber auch die Maps dann als Infanterist spielen.
Was jetzt ja, wenn man mal zurückguckt, sagen wir mal, sowas wie Caspian Border und so,
da sind natürlich die ganzen Chat-Dudes richtig scharf drauf.
Aber jetzt für die Infanterieleute ist es dann halt eher nichts.
So wie es sich für mich aus sich dargestellt hat, versuchen die halt möglichst viele Play-Styles auf den Maps unterzubringen.
Ob es klappt, müssen wir mal gucken.
Ja, was ganz cool ist, was du gerade auch angesprochen hast.
Ich hab auch, ich hab den Leuten schon gesagt im Vorhinein, ey, wir werden hier jetzt wahrscheinlich einiges besprechen,
was ich in den Videos auch erzählt hab und mich würd's freuen, wenn man trotzdem den Klick und vielleicht die Wortschreiben doch gibt.
Ja, aber cool, wenn ihr unsere Videos noch nebenher laufen lassen wollt oder einfach auch noch mal in Ruhe anschaut,
weil wir beide, Max auch auf seinem Kanal, MaxFPS auf YouTube, machen Videos jetzt auch zu Battlefield
und haben auch jetzt schon Videos oben zum neuen Teil, wo wir eben über das, was wir gerade eben auch erzählen, auch reden.
Und es würde uns natürlich freuen, wenn ihr uns die Wortschreiben zusätzlich noch geben würdet, weil das für die Algorithmen sehr gut ist.
Das wäre nice, ja.
Ihr könnt es ja nebenbei aufmachen, einfach oben Loop andrücken, dass das dann immer, ne?
Stimmt, genau, genau.
Weil dann können wir hier frei von der Seele erzählen und müssen nicht denken, ja kacke, dann guckt sich keiner mehr das Video an.
Aber die Sektoren, die du angesprochen hast, sind glaube ich auch noch ein großes Ding.
Wenn man es jetzt mit dem als große Änderung, vorne hatten wir jetzt so dieses neue Klassensystem.
Da war ich am Anfang ein bisschen, da war ich mir nicht so sicher.
Da dachte ich mir, es gibt jetzt Instanzen, weißt du?
Ja, das hab ich auch nicht richtig gecheckt am Anfang.
Aber jetzt hast du ja aufgrund der Mapgröße und der vielen Spieler, haben die es jetzt aufgeteilt in Sektoren, die ganz normal begehbar sind.
Also du drops halt, startest in der Main Base oder was auch immer und dann latschst du halt irgendwo hin, wo du hin willst.
Aber jetzt hast du ja im Endeffekt Sektoren, in denen mehrere Flaggen sind.
Zum Beispiel auf der größten Map, Breakaway, dieser Antarktis-Map, gibt es in Conquest-Modus zehn Flaggen.
Und die sind aufgeteilt auf Sektoren, das heißt du hast zum Beispiel ein Sektor, wo zwei Flaggen sind und du musst beide einnehmen, um den Sektor einzunehmen.
Welchen Boni dir der ganze Sektor am Schluss bringt, das ist jetzt nicht wie bei Breakthrough, dass du den abgeschlossen hast und dann musst du die nächsten einnehmen bei Angriff und Verteidigung.
Das wissen wir jetzt nicht ganz.
Aber das Coole ist ja, die haben das ja so auf Socombat-Zones aufgeteilt.
Genau und du musst, das ist auch ein Unterschied zu so einem klassischen Conquest, du musst, dass du so einen Sektor erobern kannst, musst du alle Flaggen in diesem Sektor erobern.
Also das ist im Prinzip so eine Art, nennen wir das mal so eine Art Domination in so einem Sektor.
Und wenn man quasi dieses Domination gewinnt, dann kriegst du den Sektor, also in Breakthrough jetzt.
Ja, und die anderen können natürlich wieder einnehmen.
Genau, also ich bin gespannt, wie sich das spielt.
Was mir persönlich ja ein bisschen gefehlt hat, ist, da haben sie sich sehr nach vorne gedrückt.
Das war eine Frage, die kam auch, ob es Rush wieder geben wird.
Wir wissen es nicht.
Ich hätte es gerne.
Ich hätte es echt gerne.
Ihr wisst, Rush ist mit Abstand mein Lieblingsspiel-Modus, wobei ich Conquest so auch in letzter Zeit wieder mich ein bisschen mit angefreundet habe.
Aber Rush wäre schon echt geil.
Wobei ich es mir persönlich ein bisschen schwierig vorstelle, wenn du wirklich Maps hast, die so riesengroß sind.
Wie viele M-Coms willst du da machen?
20 oder?
Das ist die Frage, ja.
Aber um den Hype für dich auch aufrecht zu halten, muss man ja sagen, sie haben gesagt, sie können aktuell keine Antwort darauf geben.
Natürlich sind weitere Sachen geplant und wir sollen mal gucken, was die Zukunft noch bringt.
Also ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass sie Rush reinbauen.
Weil gerade, ich meine, das ist ja, der neue Teil ist so ein bisschen, wie sie da vor Ewigkeiten angekündigt haben.
Back to the Roots, ja auch eine Hommage, gerade durch das Setting an Battlefield 4 und Battlefield 3.
Und was war denn der Modus, der gerade Battlefield 3 ja auch geprägt hat?
Ich meine, trotz, er war ja bei Bad Company schon am Start, aber Rush ist halt so das.
Neben Conquest mit der Modus, die die Leute feiern.
Die zwei, die zwei.
Die haben angefangen, die haben angefangen, Bad Company 1.
Da gab es ja am Anfang nur Rush, das gab dann DLC mit Conquest.
Das ist jetzt Boomer Talk, wahrscheinlich kennt das keiner mehr.
Aber in Bad Company 2 war ja Rush auch ganz fett und dann mit Battlefield 3 auch.
Danach ging es ein bisschen runter.
Man muss sagen, ich persönlich bin der Meinung, die Battlefield 4 Rush Maps waren okay, aber sind nicht bei weitem nicht an Battlefield 3 und Bad Company 2 rangekommen.
Das stimmt, ja.
Mal gucken, was sie da jetzt machen.
Und ja, die Fragen im Chat, die haben es einfach ignoriert, wenn du sowas gefragt hast.
Oder sie haben sich halt davor gedrückt, das zu beantworten.
Aber klar, was sollen sie machen?
Sie können nicht auf alles im Detail eingehen.
Finde ich auch okay, in manchen Sachen wollen sie sich aus taktischen Gründen vielleicht noch aufheben.
Aber Rush wäre auf jeden Fall trotzdem super, ja.
Rush wäre auf jeden Fall geil.
Passend dazu kommt gerade die Frage, ob es einen Competitive Mode gibt.
Und das ist jetzt so eine Sache.
Da würde ich kurz einsteigen.
Und zwar mit einem, wie sagt man, mit einem weinenden Auge und mit einem lachenden Auge.
Ja, so was.
Das wäre der zweite Punkt vom All-out Warfare.
Also diese drei, ich nenne sie jetzt einfach mal die bisher bekannten und uns kommunizierten drei Säulen von Battlefield 2042.
All-out Warfare, Conquest, Durchbruch, bisher bestätigt.
Scheinbar klassische Modis, die da reinkommen.
Der zweite Punkt ist, das habt ihr jetzt gar nicht mitbekommen.
Aber das ist ein weiterer Modus und der nennt sich Hazard Zone.
Und es ist kein Battle Royale.
Es ist kein Battle Royale.
Das war der Moment, wo ich mir so dachte, ah, Scheiße.
Was ja nichts heißt.
Und da schließe ich kurz an, damit die Frage beendet ist.
Deswegen auch ein bisschen mit einem weinenden Auge.
Die Frage, also ihr müsst euch vorstellen, wir waren ja da in diesem Briefing drin.
Da gab es auch einen Live-Chat.
Gerade in der Fragerunde war gefühlt jede dritte Frage im Chat, ob es Battle Royale gibt, ob es Battle Royale gibt, ob es Battle Royale gibt.
Sie haben gesagt, es wird zu Launch kein Battle Royale geben.
Und es stehen momentan ist Battle Royale nicht geplant.
Das sind zwei unterschiedliche Aussagen.
Einmal zu nicht zum Launch und einmal nicht geplant.
Die immer noch Hoffnung da lassen, dass irgendwann das vielleicht passiert.
Aber sie haben im Zuge dessen stark betont, dass man die Augen und Ohren offen halten soll,
wenn der Reveal vom neuen Hazard-Modus kommen soll, weil der in Squad-basierter Modus ist.
Und scheinbar so ein ganz neues Ding im Battlefield.
Genau, also für mich hat es sich so angehört.
Also jetzt erst einmal zu dieser Battle Royale-Geschichte.
Ich denke immer noch, es wird einen Battle Royale geben.
Die lassen sich nicht, die gucken doch nicht zu, wie Activision Millionen mit der ganzen Geschichte macht.
Und sagt doch, nö, wir haben es probiert, wir haben da jetzt keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Es wäre einfach blöd, in der heutigen Zeit keinen Free-2-Play-Teil zu machen.
Und Battle Royale ist einfach das, wo die Leute jetzt auch Bock drauf hätten,
nachdem Ravensoft bei Warzone sich jetzt auch nicht unbedingt mit Ruhm begleckert hat,
so die letzten Patches über. Das würde einfach passen.
Und sie haben gesagt, Hazard Zone ist definitiv kein Battle Royale.
Und ich glaube immer noch dran, nächstes Jahr Free-2-Play Battle Royale.
Aber zu Hazard Zone ist halt die Sache, dass sie gesagt haben,
das wird so ein High-Stakes-Squad-Based-Modus.
Also sprich, du spielst nur mit deinem Squad, wo wir übrigens nicht genau wissen, wie groß das Squad ist.
Ich vermute mal vier, man weiß es nicht.
Es könnten auch maximal fünf sein, ansonsten wird es vielleicht ein bisschen viel.
Oder hast du irgendwas mitgekriegt?
Interessant, weil die Frage kam auf in der Fragerunde, ob wir wieder mit vier Leuten im Squad sein werden.
Und da war ja, das ist ja immer das Coole, da gab es keine Antwort drauf.
Was heißt, also sie haben ja nur gesagt, da können wir momentan noch nicht drüber reden.
Was bedeuten könnte, dass sie entweder intern noch die, vielleicht noch Änderungen haben
und noch nicht sicher sind, ob sie vier oder mehr machen.
Aber was ich mir vorstellen könnte, ist, dass sie so ein übergreifendes Ding machen,
wo sie zum Beispiel sagen, aufgrund der Spielerzahl und so.
Weißt du, wenn du jetzt irgendwie mehr Timmy, Peter und Steve im Teamspeak hast,
aber du bist halt ein krass erfolgreicher Dude und gut angesehen,
und hast halt noch Xaver, Paul und Anton mit dabei,
dann gucken die erstmal die Röhre, weil die denken, ja fuck, wir können nicht alle ins gleiche Squad.
Jetzt pass auf, ich kann mir vorstellen, dass sie sowas bringen, wo du Squads connecten kannst.
Und dann so eine Art, ich weiß nicht, wie das im militärischen Terminus heißt, aber irgendwie Company.
Regiment oder was auch immer, ja.
Genau, und dass du dann auf der Karte zwar in deinem Viermann Squad bist,
aber trotzdem im 3D, also auf der Karte, auf der Minimap und in dieser 3D-Map sozusagen,
trotzdem in der speziellen Farbe, ich glaube, das war immer so ein bisschen so ein Grün,
halt deinen Sidesquad siehst und weißt du, wo die sind, und dich trotzdem mit denen koordinieren kannst.
Das wäre schon ganz geil.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass sie sowas machen, weil 128 Spieler schreit ja im Endeffekt danach,
dass du irgendwie ein bisschen übergreifend koordinieren kannst.
Vierer Squad, klar, wenn du einen Vierer Squad aus richtig guten Leuten hast,
hat das auch bei 164 gegen 64 Impact, ganz klar, vor allem, wenn die Fahrzeuge stark sind.
Dafür hamst du wahrscheinlich Kills noch und nöcher, also zumindest wenn es ansatzweise so ist,
mit den alten Battlefield-Teilen.
Aber es wäre natürlich merkwürdig, wenn du keinerlei Möglichkeiten hättest,
bei 64 gegen 64 irgendwie die Squads miteinander zu verbinden.
Also ich könnte mir echt vorstellen, dass du so ein übergreifendes Team machen kannst,
dass du dann halt keine Boni bekommst, falls es sowas gibt.
Wir wissen ja nicht, ob Squad-Perks oder sowas gibt, also du wirst dann keine Boni drauf bekommen
und du wirst auch nicht direkt von irgendwas profitieren aus den anderen Leuten in diesem Team.
Aber ich könnte mir schon vorstellen, wenn du mit acht Kollegen spielen willst,
dass du dann zwei Squads machen kannst und wenn ihr zusammen joint,
werden die anderen mal zumindest noch in der Farbe hervorgehoben,
weil ansonsten ist ja Koordination überhaupt nicht richtig möglich.
Du blickst ja gar nicht durch, wer was ist.
Also ich denke, es wird sowas sein, wie du das schon vermutest.
Haben wir nichts zu gesehen, aber es wäre echt schwach zu sagen,
wir pumpen einfach die Spieleranzahl hoch, machen aber nichts für die Übersichtigkeit.
Aber so blöd sind die nicht.
Also die sind ja auch schon gekommen.
Also es ist ja, Menschen entwickeln ja im Internet auch offensichtlich mehr Freundschaften.
Ja gerade aktuell.
Der muss dann irgendwo anders unterkommen bei irgendwelchen Randoms.
Aber das sehe ich genauso.
Also ich glaube auch, dass das wahrscheinlich in die Richtung geht, was sehr cool wäre.
Was auch cool wäre, ist so Platoons.
Weißt du noch damals so Community-Sachen?
Und so eine Art Clans machen konntest.
Ja das wäre auch geil.
Damals haben wir auch nichts gehört, aber...
Und weißt du was dann kommt?
TwitchTV als Clantech, das ist das erste.
Ja, Klassiker natürlich.
TTV.
Ja, ich sehe es schon.
TTV ist einfach vom Server basten.
Und erstmal schön Streamers nie in Stream snipen.
Natürlich.
Übrigens hast du was gehört zu Commander-Modus?
Ich bilde mir ein, da haben die nichts zugesagt, weil der Chat grad fragt.
Ne, Commander-Modus nicht.
Ich glaube, dass die Leute da in dem Chat, äh, in dem FAQ gefragt hatten, aber da sind
sie nicht drauf eingegangen.
Ich sag mal so, aufgrund der Größe und den neuen Maps, würde es sich grundsätzlich,
glaube ich, könnte man das gut integrieren.
Weil halt echt, ne, so mit diesen, wie es ja damals auch war im BF2, Fahrzeugabwurf,
Deastars und so.
Ich wäre jetzt nicht mad, wenn es keinen geben würde.
Aber ich kann mir auch, also es ist so 50-50.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es einen geben wird und sie halt erst announcen, weil es
halt eine größere, das wäre dann eine größere Sache, also wieder mal in Commander-Modus.
Aber es kann auch sein, dass es sein lassen, weil sie vielleicht denken, ja, mit Spieligkeiten
wäre es dann von 128 Leuten, also von 64 Leuten pro Team der Dude, der dann den Commander
bekommt.
Weil das haben sie ja in Battlefield 5 im Endeffekt ein Stück weit so gelöst.
Da gab es das ja auf das Squad bezogen.
Der Squad Leader, der mit seinem Squad die Punkte gemacht hat, konnte ja dann Unterstützungs-Sachen
rufen.
So eine V1-Rakete oder eine Rauchband oder ein Artillery-Schlag.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass so was vielleicht wieder passiert.
Aber gut, das werden wir sehen.
So was kann ich mir auch vorstellen, aber ich glaube nicht in Form von einem Commander.
Aber kommen wir vielleicht gleich noch mal zu, weil da gibt es auch Sachen zu Fahrzeug-Sporn
und Killstreaks und so, wo ich mir was aufgeschrieben habe.
Nächste Frage ist, weiß ich, ob ich schon kurz angesprochen habe, Skill-Based Matchmaking.
Keine Ahnung, wissen wir nichts zu.
Haben sie nichts gesagt?
Haben sie sich vorgedrückt?
Spätestens aber in dem Ranking-Modus natürlich.
Ich meine, Ranking ist der Inbegriff von Skill-Based.
Wie soll das sonst funktionieren?
Dann eine Frage, da können wir auf jeden Fall was zu sagen.
Da wissen wir was zu.
Gibt es Lootboxen?
Und soweit ich weiß, gibt es keine klassischen Lootboxen, die du dir irgendwie mit Echtgeld
oder sonst wie kaufen kannst oder Random-Faktor.
Es gibt einen Battle Pass, so wie das aktuell eigentlich so angesagt ist.
Genau.
Das habe ich vorhin auch kurz erwähnt, weil ein paar Leute gefragt haben.
Das ist nicht unwichtig heutzutage.
Ich meine, für manche ist es komplett irrelevant.
Aber da ist ganz wichtig zu sagen, der Battle Pass, es gibt vier Seasons, die für das
erste Jahr angekündigt wurden.
Das heißt, es soll vier Battle Pass geben.
Das ist bisher bekannt.
Und da gibt es halt neuen Content mit Maps, wahrscheinlich auch Waffen.
Specialist.
Neue Specialist.
Fun-Fact, kommen wir gleich noch dazu.
Aber wir haben vier Specialist mitbekommen, die es geben soll mit den speziellen Gadgets.
Es soll zu Launch zehn geben.
Also das wird sich wahrscheinlich auch, wie du vorhin schon mal erwähnt hast, zum Vergleich
zu Rainbow Six Siege, wo ja auch immer neue Operator dazu kamen mit unterschiedlichen
Fähigkeiten, wollen die halt auch zu jeder Season neue Specialist dazu packen.
Das heißt, was ich ganz cool finde, weil du bist dann nicht einfach nur der Dude wie
früher, ja ich spiele gern Medic oder ich spiele gern Sniper, sondern du kannst halt
innerhalb dieser Klassen, Subclass oder so, diese Subclassen halt spielen und neu entdecken.
Und das Coole ist auch, sorry aber, das Coole ist auch, du bist nicht gezwungen dann zum
Beispiel zu sagen, oh ja ich spiele mir jetzt den Sniper frei und spiele meine Sniper hoch.
Weil Progression ist global.
Das ist egal, egal welchen Specialist oder so du spielst, du shares im Endeffekt die
Erfahrung darin und bist nicht gezwungen zu sagen, ah ja kacke, jetzt will ich die eine
Waffe freischalten, aber die gibt es nur beim Engineer, aber den spiele ich so ungern, sondern
du machst das global und das ist ganz cool.
Und ansonsten hast du im Pass, wie du schon gesagt hast, das ist halt Cosmetics, also
für den Bezahlbaren werden halt kosmetische Inhalte sein, Skins für Waffen, Soldaten,
Fahrzeuge und Gadgets scheinbar, wahrscheinlich, ich kann mir vorstellen Drohne oder so dann.
Die müssen Skin bringen, weil 10 Operator hört sich jetzt, na gut hört sich ehrlich gesagt
jetzt noch nicht immer viel an, hört sich eigentlich relativ wenig an, wenn du überlegst
128 gegen 128, deswegen die müssen Skins und Outfits bringen, sonst spielst du den Operator
und du hast auf jeder Seite gefühlt die gleichen Dudes, na das wäre ja total hängen geblieben.
Bei 128 gegen 128, 10 Operators, da sieht ja im Prinzip, das sind ja alles Clones voneinander
und das wird nicht sein, also ich gehe davon aus, dass du die Operator ziemlich stark auch
optisch customisen kannst, deswegen sage ich ja auch, man sollte, ich finde Operator ist,
das wirkt so wie ein Overwatch, ich finde Subclasses passt einfach viel besser, weil
du hast halt so eine spezielle Fähigkeit, das ist wie so im Rollenspiel, wo du am Anfang
so Character Creation sagst, ok ich möchte jetzt Heiler sein, aber ich möchte jetzt
Heiler sein, der Fokus auf das und das legt. So und so kannst du das da auch machen, du
nimmst dann zwar den Specialist, der den 100% Defi hat, den kannst du ja aber komplett
customisen und ich denke sowohl in Optik als auch eben von Loadouts und wir haben eine
ganz wichtige Sache noch vergessen, was Waffen Loadouts angeht, du kannst, zum ersten Mal
gab es so noch nie einen Battlefield.
Warte, warte, warte, warte, warte.
Ich glaube ich weiß wo auf die hinaus bist, die Frage ist, können wir darüber reden?
Also ich weiß, dass es in einem gewissen Abschnitt behandelt wurde, den wir noch nicht
behandelt dürfen, wurde es aber, ja ich glaube es wurde angesprochen in dem Segment davor.
Das wurde, das hat man.
Ich glaube.
Ja, ja doch, doch, das hatten sie.
Hey, uns kennt eh keiner, erzähl, hau raus.
Also.
Achtung, jetzt kommt's.
Achtung, Trommelwürmer.
Riesen, Riesen.
Also ich kann mir, ich kann mir vorstellen, sorry, ich kann mir vorstellen, dass der eine
oder andere jetzt gleich, ähm.
Sagt, ich kauf das Spiel nicht.
Genau, genau, der eine sagt, ich kauf es nicht, der andere sagt, boah richtig geil.
Ja und jetzt oder aber sagen, richtig geil und jetzt.
So, jetzt hau ich's mal raus und zwar du kannst jetzt zum ersten Mal deine Waffen customisen
während du am Spielen bist, also ich rede jetzt nicht davon, dass du, dass du stirbst
und dann in einem Editor neues Electen kannst.
Du kannst zum Beispiel, wenn du Sniper spielst oder sag mal du spielst Recon, hast deine
Waffe dabei mit einem Red Dot drauf, dann kannst du deine Drohne hochschicken und die
macht dein LW für dich, du setzt dich kurz in die Deckung und schraubst dir einen Scope
drauf.
Das kannst du, kannst du wie in Crysis.
Denkt euch.
Ja, Crysis, genau.
Genau.
Stand auch grad bei mir drin.
Wenn ihr Crysis, grade Crysis 1 gespielt habt, so dieses, dieses HUD mitten im, mitten
im Display, wo du dann auswählen kannst, Schalldämpfer drauf, Schalldämpfer runter, ich will ein
anderes Visier haben, ich will sonst was machen.
Du kannst deine Waffe, wohlgemerkt nur die Waffe, also du kannst glaube ich nicht dein
komplettes Loadout ändern, das wäre ja auch ein bisschen beknackt, ja, aber du kannst
die Waffe komplett customisen, während du quasi zu Fuß unterwegs bist.
Das ist cool, das gibt schon deutlich taktische Tiefe.
Wie es sich spielt, ich mein wir müssen auch mal ganz ehrlich sagen, du hast am Ende
was gesagt in dem Video, was wir aufgenommen haben, es kann sich immer noch wie kurzes
spielen am Ende, das wissen wir nicht, ja.
Ja, Gameplay, das wissen wir nicht, wie es läuft, wie es aussieht, na, aber, aber die
Funktion finde ich auch ganz interessant, weil du ja wirklich, es ist, also es ist glaube
ich, so wie ich das verstanden hab, es ist waffentechnisch, also du wehst schon die
Waffe ab, du kannst es nicht direkt in der Runde einfach von der einen Waffe auf die
andere wechseln, aber du kannst, du hast diverse Slots, also es gibt vier Customization Slots,
das ist Visier, das ist Lauf, das ist Griff und das ist Magazin Attachment.
Genau.
Und da hast du diverse Slots, ich glaube es sind drei Stück, die du pro diesen Customize
Slot freischalten kannst, die du wiederum mit sogenannten Attachment Presets, nenne
ich jetzt mal, belegen kannst, zum Beispiel halt Vordergriff, angewinkelter Griff oder
besser beim Lauf, Schalldämpfer, Compensator, Flash Hider.
Und dann kannst du mit der Waffe, wo du das definiert hast, im Spiel zum Beispiel oder
beim Visier entscheiden, ok ich laufe jetzt in Close Quarter Situation, ich packe ein
Red Dot drauf, oh jetzt bin ich draußen auf weiter Entfernung, da sind vielleicht Leute
den Sniper oder so, ich packe mir ein ACOG Visier drauf, vierfach, und kann halt im Einzelfeuer
den besser bekämpfen als mit einem popeligen Red Dot, weil der halt irgendwie 300 Meter
weg ist.
Genau.
Schalldämpfer stelle ich mir halt geil vor, weil vor allem, wir wissen nicht hundertprozentig
wie das Spotting und die Maps funktionieren in dem Game, aber normalerweise ist ja so,
wenn du sinnlos rumballerst ohne Silencer tauchst du auf der Map aus, mit Silencer
nicht.
Und das wäre natürlich eine sehr sinnvolle Geschichte, wenn es eine Map ist mit unterschiedlichen
Playstyles, stell dir mal vor, du läufst so von außen quasi in die Close Quarters Area
der Map, dann ist draußen mit dem Schalldämpfer über Range natürlich Müll, da triffst du
nichts, Kugeln sind zu langsam, was auch immer, aber dann gehst du in den Close Quarters Sektor
rein, machst erst mal den Schalldämpfer drauf, dass du nicht mehr auf der Map erscheinst
und Close Quarter besser abgehen kannst.
Find ich, ist echt eine coole Geschichte.
Steht und fällt natürlich, genau, wollte ich gerade sagen, steht und fällt damit, wie
gut das gemacht ist, wie flüssig das geht.
Ja, das ist die Frage.
Wir haben so ein, wir haben ein bisschen Menü gesehen, da weiß ich aber nicht, ob wir
viel zu erzählen dürfen, aber denkt an Crysis, kommt ungefähr, kommt ungefähr hin.
Ja, denkt an, ich glaub Crysis, Crysis ist ein guter Vergleich, ja.
Da sagen wir jetzt nicht, wie es ist, wir sagen einfach so, denkt an Crysis.
Denkt an Crysis.
Was, gibt es, ja, sorry.
Glaub ich.
Also vielleicht haben wir jetzt noch was Falsches gesagt.
Ach, passt, passt, passt.
Ich guck mal nach.
Guck noch mal, wie es Crysis aussieht.
Ich lese, kann noch mal schnell was aus dem Chat vor, weil ich glaube, das macht keinen
Unterschied.
Wo ist besser vorbestellt, Steam oder Origin?
Ich glaube, es ist letztendlich wurscht, aber du wirst eh Origin starten müssen, gehe
ich mal stark von aus.
Das war bisher bei allen der letzten Battlefield-Teile so.
Also Battlefield ist jetzt ja komplett auf Steam, aber immer, wenn du Battlefield startest
über Steam, startet der Origin und dann startet der Battlefield.
Also, ja, keine Ahnung, wo es besser ist, kann ich dir nicht sagen.
Schwierig, ja.
Unter dem Strich macht es eigentlich keinen Unterschied.
Nee, eigentlich nicht.
Ja, ich kann noch mal sagen, denkt an Crysis.
Ich hab gerade angeschaut.
Was nicht heißt, man muss ja dazu sagen, Disclaimer, was nicht heißt, dass sich das
noch ändert, ne.
Ich meine, die befinden sich entwicklungstechnisch ja noch nicht am kompletten Ende.
Aber ja.
Ja, da wird sich in der Richtung wahrscheinlich nicht mehr viel ändern.
Aber genau, denkt einfach an Crysis.
So, nächste und wo habe ich jetzt mein Zeug hier?
Nächste Frage wäre Crossplay.
Da bin ich mir gar nicht, haben die was zu Crossplay gesagt?
Ja, ja.
Also, ich glaube, das ist vorher schon bekannt gewesen.
Jetzt machst du mich gerade ein bisschen kirre, aber meines Wissens ist Crossplay bestätigt, ja.
Okay.
Crossplay ist aber nur, ja, also Crossplay, okay, ich glaube, das ist logisch.
Ich denke, Crossplay natürlich mit der neuen Generation, also PS5, die neue Xe und PC.
Gehe ich davon aus, aber ganz, ja, stimmt, jetzt wo du es sagst, haben sie es explizit angeschaut?
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich glaube es schon.
Ich gehe auch von aus.
Es wäre blöd, jetzt, man hat es in anderen Spielen gesehen, die das vorgemacht haben
und das läuft in Warzone ja auch sehr erfolgreich.
Man muss eh sagen, also die Inspiration für mich ist da schon klar zu erkennen.
Ich finde, die haben ganz klar aus Rainbow Six sich Sachen abgeguckt und sich ganz klar
aus Modern Warfare und Warzone abgeguckt.
Auch wie das, die ganze Kombination, links und rechts sicherlich auch nochmal ein bisschen
ein Auge geworfen auf CS, Apex und was es sonst noch alles gibt, aber Rainbow Six und
Warzone dürften da so die Haupt-Inspirationsquellen gewesen sein.
Plus natürlich die alten Battlefield-Teile.
Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass das irgendwie ein Rainbow Six oder Warzone-Klon wird.
Das glaube ich nämlich nicht.
Ja das Ding, also ich meine gerade was Cross-Platforming angeht, ist halt, man muss natürlich so sehen,
das ist halt Industriestandard wird das werden.
Also Cross-Platforming geht es auch.
Immer mehr, ja.
Ich meine, ich habe da auch oftmals darüber geredet, gerade in so Sachen, weil du Warzone
erwähnt hast.
Man kennt es als PC-Spieler und vielleicht auch für die Konsolenspieler.
Man muss ja fairerweise sagen, es geht ja in die eine und die andere Richtung.
Kann natürlich Cross-Platform, ist gerade im Beispiel Warzone, ist halt hart.
Wirkt manchmal schon so, dass halt gewisse Sachen wie Aim Assist kommt dann aufs Game
drauf an, aber auch einen gewissen Impact haben.
Und es würde mich freuen, wenn man das natürlich als PC-Spieler deaktivieren kann, aber der
Industriestandard würde in die Richtung gehen, weil es langfristig für jede Plattform
halt die Spielerzahl erhält.
Korrekt.
Denke auch.
Also ich glaube, es gibt so Sachen, da muss man sich gar keine Gedanken eigentlich großartig
drüber machen, selbst wenn es jetzt nicht kommt.
Wir werden das in Zukunft bei fast jedem größeren AAA-Multiplayer-Spiel haben.
Wie gesagt, das ist Cross-Player und leider auch so Skill-Base-Matchmaking und so ein
Shit.
Das ist ein anderes Thema.
Lootboxen hatten wir schon.
Dann gibt es auch noch was.
Battle Royale zum Start haben wir auch schon gesagt.
Wurde was zu Anti-Cheat erwähnt.
Weil habe ich nur gerade gelesen, wollte ich nur kurz darauf eingehen.
Also ihr könnt davon ausgehen, dass solche speziellen Fragen noch nicht beantwortet wurden.
Das ist auch mit Skill-Base-Matchmaking.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass sie sowas auch nicht wirklich beantworten werden, weil sie damit
keinen Raum geben wollen.
Gerade in Bezug auf Cheating werden sie nicht irgendwie großartig was sagen, außer ja, wir
haben ein Anti-Cheat-System.
Die Details wirst du, ich gehe mal davon aus, dass du solche Details wie zum Beispiel Anti-Cheat
nicht bekommen wirst, bevor das Game draußen ist eine gewisse Zeit und irgendwelche Leute
krasse Analysen fahren.
Genau.
Ich denke auch, dass sie selbst nichts dazu sagen.
Die werden in üblichen Geschichten sagen, ich kann mich noch an Overwatch erinnern,
da hat Blizzard ja auch immer sehr vage erzählt, so nach dem Motto, wir arbeiten mit Experten
in diesem Gebiet zusammen, blablabla.
Also das, was jeder immer sagt, wo du dir nichts runter vorstellen kannst.
Im Endeffekt, ich glaube, es ist so sicher, wie sagt man so schön, wie das Abend in der
Kirche, das wird schnell Cheats geben und es wird über kurz oder lang immer mehr Cheats
geben.
Die große Frage ist ja gar nicht, ob es Cheats geben wird.
Das ist ja sicher zu 100% instant.
Bei Beta-Release ist das am Start, bin ich mir sicher, dann schon.
Das ist eine Multimillionen-Dollar-Industrie.
Da wäre man naiv, wenn man meine würde, es gäbe ein Multiplayer-Spiel, gerade Shooter,
wo keine Cheats existieren.
Letztens haben sie ja in China, wo es Leute in den Knast gesteckt haben, die Cheats entwickelt
haben und so was.
Zumindest, ich glaube, es steht und fällt damit nicht, ob es Cheats oder keine Cheats geben
wird, sondern wie die damit umgehen.
Also sprich, wie schnell geht das Ganze ganz vonstatten.
Also wenn die das dann machen wie manch andere Spiele, die erst mal ein halbes Jahr sagen,
es gibt keine Cheats, es gibt keine Cheats, obwohl es überall Cheats gibt, die das erst
mal machen und sagen, unser Spiel ist sicher, gibt es gar nicht und dann nach einem halben
Jahr mal eine Bannwelle von 5000 Leuten machen, dann ist natürlich Fail.
Das wird das Spiel aber dann auch dauerhaft beschädigen, wenn das so ist.
Die müssen da halt hinterher sein, dass das schnell geht, dass die Leute schnell gebannt
werden und dass man eben auch den Eindruck hat, die tun da was aktiv dagegen.
Ich glaube, es erwartet niemand, dass sie das Spiel komplett cheaterfrei halten.
Das geht gar nicht.
Man muss zumindest den Eindruck haben, ja, die geben sich Mühe und man muss halt sehen,
okay, ich kann das Spiel normal spielen, ich treffe halt ab und zu meinen Cheater, okay,
aber nicht so nach dem Motto, ich darf nicht anfangen, jeden das in Frage zu stellen,
dass es ein Cheater gewesen ist.
Dann ist es verkackt, ja.
Revolution, fragt gerade jemand.
Revolution.
Tja, gut, es gibt dynamische Wettereffekte, dynamisches, weiß nicht, ob es Tag-Nachtwechsel
gibt, sah ein bisschen so aus, weiß ich jetzt aber nicht genau.
Ja klar, und es geht ziemlich viel kaputt.
Ja, also Revolution gibt es.
Ja, also klar, wir haben ja den Tornado gesehen.
Das sind Revolution-Elemente und das habe ich vorhin angesprochen, mit dieser Ground
Deformation, also es wird durch Explosionen und so, das kennt man ja jedenfalls schon,
also die Möglichkeit geben halt so Krater oder so wahrscheinlich auch zu erzeugen.
Und dann hast du sehr viele so, keine Ahnung, ich nenne es jetzt einfach mal Mini-Events,
also wenn du irgendwie, es gibt Brücken, die du hoch und runter fahren kannst, es gibt
Zip-Lines, die man benutzen kann, es gibt so Pöller im Boden, so Absperrungen, die man
holen kann, Türen, die man, oder so Tore, wo man halt irgendwie locken kann, dass du
Wege versperrst oder den Weg aufmachst.
Inwieweit du jetzt, keine Ahnung, bei einem Gebäude oder so, irgendwie eine Hauswand
im Sinne von Bad Company oder auch dem, oder jetzt auch in Battlefield V ging es ja auch,
zerstören kannst, wissen wir jetzt nicht, wurde jetzt noch nichts gezeigt, wird wahrscheinlich
noch kommen, aber ich gehe mal davon aus, dass solche Sachen auch möglich sind, also
ich glaube schon, dass du mit nem Panzer durch die Gebäude auch fahren kannst.
Ja, geh ich auf jeden Fall von aus, ich vermute mal, dass das so sein wird, im Kern das, wie
es auch in Battlefield 3 und 4 gewesen ist, du kannst vieles kaputt machen, aber du kannst
nicht die ganze Map komplett dem Erdboden gleich machen, weil dann hast du ja keinen
Gameplay mehr, was wäre eine Close Quarters Innenstadt Area, wenn die nach 15 Minuten
Gameplay nicht mehr steht und das alles nur noch Feld ist.
Ja.
Ich glaube, tragende Elemente, du kannst Mauern rausschießen und so was, aber ich glaube,
tragende Elemente der Map-Struktur, die sie spielbar machen, werden schlicht und ergreifend
nicht zu Revolution sein, das wird einfach da bleiben, alles andere wäre auch irgendwie
beknackt.
Ja.
Ja, du hast halt, was gerade auch drinsteht, das ist mit der Rakete und so, die Rakete,
die ihr gesehen habt, die kann starten und die kann einen erfolgreichen Start haben und
die Elon Musk auf dem Mars fliegen, die Rakete kann aber auch durch diverse Einschnitte, kann
die Rakete auch nicht so wirklich starten und das endet dann in einer entsprechenden
Veränderung des Map-Layouts, ja.
Ähnlich wie wir es ja bei Siegfried Shanghai in Battlefield 4 zum Beispiel hatte, wo der
Langkang-Damm, wo der Damm gebrochen ist, ich wünsche niemanden einen Dammbruch, aber
ja, solche Sachen werden auf jeden Fall wieder da sein.
Wie groß der Umfang dabei ist, müssen wir mal gucken, aber dadurch, dass Sie ja von
Next Level und allem reden, gehe ich davon aus, dass es schon sehr imposant sein wird.
Ja, denke ich auch.
Also ich denke, Sie werden alle Register ziehen, was technisch da irgendwie möglich ist und
auch noch irgendwie halbwegs auf der alten Konsolengeneration tut und ich hoffe halt,
Sie übertreiben es aber nicht zu sehr, weil Siegfried Shanghai war gerade so ein Ding,
irgendwann, du hast einfach keinen Bock mehr drauf gehabt, du wusstest, okay, die Map startet,
zwei Minuten später fällt das Haus um, easy.
Also das muss auch nicht sein, ich finde, es ist cool, das kann man so auf alle Games
übertragen, es ist cool, wenn Sie so Sachen einbauen, aber wenn man sie einfach nur einbaut,
aber uns will und sie dann jede Runde unbedingt zeigen muss und sie jede Runde immer wieder
kommen und immer gleich und so, dann ist es auch irgendwann doof.
Aber da müssen wir mal gucken, wie gesagt, wir haben es nicht gespielt, wir können das
noch nicht einschätzen.
Was wir auch nicht einschätzen können, ist, was hier zum zwanzigsten Mal jemand im Chat
schon fragt, ist, ob es wieder Battlelog geben wird.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich vermute nicht.
Ich glaube es auch nicht.
Also es ist ja sowas, was die Leute auch so ein bisschen hinterherweinen, muss man
ehrlicherweise sagen, so gerade natürlich von Battlefield 4 auch noch.
Da wurde nichts dazu gesagt.
Ich kann mir auch vorstellen, ich habe das auch schon ein paar Mal thematisiert, dass
Sie es wahrscheinlich aufgrund des Mehraufwandes separat noch mal irgendwie das nicht machen.
Ich meine, Sie haben versucht in Battlefield 5 und Battlefield 1 das Ganze ja in-game
mäßig zu lösen.
Muss ich ehrlicherweise sagen, ist ein bisschen gescheitert.
Ich fand das In-Game-Menü von den letzten Battlefield-Teilen, gerade BF5, nicht so geil,
teilweise auch ein bisschen unübersichtlich.
Gerade der letzte, da habe ich nie durchgeplatzt.
Das war mir zu hoch.
Aber ich würde jetzt einfach mal mit Deiner Hand ein bisschen ins Feuer halten und würde
behaupten, dass kein System zurückkommt, was du außerhalb im Browser-Form benutzt,
sondern dass Sie das integrieren.
In der Hoffnung natürlich, dass Sie halt das cooler machen, intuitiver und halt irgendwie,
keine Ahnung, wie auch immer halt so.
Ein Battle-Lock im Spiel, halt 2021 Edition so.
Ich denke auch nicht, dass es das geben wird mit Battle-Lock.
Ich fand es cool.
Ich fand die Verwaltung von Gruppen und allem über den Browser viel einfacher, weil so
was kannst du halt auf Webseiten besser machen, als wenn du es halt extra programmieren
musst für den Game.
War schon cool, auch Squats vorher erstellen und so.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass das kommen wird.
Vielleicht sehen wir irgendwie eine Companion-App.
Sowas ist ja heutzutage auch ganz angesagt, dass man vielleicht da ein bisschen einfacher
Leute drüberinviten kann, Freundeslisten managen kann, wie auch immer.
Kein Schimmer.
Wir können nur raten.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich hätte noch mal die nächste Frage.
Ich würde die gleich mal hier raushauen, weil da können wir einiges zu sagen.
Was?
Paar Zeuge.
Und zwar, man hat ja im Trailer das mit dem RPG gesehen und dem Raussteigen.
Und wir haben ja schon in unserem Video auf YouTube vermutet, dass das eventuell bedeuten
könnte, es gibt weniger Animationen.
Also du musst nicht mehr ein- und aussteigen und dich dabei killen lassen und sowas.
Ist unsere Vermutung.
Wir wissen es nicht genau.
Wir haben es nicht bei Panzern gesehen.
Wir haben es von dem Jet.
Aber es ist halt die Frage.
Was meinst du?
Einsteigen?
Direkt drin spawnen?
Oder wie wird das mit den Fahrzeugen?
Also ich muss ehrlich sagen, klar für die Immersion ist das natürlich ein großes Ding.
Ich habe es in Battlefield 5 aber tatsächlich immer so ein bisschen gehasst, weil ich während
dem Einsteigen das eine oder andere Mal weggeschossen wurde, weil du erhaltbar bist.
Rein Gameplay-technisch würde ich es grundsätzlich schon cool finden, wenn du die Animationen
nicht hast.
Wenn du einfach ein- und aussteigen kannst.
Das macht das Ganze dynamischer.
Ich meine, wenn du was realistisches spielen willst, dann bist du bei Battlefield grundsätzlich
eh falsch.
Battlefield war ja nie semi-realistisch oder so.
Es war immer ein Arcade-Shooter.
Und ich glaube, dass es dem Spielfluss guttun würde, wenn du einfach ein- und aussteigen
kannst.
Jetzt tut sich der eine oder andere aufregen und sich denken, ja, aber das kannst du voll
abusen.
Ja gut, aber du kannst es ja auch dann nutzen.
Und das zeigt ja auch einen krassen Spieler, wenn er zum Beispiel eine Möglichkeit nutzt,
irgendwie wegzulaufen, rüber zu sliden.
Sag ich jetzt mal, vielleicht kann man wieder ein bisschen sliden, so wie B5.
Kannst du wahrscheinlich, ja.
Und dann steigst du kurz in ein Fahrzeug, einfach du beschossen wirst und wechselst
auf den anderen.
Auf der anderen Seite raus.
Auf den anderen raus und gehst weit.
Du hast solche Sachen, solche Manöver.
Das finde ich dann schon cool und das kannst du im B5 nicht.
Da steigst du in ein Fahrzeug ein oder aus.
Und bist entweder tot oder...
Ja.
Ja, genau.
Nee, ist so.
Ich bin da auch, ich hab's auch total auf den Videos gesagt.
Ich frag mich eh immer noch, warum die mich eingeladen haben.
Ich hab die letzten zwei Teile fast nur geflamed, aber gut, hab ich gedacht, na, müssen die
alten Leute mal wieder mit ansprechen.
Das hat mich auch übelst abgefuckt.
Wenn du da, wenn du quasi laufend durch irgendwas über...
Ich mein, gerade in Battlefield 5 oder 1, ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher, wo ist es
dann auch voll übertrieben an?
Du hattest bei allem irgendwelche Animationen.
Irgendwelche Werkzeuge rausholen, bauen, irgendwelche drüberspringen Animationen, 5000
Dinger, dann erst mal Tür aufmachen vom Panzer und rein öffnen.
Das war so nervig.
Ich wollte einfach nur ein flüssiges, ein flüssiges Game haben.
Und man hat ja auch gesehen, dass sie das ursprünglich noch viel krasser machen wollten,
weil viele Animationen wirkten in diesen Spielen auch total vorgespult.
So nach dem Motto, als hat sich jemand brutals viel Mühe gegeben, die detaillierteste Animation
aller Zeiten zu erstellen.
Und dann haben die Gameplay-Designer gesagt, Leute, wir können denen keine 30-Sekunden-Einsteiger-Animation
abspielen, die Leute flippen aus.
Und dann haben sie es vorgespult um 30%.
Also, ich hoffe, sie lassen es einfach weg und gut ist.
Ja.
Du, ich würde dir mal ganz kurz das Wort übergeben.
Ich muss ja ganz schnell pinkeln.
Ja, kein Problem.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Ich bin da, bin voll im Mund.
Aber jetzt habe ich gerade runtergeschluckt.
Habe ich noch ein Getränk hier?
Getränke sind auch schon leer.
Würde es eine Killcam geben?
Gibt es keine Infos?
Das sind auch so Sachen, Killcam.
Ich meine, das ist eine interessante Frage, muss ich zugeben.
Das interessiert mich grundsätzlich auch.
Aber das würde ich gleich so ein bisschen in die Richtung auch mit dem Anti-Cheat stellen.
Das werden wir vorher schon erfahren, aber das werden wir auch erst mitbekommen,
wenn wir das Game wahrscheinlich antesten können.
Weil am 13. soll ein Gameplay-Trailer kommen.
Aber ich gehe mal davon aus, dass sie einen Gameplay-Trailer nicht so gemacht haben,
dass du dort eine Killcam siehst, wenn eine drin ist.
Ergo wird sich das erst ersichtlich zeigen,
wenn man das selber wahrscheinlich im Rahmen von einer Beta oder so spielen kann.
Also da kannst du jetzt auch nicht wirklich was zu sagen, leider.
Das kleine Auto in der Tornado-Szene ist einfach 10 auf 10.
Ich habe das im Endeffekt, also das ist ein futuristisches Tuk-Tuk,
wie auch immer man es nennen soll.
Das fand ich geil, das will ich auf jeden Fall fahren.
Da sehe ich mich auch darin mit C4 komplett vollgebappelt, irgendwo reinzufahren.
Mich in den Tornado zu bewegen und dann mit dem Tuk-Tuk einfach mit C4
und Wingsuit einfach auf irgendjemanden zu stürzen.
Fun Fact, Wingsuit kann ich schon erwähnen.
Ich nehme damit ein Detail voraus über die Klassen im Battlefield 2042.
Der Wingsuit ist klassenabhängig, bzw. spezialistenabhängig.
Also der Wingsuit soll, die Information haben wir bekommen, weil wir die Frage haben,
der Wingsuit ist abhängig davon, welchen Spezialisten du hast.
Also soll heißen, dass scheinbar nicht jeder automatisch auch einen Wingsuit hat.
Fallschirme mit Sicherheit, klar, aber Wingsuit ist abhängig.
Gesehen, was auf dem Schild steht bei dem Ding? Ja, sehr nice, passend dazu.
Das wird wahrscheinlich auch ein Game dann sein, bin ich mal gespannt.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall sehr cool.
Steckt man ein Fahrzeug wieder direkt, darüber haben wir gerade...
Ach so, kann ich auch nicht sagen.
Das ist auch so eine Frage, die wird man erst mitbekommen, wenn man Gameplay antesten kann.
Das sind sehr, sehr spezifische Fragen für einen Reveal.
Also ich kann verstehen, dass die Frage aufkommt.
Das sind so Sachen, die interessieren mich auch, weil ich immer Fan von war, von den alten Teilen.
Du spawnst in der Maimis und läufst zu deinem Fahrzeug hin und steigst ein
und startest von der Landebahn mit dem Chat in die Luft.
Was ich aber sagen kann, passenderweise dazu, du wirst die Möglichkeit bekommen,
auf der Map über ein gewisses Menü, wahrscheinlich hast du ein Tablet dabei oder so,
dir Fahrzeuge zu droppen. Du hast zum Beispiel die Möglichkeit,
dir ein Quad oder Transportfahrzeuge, was auch immer, an eine Position, wo du bist, zu droppen.
Das kommt dann runter, hängt dann so einen Fallschirm dran,
hat so Schubdüsen dran, die den Fall abbremsen so ein bisschen
und dann kannst du einsteigen und ab dafür.
Wir wissen aber noch nicht, weil das wurde nicht erwähnt, wie das kombiniert ist.
Also ob jetzt am Schluss jeder, ob am Schluss 128 Leute in einem Tank hocken können,
bezweifle ich mal ganz stark.
Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass das irgendwie mit Punkte gekoppelt ist,
so ein bisschen wie das System aus Battlefield 5, wo du im Squad Punkte machst
und dann für die Punkte unter anderem auch Fahrzeug anfordern konntest,
neben Artillery Strike und so.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass das irgendwie gekoppelt ist,
aber damit wollen sie auch die Möglichkeit bieten, weil vorhin auch die Frage aufkam,
bzw. der Kommentar kam, wo wir gerade über Sniper und dieses Klassensystem geredet haben,
weil jede Klasse, jede Waffe hier auswählen kann,
dass sich dann 90 Sniper auf der Map bewegen.
Ich bin übrigens wieder da.
Ah ja, sehr nice. Ich bin gerade bei dieser Frage wegen Fahrzeuge und Droppen
und jetzt mit diesen Klassen, weil die Übergang auf diese 90 Sniper laufen darum.
Die haben das damit eigentlich ganz cool erklärt, weil gerade durch diese neuen Zonen
oder diese Sektoren, wo du dann wahrscheinlich irgendwann,
wenn du es gespielt hast und gesehen hast, es gibt verschiedene Combat Zones in den Sektoren
und diese im Endeffekt so gestaltet, dass du halt je nachdem, was für eine Art von Action du hast,
du bist zum Beispiel Fahrzeugfight oder halt Close Quarter Infanterie, kannst du speziell dahingehen
und da weißt du, da geht es halt richtig aufs Fressbrett im Nahkampf
oder dass in Panzerfights einfach viel mehr Fläche ist.
Und dadurch, dass die Karten größer sind und sie halt umgehen wollen,
dass du über hinlaufen musst ewig lang, haben sie dieses Dropsystem
und damit umgehst du auch die Tatsache, dass du halt ständig,
natürlich kann das mal vorkommen, aber ständig über freie Fläche läufst,
wo halt irgendwo ein Sniper hockt und dich halt wegsnipe, weil er den krassen Vorteil hat.
Also wir hocken irgendwo auf dem Hill und 20 Leute aus dem Team von 32,
wo wir früher snipen, da irgendwie runter.
Klar kann es sein, das ist immer abhängig davon, wie viele Leute das spielen,
aber sie wollen eben das auch balancen so, dass du die Möglichkeit hast,
halt nicht ständig da dran zu sterben.
Und ganz wichtig auch, das ist sowohl bei Conquest als auch bei Durchbruch wahrscheinlich umso mehr,
weil Durchbruch ja so ein Clash ist, die einen verteilen, die anderen greifen an.
Die Maps sollen beide mehr Flankierungsmöglichkeiten haben, gerade auch bei Durchbruch.
Das heißt, du bist nicht gezwungen immer in den harten Cluster zu laufen
und wenn du Angreifer bist, dir erstmal zu denken, ja fuck, auch wenn es mir Spaß macht, weil der Progress so da ist.
Jetzt muss ich erstmal mit fünf bis zehn Tode rechnen, je nachdem, was du für ein Spieler bist,
was der mit dir motivieren sein kann. Du hast mehr Möglichkeiten zu flankieren,
bist nicht gezwungen in den Cluster zu laufen und was ich ganz cool finde für die Piloten unter euch da draußen,
die haben das aufgeteilt, die haben das erklärt in Inner Comet Circle und Outer Comet Circle.
Inner Comet Circle ist auf den Maps ja so dieses Infanterie, ne?
Crosswater ist Infanterie, ja.
Genau und Outer Comet Circle ist, was im Endeffekt Flugzeuge haben,
weil die haben ja mehr Reichweite, wenn du zum Beispiel in den alten Teilen mit der Infantristen bist du irgendwo in die Red Zone.
Genau, sie verlassen das Schlachtfeld, blablabla, fünf Sekunden.
Genau. Und das ist jetzt größer, sowohl für den Inneren Circle scheinbar, was ich jetzt noch in Erinnerung habe,
aber gerade auch für den Outer Circle. Das heißt, wenn du in einem Chat unterwegs bist,
fühlst du dich nicht mehr so, wie es auf manchen Karten der Fall war, als würdest du in einem Goldfischglas rumfliegen,
sondern du hast viel mehr Weite, wo du halt auch mal richtig ausholen kannst
und halt das Gefühl hast von weitaus offeneren Maps und so. Das finde ich eigentlich auch ganz cool
und bietet halt eben auch diese Möglichkeit, mal hinten rumzusneaken und nicht immer in diesen Cluster rein zu marschieren,
vor allem bei 128 Leuten.
Die Chance ist auf jeden Fall da, gerade in Kombination auch, dass du dynamisch deine Attachments wechseln kannst,
da kannst du das dementsprechend anpassen. Also, es steht und fällt natürlich damit,
die können viel einbauen, viel erzählen, ist halt die Frage, wie es dann im Endeffekt umgesetzt ist,
aber ich habe ein gutes Gefühl, das sagt natürlich noch gar nichts, was da im Ende rauskommt,
aber alles das, was ich bisher gesehen habe, ich war ja am Anfang auch total skeptisch,
ich habe gesagt, oh nee, den letzten Battlefield Teilen haben wir überhaupt nicht gefallen
und jetzt müssen sie mich erstmal wieder richtig überzeugen.
Ich kann es jetzt nochmal sagen, ich pre-ordere definitiv nicht, ich habe mir das komplett abgewöhnt,
so den Kram zu pre-ordern, aber sie haben mich zumindest ein Stück so weit jetzt schon zurückgewonnen,
da ich sage, okay, ich interessiere mich jetzt richtig wieder aktiv für das Game
und werde da quasi die News komplett bis zur Release verfolgen, hey,
und wenn es dann halt kacke ist, dann ist es halt kacke, ich meine, da kann man nichts dran ändern,
aber die Chancen, finde ich, für mich sehen insofern schon besser aus,
und ich bin dreimal mehr gehyped als bei den letzten Battlefields oder zehnmal mehr gehyped.
Wir waren ja zusammen in Berlin bei Battlefield 1 damals, das haben sie auch,
wir waren ein cooler Trainer und alles, wir haben uns danach dann auch angeguckt,
das war ich einfach gesagt, ja, es ist schon cool irgendwie, aber...
Dafür, dass es das erste Weltkrieg war, ja.
Ja, aber so, so nett, so, ich hatte da nie, als ich das gesehen habe, dieses Gefühl,
so dieses, boah, ist das geil, so wie bei den Jets jetzt zum Beispiel, ja,
sondern so, ja, es könnte ganz nice werden, ich weiß nicht so recht,
aber das hat mich jetzt schon so überzeugt, vielleicht haben sie einfach nur gute Cutter
und gute Marketingleute, aber das hatten sie in Battlefield auch,
in Battlefield 3 auch, Battlefield 3 war richtig krass vom Aufbau her,
wie sie das gehyped haben, und am Endeffekt hat es das Spiel aber halt auch gehalten,
weil du kannst noch so viel hypen, wie du willst im Vorfeld,
und alles übelst ausflippen, und dann kommt das Game raus,
und eine Woche später wird es nicht mehr gespielt, weil es kacke ist, ja.
Zum Beispiel, du hast links hier mitgewolzen, dieses RPG, dieses Diablo-Style,
wo fanden auch am Anfang alle voll geil, Game kommt raus, eine Woche später, dead.
Ja, das fand ich schade, ich hab's auch ein bisschen angespielt, aber ja.
Kann da immer noch passieren, aber sie haben mich insofern abgeholt jetzt mit dem Trailer,
und, ja, wo waren wir, genau, bei den Fahrzeugdrops, ich denke schon,
dass sie sich da was bei gedacht haben, nämlich gerade aus einem Hauptgesichtspunkt,
wenn die wollen, dass du Infanterie spielen kannst, was sie ja müssen,
es können nicht nur 28 Panzer auf der Map rumfahren,
und die Map größer ist auch für Infanteries, da müssen die irgendwie was zur Verfügung stellen,
dass du von A nach B kommst, das geht gar nicht anders,
sonst hast du keinen gescheiten Spielfluss, du hast einen gescheiten Sektor erobert,
willst zu dem nächsten Sektor fahren, und wenn du keinen Quad droppen kannst,
oder wenn es da nichts gibt, das funktioniert nicht,
da brichst du 10 Minuten am Rennen so groß, wie die Maps sind, das macht doch keinen Spaß.
Ja, also das haben sie ja extra betont, weil ich glaube, sie wissen,
also sind sich da auch sehr bewusst darüber, dass das halt ein großer Game-Breaking-Faktor werden könnte,
und haben sich nochmal betont, dass sie da wirklich auch mit den Mechanismen und so dran gearbeitet haben,
um das eben zu verhindern, dass du halt wirklich so dieses, ich nenne es mal so diesen PUBG,
dieses PUBG-Feeling hast, dass du halt irgendwie einen Firefight hast,
und dann erst mal eine Viertelstunde durch die Gegend läufst,
die haben das so schön beschrieben so, ja, du bist an einem Punkt und kämpfst halt,
und das ist halt echt Action, und es ist sowieso, dass du abhängig davon,
wann die Gegner wiederkommen, kannst du theoretisch auch die ganze Map an einem Punkt bleiben,
wenn du dir wieder verteidigen willst, und dann kommst du halt kurz zum Durchatmen,
weil du den Punkt eingenommen hast, und dann guckst du auf die Map und entscheidest,
ok, da gehen wir hin, lässt dir ein Fahrzeug droppen, zack, boom, ab dafür,
und bist halt in kürzester Zeit am nächsten Punkt, und zwischendrin kann ja auch wieder was passieren,
ist halt, ist natürlich abhängig davon, was die Spieler draus machen,
aber es wird kein so, und das kann ich ganz gut vergleichen mit Battlefield 1942,
L.A. main Erlebnis, da hatte ich oft, deswegen hab ich die nicht so geil gefeiert,
das war ja die größte Map aus BF 1942, das war ja, nur Wüste,
aber es war halt echt, wenn du infantryst warst, und du bist in der main base gespohren,
meistens waren die Fahrzeuge weg, dann bist du erstmal, dann bist du,
ungelogen, erstmal ein paar Minuten gelaufen, bist du irgendwo an irgendeiner Stelle was,
wo irgendwo auch was passiert ist, meistens bist du aber vorher von dem Tank weggeschossen worden,
der irgendwie aus 500m dich weggeknallt hat auf den Hügel, oder ein Flugzeug hat dich erschossen,
erschossen und das wollen sie komplett umgehen ja das ist ganz geil das stimmt
weil es gerade im chat kommt das habe ich eben auch gesagt das hat als ich das
ganze konzept gesehen habe und so hat mich das so ein bisschen an planet
zeit 2 erinnert ich kenne das aber ich habe es nie gespielt
das ist so ein bisschen ja es hat auch so ein vibe und ich habe vor monaten habe
ich mal im stream so ein bisschen diese diese idee gedroppt stellt euch vor das
game geht so in die richtung planet zeit 2 weil da kam so das gerücht auf so mit
128 leuten und so größere maps und wie und es ist so ein stück weit geht's
glaube ich also hat es auch so ein bisschen so ein vibe also wird mich nicht
wundern wenn sie sich daran auch ein bisschen orientiert haben kann er
durchaus ganz nice vor weißt du von wem ist das vor weißt du welche
mehrstelle das ist keine ahnung ich wollte noch eins schnell sagen zu den
zu diesen zu diesen drops es wäre natürlich bescheuert es so zu machen
dass jeder auf der map sich in tank droppen kann also das muss an irgendwas
gekoppelt sein sei es dass du ich also ich persönlich denke es wird an
captures oder sowas in der richtung gekoppelt sein dass du dann quasi sagen
kannst hey du hast jetzt drei capture points und es wird dann wahrscheinlich
verschiedene drops geben was du machen kannst angefangen von keiner mit dem
bike nem quad nem l.a.v. bis hin zu irgendwie nem fetten panzer was auch
immer kann ja alles sein und das kannst du dann je nach capture capture points
oder wie auch immer machen also es wäre beknackt wenn es nach timer geht und
nach fünf minuten top dann einfach 128 spieler in panzer das kann es nicht sein
und ich glaube so blöd sind sie nicht das werden sie auch nicht machen es gab
noch eine frage über bei mir im chat ob wir nähe infos zu diesem robo hund
haben ob das den battle pick-up wird oder den squad feature wissen wir nicht
nach battle pick-up sah bisher nix aus ich habe nichts gesehen was irgendwie nach
battle pick-up aussieht also ich kann mir ich kann mir gut vorstellen also weil
du es gerade noch mal erklärt das hatte ich auch kurz erwähnt dass du also kurz
auf der toilette warst dass man auch irgendwie wie ein bf5 schermer punkte
sammelt und sich dann vielleicht was holen kann und vielleicht gehört dieser
robo dock dazu aber vielleicht wird es auch wie wie dieser war in battlefield 4
tatsächlich irgendwo ein pick-up was man aufnehmen kann aber ich glaube dass
sie davon weggehen weil die leute dann drauf geiern wenn das ja das steht du
stehst den ganzen tag da und war das gleich sponti sniper gleich sponti
wal-het-sniper gleich sponti wal-het-sniper
und es wird mit sicherheit nicht nur irgendwie einen hund geben und so es kann auch gut sein
wenn die leute das dann nehmen dass es hat dann irgendwie auf einmal 10 20 hunde
halt auf der auf der map unterwegs je nachdem groß ist ja vielleicht ist er
vielleicht ist der hund auch ein primary gadget von einem specialist kann ja auch
sein je nachdem was der kann ja ich bin gespannt daybreak ist das
übrigens also h1c1 die das planet site gemacht haben
ach die sind das ok ne wusste ich wusste ich auch nicht nicht da wechseln auf
wirst du die von h1c1 das sind wir können doch kurz erwähnen wie viele maps gibt
was ist was wir für maps gesehen haben dürfen wir dürfen wir erzählen also ich
glaube zum release sind sieben maps also was sie gezeigt haben sind folgendes es
gab eine map in meine meine ordnung hier da drin ist ja auch natürlich der
wahnsinn also es gibt es genau das erste war kaleidoskop das ist in süd korea das
ist ein bisschen so ein bisschen die city map das ist glaube ich auch das was
man im trailer gesehen hat wo die leute dann von den von den häusern runter
jumpen wo es also sonnig ist wo die von den häusern runterspringen das sind
süd korea erinnert mich hat mich ein bisschen an sie zu shanghai erinnert
haben sie auch erzählt viel vertikales gameplay außen gibt es wasser drum wo
dann landefahrzeuge hinkommen können und es gibt eine komplette
fernsehstationen wo dann close quarters drinne ist da genau das ist das
kaleidoskop dann haben sie noch irgendwas in singapur
wie hieß denn das ding mani nee ich glaube es kann sein dass manifest
manifest war das manifest mit dem container mit dem container hafen mit
den kran und im container hafen wo viel heli wo viel heli gameplay ist und so
lasten kranz die boxen rumheben und rumtragen und ich wahrscheinlich auch
erschlagen können und du kannst wahrscheinlich dann auch obendrauf da
gab es ja dann irgendwann auch mal was wurde an einem battle hook sich da
hochgeschossen hat und was auch immer also das ist auf jeden fall ein bisschen
mehr richtung close quarters würde ich sagen dann hat man was gibt es dann noch
das ist wohl in französisch gojana das neugineer ist das ja genau das ist
diese raketen basis die ihr gesehen habt schon auch in den allerersten leaks auf
die reddit leute die sind ja wirklich so so richtig diese twitching also richtig
free hat ja teilweise auf reddit ich weiß nicht ob du mal geguckt hast die
letzten tage da gab es da auch ein leak von dem cover art von battlefields 2042
da haben die leute das gepostet so als leak und die antworten da drunter war
nene guck dir mal die farben manne das sieht so falsch aus das kann nicht sein
so was würde da ist niemals veröffentlicht wie schlecht der
hintergrund ist und ich denke mir so und ich denke mir so
oh paint champ paint sehr gut es ist halt es ist halt reddit genau reddit ja maps
wir haben noch discarded das ist wohl in indien sieht ein bisschen aus wie das
container ship aus fahrkreis das ist das was man ganz am anfang vom trailer
gesehen hat wo diese diese verrosteten riesen schiffe rumstehen dann haben wir
genau angeblich ist dann auch in den u-boot in einem der schiffe unten drinnen
und was vielleicht kann man mit dem rumfahren das wäre natürlich richtig
cool keine kein schimmer dann haben wir noch borderline in egypten da bin ich
mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher ich glaube das ist diese map die mit so einer mit
so einer wand in der mitte getrennt ist wo du auf der einen seite ganz viel
wiese hast du auf der anderen seite hast du hast du wüste ja ich muss ich muss ich
kann die map gleich mal gerade einblenden dabei ich bin ich bin so
fies natürlich nur kurz berichtigen dass haben sie umbenannt hat renewal die
mehr das habe ich nicht mehr gelesen was sie da noch geschrieben und das ist
die map das ist tatsächlich die einzige map die wir nicht in diesem review
trailer gesehen haben und das fand ich so interessant das habe ich aber wir haben
screenshot genau das ist im endeffekt eine map ja mit einer mauer die gezogen
wurde durch die map und auf der einen seite zum endeffekt so ein bisschen
brachland so wüstenanteile und auf der anderen seite das war halt eine
komplett florierende vegetation auch mit so einem mit so einem solar park
nenne ich jetzt mal solar panel und die sieht auch interessant aus auf jeden
fall ja denke ich auch bin mal gespannt darauf wie sie das wie sie das machen
wollen ob man an die mauer tatsächlich kaputt machen kann oder ob das so ein
tragendes element in der map ist wo man sagt hey das geht nicht aber mal
gespannt genau das ist aber gut da kann ich die screenshots dazu einblenden
das hier bei der way das ist die map die vorher erwähnt hat mit der mit der
raketenbasis die habt ihr ja gesehen dann ist hier das mit dem container
hafen das war container war diskade ne container hafen war manifest
container hafen ist manifest genau da gibt es noch hourglass das nicht mal so
heißt oder wie war das hourglass ist die mit dem hourglass ist die neon city
da genau ich glaube das ist die hier mit den hochhäusern und im stadion drin ja
es könnte könnte das sein genau die finde ich sie ziemlich krass ich
sieht richtig geil aus gerade bei nacht sieht das sieht das mega nice aus
ach hier oben steht sogar hourglass in der teilnahme big brain chat chat hat
wieder erkannt wer guckt denn auch in der teilnahme
zumindest genau das ist hourglass das ist close quarter fight in den bei den
bei den gebäuden und im stadion da bin ich da bin ich mal gespannt wie sie das
hand haben gerade die ganzen wüste nicht dass sie dann wirklich fünf minuten
rumlaufen muss und wir haben glaube ich leider kein bild von der doch von der
schnee map weil das ist nämlich die letzte map die ich noch nicht gesagt
habe und zwar bin ich jetzt nicht sicher hat sie mich korrigiert dass die jetzt anders heißt
ich habe irreversible aufgeschrieben jetzt breakaway breakaway ok das ist
also das ist das ist breakaway es steht auch noch irreversible im
datainamen drin und da haben wir jetzt nicht so viel ahnung von außer dass es
eine radarstation gibt und das ist die größte map im gesamten spiel sein soll
ja mehr mehr wissen wir dazu nicht also sieben maps anscheinend zum start und ich
vermute halt mal dass es dann mit je nach season und wie sie es auch machen
ich glaube nicht dass es oder was meinst du wie das ist ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass es zu jeder season neue maps gibt sondern eher nicht so jede
zweite season oder wie wollen sie das machen stand das ich kann es mir aber
schon gut vorstellen dass es kommen wird weil wenn du wenn du überlegst dass die
seasons auf vier seasons im ersten jahr aufgeteilt wurden dann ist
wahrscheinlich liegt es nahe dass alle drei monate was neues kommt und ich schon
glaube dass mit jeder season auch mindestens eine neue map kommt gerade
was multiplayer shooter halt angeht ist das finde ich immer so wichtig
müssen sie ja eigentlich müssen sie aber was wollen was wollen die sonst
großartig an content machen klar klar skins und alles aber das ist halt nicht
was die leute dann wieder dazu bringt zu sagen ja ich mache jetzt mal
battlefield an neuer skin also ich glaube es doch schon bestätigt durch die
preorder sachen dass irgendwie im battle pass beziehungsweise in den neuen
updates ein specialist dabei sein wird neuer pro pro season ja das heißt wir
haben im ersten jahr neu vier neue specialist wenn sie sich das wenn sie
diese vier dinger beibehalten ob das auch auf die maps bezogen ist ich gehe
davon aus dass es mindestens eine neue map auch pro season gibt und man darf ja
auch man muss ja das ist ganz interessant weil die frage wurde
tatsächlich gestellt und ich habe vorhin noch ein paar fragen gesehen wo ich
sag ja die sind so krass also da kannst du nicht darauf eingehen weil das sind
so detaillierte fragen gerade anfangen ich habe auch welche gefragt tickrate vom
server keine ahnung es wurde aber als wir in der fragerunde waren die die frage
gestellt ob jetzt durch die durch die weiterentwicklung der frostbite engine
so und die neue technik ist möglichkeiten gibt halt schneller und
besser maps zu machen und da wurde explizit hat auch gesagt
näher durch die neue möglichkeiten ja es ist halt es ist die möglichkeit
coolere und größere maps zu gestalten aber die brauchen natürlich auch wieder
zeit und manpower genau deswegen nimmt sich nicht viel nimmt sich sehr nicht
viel ja so habe ich das auch verstanden aber ist im prinzip ja logisch umso mehr
es ist ja generell wenn dir super game entwicklung anguckst klar du kannst jetzt
auch mit kleinen leuten richtig coole sachen erstellen die vorher dank dank
aktueller engines so was vorher nicht gegangen wäre aber dementsprechend im
detail grad steckt dann halt auch der der riesen auffang drin und wenn die maps
halt dann irgendwie vier mal größer ist fünf mal größer ist was auch immer wie
eine alte battlefield maps man kann ja nur wirklich nicht sagen dass sie nicht
detailliert und gut gemacht gewesen wären die alten battlefield maps
dann du musst ja auch so viel manuelle sachen setzen in battlefield es ist ja
gar nicht mal so dass in battlefield rein das terreur was du machst fertig ist
mit der map du musst da so viele dinge einbauen von wo brechen gebäude
auseinander ist ja immer die frage wie viel da wirklich von simuliert ist und
wie viel vorher schon festgelegt ist ja das gebäude kann bestimmte du kannst
ein gebäude wahrscheinlich nicht 100 prozent physik simuliert einschürzen
lassen weil es dann vielleicht irgendwelche
klitsches auf der maps map gibt dass die map nicht mehr spielbar ist weil das in
den tunneleingang rein liegt was es nicht darf oder oder irgendwas in der
richtung also da musst du sehr viele sachen machen und ich bin mir auch
sicher die müssen trägerpunkte setzen wo du wo du wie springanimationen teilweise
kommen das ist glaube ich verdammt viel arbeit so eine battlefield map zu machen
man sieht sie oft genug dass es auch manchmal klitscht gerade in battlefield 3
war das halt richtig krass wenn sie wenn du irgendwie halb halb durch den
fensterrahmen durch durch dich geworben hast weil du gesprungen bist dass da ist
viel arbeit drinne und dementsprechend ja kann ich eigentlich noch mal
unterstreichen unter und unterstreichen auch so als meiner sich aus meiner sicht
so als als programmierer entwickelt keine spiele aber bin auch ein bisschen
größeren software projekten beteiligt klar du kannst viel machen aber die
größe macht auch viel arbeit deswegen nimmt sich wahrscheinlich nicht so viel
genau dass es wohl war was ich da mal die nächste frage raushauen ich habe nicht
mehr als so viele also gab jetzt noch die frage haben wir wahrscheinlich schon
ein bisschen beantwortet ob wir wissen was es alles für fahrzeuge geben wird
also von von schiffen panzer helis flugzeuge ich kann dazu eigentlich nur
sagen ja also das gibt es gibt eigentlich alles gibt noch hovercraft
sachen gibt es noch gibt auch so osprey gunner und solche geschichten also die ich
würde mal sagen so umschreiben so die üblichen verdächtigen an fahrzeugen
ist noch da
holen mein mb you button hat ich wollte den zahlen nach haver noch mal kurz
wiederholen ich habe gesagt im prinzip die üblichen
verdächtigen sind wieder dabei plus noch ein bisschen future future zeug ist es
genau es ist noch ein bisschen also sie was man sagen kann ist auf jeden fall
dass sie versucht haben sich wirklich realitätsnah zu halten das muss man da
muss man wirklich schapo sagen also wir befinden uns nicht in dem battlefied
2143 sondern es ist battlefied 2042 das ist jetzt im endeffekt mehr oder weniger
20 jahre in der zukunft wenn man sich ein bisschen in dem militärbereich
unter auskennen unterwegs ist dann wird man sehen dass es schon diverse
prototypen gibt auch mit den hohen entwicklung sind genau das ist ja boston
dynamics waren sich das orientiert wo er auch schon test mit dem us-militär
laufen und ich sage mal so unnaiv die wahrscheinlichkeit sehr groß ist dass
in den nächsten 15 bis 20 jahren da halt auch neue sachen kommen die halt hier
jetzt aufgenommen wurden man muss es ja vergleichen battlefied 4 war ja im
endeffekt ich glaube das hat sogar 2020 damals ich glaube das ist jetzt gerade
ja genau und wenn du das jetzt mal vergleicht dann trifft das sehr gut zu
und das haben sie jetzt im endeffekt und deswegen auch homage wie ein bfb
finde ich cool hat wieder weitergebracht aber es ist eben nicht so dass du mit
irgendwelchen also wie zum beispiel final stand dsc b4 mit hovertanks rum
fährst oder eine rail gun hast ich weiß nicht was die sie technisch natürlich
hier im neuen dann noch kommt aber dass das gehen sie nicht deswegen das ist ein
das ist ein moderner modern kommets shooter der natürlich elemente hat die
halt glaube ich cool sind dass sie es integriert haben weil sie das gameplay
einfach noch ein bisschen in der einen möglichkeit dynamischer und
abwechslungsreicher machen als wenn du halt wieder nur modern kommet durch die
gegend läuft und das kannst du du wirst du wirst deine ak haben du wirst
deine m4 haben die heißen nicht unbedingt so und schauen vielleicht ein
bisschen anders aus aber wenn du dir wie gesagt ich habe letztes mal ein video
angeschaut zum beispiel von 6 sauer ist ja ist ja ein bekannter waffenhersteller
und das sind halt auch prototypen am start die in den nächsten jahren also in
massen oder teilweise jetzt dann in produktion gehen und die sehen ein
bisschen futuristischer aus aber sind jetzt kein phase aus star wars oder so
das ist halt der ganz normale werdegang alles was du gesehen hast ja ich weiß
ja zweiter wenn du überlegst vor vor vor 80 jahren zweiter weltkrieg das war
damals halt top das war top die high end technologie jetzt für uns ist das alter
kram ich meine in 100 jahren ist wahrscheinlich das was wir jetzt haben
alter kram deswegen man sollte sich dann nicht so
limitieren und sagen das ist mir zu futuristisch nein fun fact ist das ist
nicht die zukunft das ist zu einem großen teil aktuelle gegenwart und das
ist halt das finde ich einfach cool weil sie so diesen übergang schaffen von
modern mit leichten anhauchen futuristisch wie b4 richtig richtig aber
halt nicht nicht irgendwie laser abgespäßt das das das hat mich auch
ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen enttäuscht also ich habe muss ich musste ehrlich
sagen ich persönlich habe auch so was in der richtung gehofft also ich habe
erstens darauf gehofft dass es ein modern military setting ist und dass sie
jetzt gesagt haben okay wir verlegen das ganze noch 20 an die zukunft habe ich
so vorher nicht drüber nachgedacht ich habe mir gerade am coolsten wäre es wenn
es ist quasi jetzt zur aktuellen zeit spielen würde aber jetzt wo ich das
gesehen habe muss ich sagen dass das eigentlich das für mich perfekt ist
bis jetzt aussieht das für mich perfekte setting für das game ist einfach weil
es nicht exakt das gleiche ist aber es hat zu 80 prozent das was ich schon in
meinem kopf drinne hatte wie so ein modern military setting aussehen soll
plus halt noch die coolen sachen drum herum die du machen kannst wenn du das
ganze 20 jahre in die zukunft verlegst und du musst ja kein battlefield
viel remake machen im endeffekt ja die sollen was neues machen deswegen ist es
auch komplett in ordnung 20 jahre in zukunft ich finde das setting super das
passt und ich denke dass da was was ordentliches bei rauskommen kann jetzt
rein wenn man sich das setting anguckt rest ja gucken wir schluss wie du am
anfang eingangs auch schon gesagt hat es schlussendlich muss das gameplay
überzeugen dazu kann man nichts sagen weil man es nicht gespielt hat dass es
das wird das wird das wird in gewissen bete oder so dann möglich sein dann kann
man sich natürlich noch mal in urteil bilden aber fakt ist ich persönlich auch
dadurch dass wir durften das ja schon vor ein paar tage früher ja alles schon
sehen ich bin immer noch extra also mein hype
level was ich über die hochen aufgebaut habe wo ich noch nicht diese
informationen hatte wie wir sie jetzt haben hat sich hat sich nicht
verkleinert sondern sondern ist sogar noch gestiegen und ich bin guter dinge
dass wir einen shooter bekommen der den mut zumindest den multiplayer markt was
was multiplayer shooter angeht ein stück weit neu definiert und und auf den
kopf stellen wird gerade halt das auf genau dass das halt gerade auch mal in
rett das in battlefield auch in battlefield sein will finde ich halt
gut man sieht die inspiration von den anderen titeln ganz klar keine frage
aber man merkt dass es im kern in battlefield ist und dass es auch in
battlefield sein soll und ich bin jetzt gar nicht sicher ich suche gerade auf dem
benad steht irgendwo an beta wann beta startet
beta beta termin gibt es nicht aber also was offiziell ja schon announced wurde
das ist halt das release datum ist ja am 22 oktober für vorbesteller glaube ich
am 15 ich weiß nicht ob jeder vorbestellten glaube jeder vorbestellten
abhängig davon welche version es gibt ja wieder verschiedene versionen wo du
dir zusätzlich wenn du ich glaube bis zu 120 euro wenn er wollt macht aber ja
du hast halt die season pass drin du hast halt dann cosmetics drin das muss
jeder selber für sich entscheiden aber ich glaube bei jeder ist dann der
fünfzente drin das heißt du kannst fünf tage vorher schon spielen so wie es
aussieht und das ist cool weil es war ja es wurde ja angekündigt dass es im
zeitraum zwischen oktober und december rauskommt ich habe ja tatsächlich auf
anfang november getippt jetzt ist es ein bisschen früher so verkehrt warst du
jetzt nicht also das ist schon ist schon im rahmen ich finde es natürlich ganz
geil ich hätte auch kein problem jetzt ein
bisschen wenn es erst im mitte november oder so kommt weil halb bleibt halb aber
so kannst du es halt mitte oktober wenn du vorbestellst halt schon spielen und
das ist halt cool weil es ist eine absehbare ist ein absehbarer zeitraum
weiß es ist nicht mehr so lang ja es ist eigentlich auch wirklich nicht mehr so
lang hin wenn du jetzt guckst es ist jetzt juni juni ok monat ein monat
juli 2 august september und dann ist oktober also fünf monate ungefähr ja
ich habe mir da schon so einen plan zurecht gelegt also ich ich ich versuche
gerade gameplay technisch und game technisch einfach bis zu bis zum start
von new world durchzuhalten dann das soll ja irgendwie am ende kommt ja am
zwanzig kommt sogar auch um 20 oder 22
und dann und dann und dann damit halt zwei monate irgendwie spiel Spaß zu
haben was ja mehr oder weniger in anführungsstrichen in die mmo richtung
ja geht und dann rüber zu gehen weißt du dann zu bettel viel teil das war nicht
dass du nicht irgendwie wieder so eine so eine flaute hast was games angeht das
ist so mein masterplan gut ist für dich natürlich auch stream technisch
wichtig ja klar das auf jeden fall auch ich klar jetzt wenn man das so sieht
hat man natürlich bock im nächsten stream dann einfach noch mal wieder die
alten teile auch noch mal reinzuschmeißen zwischendurch kommt ja
noch eine beta ohne nda genau es wird eine beta geben mit
sicherheit die man auch wieder streamen kann und auch der sage ich mal der
autonormal dude natürlich da auch mit reinkommt vielleicht gibt es auch
wieder natürlich alpha technisch was klar das ist ja immer im battlefield
universum so der fall gewesen ja vielleicht haben wir glück aber ja ja
dürften auch vielleicht auch mal anfassen ja weiß ja nicht na ja 7 oktober
konfer krei guck mal ja dann kann ich noch schnell die 12 stunden kampagne
durchspielen den online also den den rest ist halt irgendwie 200 stunden
außen außen posten einnehmen und dann kannst du zu bettel viel gehen
das ist ja weiß dass wir gerade einfeld wenn du sagst was sagt du kommst
raus 23 27 oktober 22 oktober ok hat man schon irgendwas zum diesjährigen
call of duty gehört wann das kommt das soll ja wohl vor 2 werden man weiß es
nicht da gab es glaube ich doch ich habe also ich habe mal ich habe das nicht
wirklich verfolgt muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen ich habe nur mal gehört dass
irgendwie gestruggelt haben ja dass es irgendwie verschoben wurde und dann
habe ich aber noch mal was gehört dass es jetzt doch also dass dieses ja gar
keins rauskommen soll ja das habe ich auch gehört das glaube ich aber nicht
dass also das glaube ich erst wenn ich sehe dass da nix rauskommt dieses jahr
aber ja und dann dass halt dass halt das aber aber also no joke wie gesagt ich
habe beides serien gespielt ich kann beiden was abgewinnen
der multiplayer mich langfristig immer im battlefield mehr angehuckt gerade in
den älteren teilen ich meine call of duty hat mit worsen natürlich den
unabhängig davon was man von dem gameplay hält mit den ganzen mit problemen
dass es aber doch hat haben sie aber den absoluten nagel auf den kopf getroffen
oder wie man sagt das bietet halt mehr langfristigkeit was bettel royal ist
die haben alles damit mehr oder weniger alles richtig gemacht für sich als
firma aber ich sag es wie es ist auch wenn ich zweiter weltkrieg fan bin und
world war zu gefeiert habe also das erste also die ersten teile von
korn auf den gab es ja noch mal wurde war und dann gab es ja noch mal zweiten
weltkrieg danach noch mal aufguss ja noch mal brauche ich jetzt ein ich brauche
es auch nicht noch mal aber worauf brauche ich eigentlich drauf raus
glaube ich weiß dass da raus die hardcore cod leute ja klar weiß
war so ein update ok vielleicht drei ja aber ja genau was das ist ja das ding
leute spielen hat das war so ein update die spiel weißt du was das sorry ich
will es muss jetzt los weißt du was das lustige am call of duty multiplayer
mittlerweile ist die leute spielen den multiplayer nicht mehr um call of duty
multiausnahmen bestätigen die regel aber die leute spielen den call of duty
multiplayer zum anlocken und freispielen von worson waffen die sind die haben
alle keinen bock mehr die machen sie sind pass multi xp machen die an 24
jugtau und 24 schippen wer spielt denn freiwillig schippen schippen ist vom
gameplay die beschissenste map aller zeiten das hat der praktikant in der
middagspause beim kacken erstellt schippen weißt du das ist so was was du was du
in einem level editor machst und im tutorial da kommt schippen draus so die
leute das spielen die leute das heißt die können diesen multiplayer nicht für
spaß spielen die spielen den multiplayer zum anlocken für worson und scheißen
drauf das ist so true ganz ehrlich wenn man hart ist könnte man behaupten
call of duty förder kinderarbeit weil was sie da betreiben ist wirklich
arbeit das neue update kommt raus okay mann ich muss call of duty spielen ich
muss die waffen freischalten
24 sieben schippen um alles freigeschalten macht gar keinen spaß die
rachel rein jede woche mit mindestens eine tastatur in einem mausbüro und
controller kaputt um danach maximal halt worson zu spielen und auf der anderen
seite hast du halt dann noch die leute und da habe ich respekt finde ich cool
weil die haben sich auch das ist auch ein großer markt glaube ich im call of duty
hat sich halt so diese zombie community hat entwickelt jetzt versuchen immer
weiterzukommen also dass im endeffekt aktuell hat call of duty zombie die
hardcore zombie leute dann hast du die leute die halt einfach arbeiten gehen
in call of duty wo sie wahrscheinlich viele von denen das alter nicht dafür
haben das noch schon zu dürfen und die hat dann zwangsweise worson spielen ja
es ist echt es ist echt der wahnsinn aber rachel gibt es überall
ich hab mir letztens ein kollega auf der arbeit erzählt er kann heute kein
homeoffice machen weil sein sohn hat den monitor kaputt gemacht beim fortnite
spielen der war dann am händi da musste den ganzen tag über über smartphone
dann irgendwas richtig also da wird es ja dann konsequenzen geben hey krass wenn
dein kleiner halt wirklich durch ein computerspiel hat sachen kaputt macht
also dann da musste dann also da bin ich da kann ich verstehen dass man dann in
frage stellt was diese computerspiele mit uns zum achten aber das natürlich
immer abhängig davon wer das so tut aber ja also ich muss dir ehrlich sagen ich
habe noch nie also ich habe mich auch schon übelst aufgeregt beim spielen aber
ich glaube mehr als mal irgendwo dagegen gehauen oder im zweifelsfall mal ein
controller runter geschmissen oder so ich habe es nie passiert ja mir auch
nicht ist nichts kaputt gegangen durch durch durch irgendwie mutwillige
zerstörungen wird auch ganz schön teuer wenn ich hier einfach durch den monitor
durchschlage das muss nicht sein krass aber du musst mal überlegen wir haben
jetzt also gut wir rechnen jetzt ein bisschen runter aber wir mit man
könnte behaupten so wird du bei dir erst und ich bei mir und dann ist zusammen
haben wir jetzt gerade glaube ich drei stunden lang über über den neuen teil
geredet ja und ich würde mal behaupten das war das zu battle feed 5 slash 1 nicht
hat man nicht gemacht und ich glaube es gab einen grund auch dafür warum man
das nicht gemacht hat weil man hätte genau so gut tun können
beta gerade nach dem richtig richtig haben wir nicht haben wir haben damals
auch was zusammen aufgenutzt weil keiner einer fragt wann kommt die beta wissen
wir nicht und es gab eben noch eine interessante frage ob wir nur schon
mehr wissen als wir jetzt preis geben dürfen ja tun wir wir haben noch wie
gesagt wir hatten in fq noch mit da ist und wir haben noch ein gameplay trailer
gesehen dazu haben sie aber gesagt dürfen wir auch erst ab 13 13 ja chat wir
haben es schon gesehen was am 13 kommst ja wobei wobei ja gut lasse es
sein näher aber was was was was wir dadurch sagen können ist dass wir noch
mehr informationen haben und wahrscheinlich natürlich jetzt ich also
die ein oder anderen informationen die woche natürlich noch kommen mit
sicherheit also ich denke mal bei dir wahrscheinlich auch ich werde auch das
eine andere machen ja genau und da habt ihr entweder noch mal recaps als über
das was wir jetzt besprochen haben aber natürlich auch noch mal detail also
wo man einfach ins detail gegangen ist und spätestens wenn der gameplay trailer
am was ist das ist das sonntag ja sonntag getroppt ist wird danach werden wir
danach können wir gerne uns wieder zusammen hocken wenn wir danach noch mal
darüber sprechen und es wird natürlich noch mal mehr details gerade was das
gameplay angeht ja und wir müssen uns auch keine gedanken mehr machen wir
müssen ja teilweise hier bei jedem zweiten satz überlegen so aber wenn wo
war das jetzt bestandteil von von dem aktuellen von dem was am 13 kommt dann
können wir wirklich komplett alles erzählen dann müssen wir uns keine
gedanken mehr machen genau aber das ist ja ganz wichtig zu
erwähnen man weiß natürlich nicht alles und es ist offensichtlich noch noch
einiges auf dass man sich halb also auch wir uns hypen können was halt noch
kommen wird unter anderem auch spätestens am 22 juli auf der ea play das
ist ja so ein datum das können wir sogar noch erzählen da wird der neue also
diese diese drei säulen von von battlefield mit all out warfare
es hat so und und einem geheimen der kein royal ist gar nicht gesagt das haben
die doch so gar nicht gesagt die haben gesagt hazard zone ist definitiv kein
battle royal und zu dem nächsten spiel modus haben gesagt kein kommentar aber
es wird etwas sein was für alle battlefield veteranen ganz toll ist so
nach dem motto ja aber es also sie haben ja auf jeden fall sie haben auf jeden fall
schon bestätigt dass battle royale nicht geplant ist mit 20 42 bisher also es
gab es habe ich von kurz erzählt es gab zwei aussagen da war ich extrem
hellhörig aber beim ersten mal nachdem die frage auf kam wurde gesagt zum
launch und das war die trigger ward zum launch ist kein battle royale modus
geplant das habe ich gehört es kam später weil die mehrfach kamen und ich
weiß nicht ob der der der dudes die kommentar die die fragen gestellt hat
dass nicht mehr so auf dem schirm hatte die frage kam noch mal auf weil sie
mehrfach gestellt wurde und daraufhin hat der gleiche der das mit dem launch
gesagt hat gemeint in battlefield 42 20 42 ist also ich weiß nicht aus dem
englischen aber bisher gesagt hat aber ist battle royale modus nicht geplant
okay haben wir jetzt so interpretieren sie wollen es gar nicht machen kann man
aber auch so interpretieren von wegen gerade mit dieser at launch dass sie
sich halt offen lassen es kann sein dass das vielleicht erst in
dem jahr kommt wenn man auch mal sieht was bei apex was ja der ea battle royale
titel sozusagen ist der sehr sehr sehr gut läuft auch finanziell für die hat
man beim letzten finales comment bekommen da auch nicht ewig weitergehen
wird ich hoffe natürlich sie lassen sich offen ich kann es mir nicht
vorstellen dass sie sich entgehen lassen ich kann es mir einfach nicht vorstellen
was sein könnte ist dass sie ist dass sie halt quasi sagen hey wir machen quasi
unsere neu interpretation von battle royale dementsprechend nennen wir es
nicht bettel royale sondern setze ichs beliebiges ja vielleicht ist es ja auch
so was also squad basiert nur dass es halt mit dem twist keine ahnung aber ich
gehe davon aus es muss also sagen streichen wir mal battle royale streich
immer bettel aber es wird es kann ich mir nicht anders vorstellen in free to
play teil kommen von dem spiel es kann die frage fun fact die frage kam auf ob
es einem free to play battle royale teil geben wird wahrscheinlich in bezug auf
man hat nicht das wort br genommen smartphone im jeweiligen der die frage
gestellt hat wenn er die intention dafür hatte und meines wissens nach ich glaube
also ich bin mir zu 98 prozent sicher dass noch in kopf zu haben wurde da auch
da haben sie gesagt wir können dazu nichts sagen aber im laufe der nächsten
monate bis zum release werden wir natürlich zum spiel entsprechend
diverse informationen noch droppen was auch wieder heißt nicht ja oder nicht
ein heißt vielleicht also es ist ja irgendwas also sie haben gesagt so ein
fan favorite und es kann ja nicht rush sein weil das würde eigentlich sein
eigentlich ein segment genau ja also es muss ja irgendwas gravierendes sein was
eine säule bildung komplett anders ist genau das muss das muss so was sein das
muss so was sein wie gesagt selbst wenn es kein bettel royale ist ich glaube
man kann wir so ein spiel langfristig tatsächlich nur noch machen wenn du
zumindest eine komponente free to play dabei hast also wenn die das wirklich
vorhaben service game technisch zu betreiben für 2 3 je nachdem wie gut es
läuft rainbow 6 ist jetzt auch das vierte jahr oder so ist ja auch schon
ewig ewig am start du brauchst irgendwie gut rainbow 6 ein schlechtes
beispiel das glaube ich auch kein free to play aber ich glaube du brauchst für
das und auch dass du die spielerzahlen hochhalten kann sein du brauchst
irgendeine free to play komponente dabei irgendwas die leute buddender mega kohle
rein ja auch weißt du weißt du was weißt du was gerade ein guter kommentar
war den ich den ich einfach komplett mit den ganzen dopamin den ich in den
letzten tagen hatte komplett ausgeblendet habe in bezug auf bettel royale deswegen
grüße gehen raus und danke für den da sieht man das ist ja wieder das
betriebsblundheit ne wo war denn hier das darüber habe ich gar nicht nachgedacht
stimmt das ist ja auch weil sie ja marketing technisch gesagt haben ja
können wir nicht zu sagen hier klingt ein bisschen so als würde das bettel
royale einfach ausgeklinkt werden aus 2042 was er im endeffekt war so und
genauso gemacht hat es ist nicht nur warfare es ist der war so und einfach
als eigenständiges free to play und dann können sie natürlich sagen ja im
rabel von 2042 kommt kein bettel royale was er nicht heißt dass ein free to play
game was irgendwie halt dann anders heißt gab es da nicht sogar gerüchte gab es
da nicht sogar gerüchte im free to play battlefield ja das das wird es
wahrscheinlich sein das wird sein ja das ergibt das ergibt echt sind ja und
und mobile battlefield soll noch kommen ja das brauche ich natürlich
unbedingt 22 das ist ja gottseidig eigenständig aber wie du sagst also ich
bin gespannt was an der ea play wie da werden wir also wir werden so ist
gestartet ea play fun fact wird ja dieser dritte säule dieser fan favorite was
auch immer sein wird am schluss kommt battlefield heroes 2.0 oder so
irgendwas kommt da was scheinbar veteranen und favorite ist von ich aber
ich saß auch da und denke mir so ich habe 20 jahre lang battlefield gespielt
was außer modus was kann da sein ich habe kurz gedacht der titan modus aber
das wäre auch wieder war eher ja aber packen die dann den modus an sich in
den eigenen spielbereich i don't know ich meine die haben in den
menus von battlefield 5 und 1 in den menus kannst du ja auch über die
schnellauswahl einfach auswählen so so presets kannst du auch conquest und
durchbruch oder pacific und hast du halt die ganzen pacific max wenn sie so an
die sache herangehen können sie natürlich sagen wir packen den titan
modus rein also ein eigenständiges ding ist ja ich glaube nicht dass es das
sein wird weil die haben das so angekündigt hier ich das wollte ich
gerade sagen sowas in der richtung kann ich mir nämlich tatsächlich vorstellen
die haben ja gesagt das wird was sein was auch gerade alle ältere
battlefield oder leute die langzeit schon dabei sind ansprechen soll das
heißt das kann ich einfach nur in den battlefield 2042 spielmodus sein ich
gehe mal davon aus das sind ich vermute mal das sind wahrscheinlich so so
legacy maps und und alte charaktere aus alten games und sowas
das ist metro 128 leute 24 24 7 metro oder 28 24 7 metro 128 leute auf der
krankengröße von ursprünglich metro und da musst du dann unten im
kleingedrückten schreiben oder wird dann hingeschrieben so in jeder runde metro
stirbt real life ein mensch vor dem pc weil einfach einen kompletten anstand
ist gesehen kommt wahrscheinlich hin wenn die das wirklich machen ja das
gefährlichste spiel der welt kommt dann irgendwo ja voll scheiß auf resin
wien oder so herzinfarkt in metro 128 leute allein schon eine epilepsie warnung
pur ja aber das kann echt sein dass sie so sachen machen wie sie bringen
einfach karaktere aus alten teil ich bin übrigens der erste der sich so einen so
einen bett company 2 medic skin holt mit der roten mütz kennst du den noch
mit dieser beret beret ist das doch oder so mütze diese diese das war das war
russische ne ne ne das war russische das war in der russischen medic wc2 hatte
doch diese rote mütze aber schauen so diese diese flach diese rüber hängen
irgendwie so ich weiß ich weiß ich weiß nicht wie es genau jetzt glaube ich
barrette ich glaube die mützen form könnte so heißen ja kann sein dass aber
sowas könnten die echt machen die nehmen die machen einfach alte karten
und alte alte skins und sonst wie und bauen das so quasi so als zusätzlichen
zusätzlichen spielmodus quasi für für die leutein und es passt auch zu dem was
du in unserem video gesagt hast du sagtest ja bald ist ja auch bettel viel
20 jahre da würde sowas auch richtig krass gut zu passen ja quer durch die
history quasi bettel viel das das ist genau das weiß gerade immer noch
geschrieben hat das hatte ich damals schon mal erwähnt ich glaube ich hab
ein video geredet dass mal das gerücht aufkam dass er so einen hub bauen wollen
angeblich das wurde dann das wurde einerseits geleakt aber andere leaker
haben das dementiert das war leak was sozusagen dass sie halt so einen hub auf
bauen wo du angeblich bettel viel bettel kompany gegen bettel viel drei auf auf
auf in dem modus spielen kannst und dann die waffen und die charaktere von
den bettel vieles hättest was komisches war ja auch die bettel viel
bekomme die konnte sich zum beispiel nicht hinlegen
ich hoffe auch nicht dass das kommt weil ganz ehrlich ich glaube der modus also
ich würde auch zu viel zu viele leute aus den aber so wie du sagst ich kann mir
vorstellen dass sie da halt homagen homage an alte teile bringen und
entweder sind entweder sind maps oder irgendwie oder oder modus der hat dann
irgendwie mit mit mit so wie du sagst charakteren gespicktes irgendwie ist
i don't know aber das das finde ich ganz cool weil da bin ich wirklich ich klar
ich habe zu die vermutung vielleicht ist es ein modus wie zum beispiel teiten
modus der so ein alleinstellungsmerkmal bekommt bettel royal wird es
wahrscheinlich jetzt erstmal nicht sein was uns setzen sie außer sie haben uns
richtig hart gebetet und denken sich was gezeigt und auf der anderen seite kann
es aber auch sein dass halt so ja das ist so ein ich meine wenn es free to
play modus wäre wäre es wird nicht funktionieren weil das ja im spiel ist
ja genau ich bin gespannt also ich tippe dass es irgendwie so ein
so ein ding ist wie wie der teiten modus aber wenn es das nicht ist bin ich echt
wo ich sage da bin ich wirklich gespannt weil da könnte ich echt erwischen so
offen so so so überraschen sowohl in positiven weisen negativ wobei ganz
ehrlich also ich meine das das base game an sich muss taugen das ist wichtig
das genau das das ist unglaublich wichtig das war halt das gute in
battle field 3 und bettel viel am anfang hatte viele bugs das spiel hatte den
brutalsten halb überhaupt von jedem battle field game am anfang aufgebaut
battle field 3 das kam raus und es war halt auch gut das muss halt das muss das
halt auch zeigen dass es gut dass ein gutes game ist aller hype bringt nix wenn
die leute anfangen zu spielen und feststellen ist ja kacke und dann ist
es nach einem monat weg
ja was ich ganz cool finde ist dass da muss ich auch da muss ich auch fairerweise
sagen oder ehrlicherweise sagen das wusste ich auch bevor wir die infos
hatten wann das gelben der gameplay reveal ist habe ich schon vermutet dass
wahrscheinlich zur xbox präsentation gameplay kommen könnte
ja war ja in der fangung halt auch mit xboxen so immer wieder was gemacht hat
thematisch auch gut ja und das hat sich jetzt bestätigt das heißt dazu sehen wir
uns auf jeden fall spätestens nur weil ich es jetzt gerade im check gelesen
habe was ist das was ist das deutsche zeit ich bin so scheiße in
conversions ich glaube 18 19 uhr oder so aber was meinst du gleich ja die xbox
ding ist am sonntag 19 uhr geht die los das können wir gucken das passt ja das
wird wahrscheinlich also ich gucke ist die frage darf man streamen nicht so wie
bei apple ja ob man geappelt wird veräppelte leute ich habe es euch ja noch
gar nicht erzählen wobei ich kann sein ich habe einen copyright strike auf
twitch weil ich mich ertreistet habe das letzte public apple event zu streamen
und mein senf dazu zu geben ich weiß nichts ich habe echt keine ahnung warum
sowas noch gestricked für 2021 aber apple ist da halt er schon immer
besonders gewesen kostenlose werbung für apple gemacht und wurde es dafür
gestricked also ja es ist schon absurd ne also als ich das gehört habe dachte
ich mir was ich werde ich verstehe es auch nicht natürlich nicht apple selbst
sondern irgendeine anwaltskanzlei diese vertreten im endeffekt das dumme ist
jetzt halt du hast nicht wirklich eine chance das willst du großartig machen
das ist natürlich schon berechtigt die haben die rechte dran du kannst jetzt
auch nach dem sein anwaltkanzlei ist nicht einfach mal eine nette mail
hinschreiben so nach dem motto sorry leute mache ich nie wieder das wird ich
sagen ja leck mich juckt mich nicht was wenn juckt weißt du ist mir egal also
und bei twitch ist halt das dumme strikes verfallen nicht auf youtube ist
nach 90 tagen wenn du die copyright school machst ist es weg ja was soll ich
machen ja um ganz kurz das thema kurz zu switchen aber da siehst du einfach mal
was wie youtube halt der ganzen sache halt schon jahre voraus ist ich meine
zuletzt natürlich mit den musik rechten die ja vor ein paar monaten und jetzt
auch aktuell wieder auf kam es kam wieder eine runde mail auf twitch noch mal weil
wieder die jetzt paar leute geklämt wurden es kommt ja immer so ein bisschen
wellen youtube ist der zeit voraus du kannst ich kann ich könnte in dem
battle feed video halt einfach ac dc ballern bis zum umfallen
den einzigen nachteil nicht davon habe ist dass ich wahrscheinlich so laut
einstellen was ein banger ist dass man meine stimme nicht mehr hört und dass
ich kein ad revenue davon bekommen aber du kannst es halt machen weil youtube
das halt so geregelt hat und zweifelsfall wird schon geplogged wenn du es
hochlädt hast du früher schon nicht nicht jetzt mit upload filtern erstes ist
ja schon lange so die sagen einfach hier ihr video ist nicht mehr verfügbar aber
kein strike sondern einfach runter genommen genau und das ist halt so cool
weil du einfach ein sicherheitssystem das musst du auch machen ich meine
viele leute beschäftigen sich da nicht auch nicht damit ich meine die viele der
content creator draußen die sind halt noch nicht mal volljährige kannst du
nicht erwarten dass ich da voll ausgehen und wie du sagst ab 90 tagen wenn du
halt das ist ja so dieses fingerhau rauf hauen wenn du dich entsprechend gut
benommen hast 90 tage überlebt hast dann bist du halt auch wieder safe bei
youtube er bei twitch da da bist halt nach drei strikes und tschüss
ich meine ob du jetzt ob man jetzt als partner noch irgendwie möglichkeiten
hat sehe ich eher schwierig bei diesen hat mir auch die hände gebunden die
werden bei dem team stellen die hauen weg und das war es weil die übernehmen
die übernehmen keine verantwortung das einzige wo du vielleicht glück haben
könntest sie sind ja da grad hart dran die hat es ja bei twitch auch letztes
jahr kann ich sagen überraschend getroffen aber das war ja da hat ein
riesen welle geschlagen auch dank corona jetzt auch die ganzen plattenfirmen und
alle auf twitch aufmerksam geworden sind da kommt ja eigentlich ursprünglich her
sonst vorher hat sich kein mensch für twitch da interessiert bei denen und dass
die dass die bei twitch das halt jetzt insofern immer weiter verbessern und
wenn man glück hat irgendwann auch mal vielleicht so was einführen dass du
sagen kannst hey beim ersten strike musst du halt noch mal so einen
copyright lehrgang machen und dann machst test und hast verstanden und dann
ist das strike wieder weg ansonsten ja ich meine muss ich jetzt halt aufpassen
die scheiße ist halt dass das alles so so krautzone ist was man da macht wenn man
es genau nimmt wer hätten wir das wahrscheinlich heute auch nicht streamen
dürfen ohne da irgendwie super super genehmigung mit unterschrift zu haben
ja ich habe das alles ohne ich habe es ja vorhin kurz erzählt dass ich schon
mitbekommen habe dass leute wirklich auch nachgefragt haben und eine absage
bekommen haben also dass nicht streamen durften und ich kann jetzt schlussendlich
auch nicht hundertprozentig sagen ob das ob wir jetzt wirklich eine exklusiv
da jetzt kommen haben oder ob sie da hätte streamen können ich meine wir
sind zumindest safe weil wir die offizielle ja also wirklich offiziell nicht
nur von irgendeiner agentur oder so sondern wirklich von ea selber lied die
haben gesagt watch party macht ja watch parties fein und wir werden kommen auch
nicht ins youtube gefängnis das heißt wir sind das safe aber natürlich kann
sein dass andere halt wirklich potenziell nicht dass das sein muss aber potenziell
hätten probleme haben können und wir haben das nicht deswegen konnten wir das
hier zeigen ja genau hat es auch keinen sinn sich da weiter großartig drüber
drüber aufzuregen vielleicht habe ich glück und irgendwas das ding mal weg
ansonsten tja muss ich aufpassen jetzt haben wir aber ordentlich content raus
gehauen hier jetzt haben wir ordentlich konnte aber es war nice war echt nice hat
mich auch schon letztens wahnsinnig gefreut dass wir mit einem video gemacht
haben richtig coole geschichte habe ich ich habe gar nicht gemerkt wie ich so
dual laberkram vermisst haben über battlefield habe ich ewig nicht mal
gemacht war auf jeden fall leist und jetzt auch jeder battlefield talk sehr
coole sache jetzt muss was futtern gleich mal hab übelst
ja ja gut was machst du jetzt noch irgendwie stream technisch weiter ich guck mal also ich bin jetzt
seit 15 oder so ein bisschen also vielleicht bin ich bis 20 uhr noch hier sein dann werde ich
duschen gehen wahrscheinlich mit dem mit dem hype abwaschen ich kann ich meine pumpen erheizung ist
kaputt diesort morgen verreckt ja gut aber so eine kühle dusche ist doch jetzt genau richtig ja gut
vielleicht noch ein bisschen warm aber ich denke mal wir werden sobald es neue sachen gibt können
wir noch mal schauen genau ich mein spätestens spätestens wie gesagt zum zum microsoft event
werden wir uns können wir uns gerne on stream noch mal zusammensetzen um dann noch mal game
gameplay technisch bezogene sachen zu besprechen auf die wir jetzt nur nicht eingehen können weil
wir dürfen weil wir nicht dürfen oder halt auch nichts wissen ich mein wie gesagt wir wissen
jetzt auch noch nicht alles aber wer weiß was überraschung vielleicht gibt es am 13 noch
was was wir noch nicht gesehen haben kann ich mir vorstellen sie haben da so sehr drauf bestanden
dass das alles noch in der entstehung ist das kann sein dass jeder dinger sieht wo wir keine
ahnung von haben wunderbar hat mir sehr viel spaß gemacht ebenfalls hat mich gefreut und
läuft einfach genau flutscht spätestens am 13 wieder und wahrscheinlich gibt es sicherlich
die ein oder anderen themen zwischendurch wo wir dann auch mal in videoform uns verewigen werden
auf youtube also guckt guckt beim lost mal vorbei die leute bei mir und wenn ihr bei mir vorbei
gucken würdet hätte ich natürlich auch nichts dagegen kann ich kann ich natürlich nur zurückgeben
auf jeden fall max fps max mit vier max ist mit vier mit vier lead speech ja hacker man
jix fps wahrscheinlich haben sie weiß leute schon mal irgendwann irgendwo gesehen hoffe ich
ja ich glaube aber auch wenn du es so eingibst dann kriegst du trotzdem den ganzen kanal oder
wenn es nicht mit der vier eingeben ja ja glaube ich kriegst du auch Leute schon gesucht hast
schon im zeitverfahren sucht ihr einfach nach battlefield reveal german oder sowas auf youtube
da wenn unsere videos denken kann nicht weit oben sein ja kanns im keks guckst du nach dem
keks der chat als nächstes dual mit dr. kabu ich glaube das ist abgefahren erst mal vorbei wir
können mal gucken vielleicht können wir uns doch irgendeinen der alten bettel viel leute ich weiß
nicht wenn er noch am start ist ob sie in eck war oder irgendwie noch gibt vielleicht finden wir
noch irgendeiner mit labern will können wir mal gucken ansonsten sehen wir uns am 13 wieder
dann machen wir den den roundtable zu battlefield genau alles da wünsche ich dir noch einen schönen
abend auf jeden fall dir und deinen leuten wünschen wir dir auch her wir hören uns dann alles klar war
es gut bis denn so leute nice echt hat mir mega bock gemacht und ich habe hunger as fuck ich
glaube ich gehe jetzt essen ich kommt mal kurz was youtube ich guck mal kurz in youtube rein was
da was da so abgeht was geht denn auf youtube bei mir ab ich kann nicht mehr schreiben leute
ich hoffe euch hat das stream gefallen war heute mal ein bisschen was anderes wir haben uns da jetzt
nun wirklich äußerst ausführlich drüber ausgelassen ausgelassen ich habe auch fast alles
weil ich habe darauf geachtet ich habe zwar 50 fragen aufgeschrieben aber wir sind da so wild
durch wir haben alles wir haben alles durch spielmodi haben wir durch kampagne haben wir durch
battle pass haben wir durch commander haben wir durch maps haben wir durch konsole alt versus
neue neue frostbite battle royale waffen pickups haben wir alles irgendwie durch also ich glaube
wir haben es zum größten teil schon hingekriegt auf jeden fall eine gute idee dass wir uns das
vor aufgeschrieben haben und ja was soll ich jetzt noch sagen hast du alles von den ea assets
gezeigt ja wunderbar sehr nice also ich hauste den lost jetzt einfach wobei er hat gemeint er
geht oft na ist da frasier am start vielleicht heute ist er live ne das ist gemütet da gehe
ich jetzt furtern heute wir sehen uns und spätestens am 13 aber wahrscheinlich sehen
wir uns auch schon am freitag aber da machen wir wieder technik kram müssen wir mal schauen
ich habe ich bin ja immer noch am überlegen ob ich mal einen streaming kalender machen sollte
wo ich halt nur die termine eintrage wo ich weiß dass ich da bin also ich werde keinen
regelmäßigen streaming kalender machen weil werde ich nicht einhalten ihr kennt mich am
13 2 streams da ist ja aufwachen zum jahr dann zwei streams warum nicht also leute wir sehen
uns macht's gut äußerst leiser stream bis denn wir sehen uns zu